MORNING THANKS FOR BEING HERE
WE'RE GONNA BEGIN THIS JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE AND THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WE ALSO
HAVE WITH US TODAY THE CHAIR OF
THE GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMITTEE MISS BETWEEN OUR S.
AND I'LL BEGIN BY SHARING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STEPS
WE'RE TAKING TO PRESERVE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE AND TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO
THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. TO
ENSURE EMBERS OF THE MEDIA AND
PUBLIC ACCESS TO OUR PROCEEDINGS
TODAY THE HEARING WILL BE
STREAMED ON THE ASSEMBLY'S
WEBSITE AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CAN PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
PERSON HERE IN OR FORTY TWO OR
TWO. OR VIA THE PHONE. EVERYONE
IN THE CAPITAL MUST CONTINUE TO
WEAR MASKS AND IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH WE DO HAVE THEM FOR
YOU. FOR ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM
PRESENT WE ARE REQUIRING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. PLEASE
FOLLOW THE DIRECTIONS ARE
SERGEANTS AND THE POSTED
GUIDANCE YOU'LL SEE THROUGHOUT
THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM IS ON THE
AGENDA TO TESTIFY OR WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY DURING
PUBLIC COMMENTS PORTION OF THE
AGENDA I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. A COPY OF THE
AGENDA AND BACKGROUND MATERIALS
ARE AVAILABLE ON BOTH THE
COMMITTEES WEBSITES. FOR THOSE
WHO WANT TO JOIN US VIA
TELEPHONE WE WILL BE USING THE
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANYONE CAN PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
AGENDA. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THE HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE PAIN IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. PLEASE CALL IN ON WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE LAST WITNESS ON
OUR AGENDA WE'LL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THAT TIME. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE WHICH INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST
AND YOUR DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND ISSUES. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE LINE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AND NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
SIX FOR HELP AND THAT
INFORMATION IS ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS WELL.
FINALLY I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND
FLOOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS. AND WEEKS. WE WILL
ENSURE ALL VOICES ARE HEARD
HOWEVER CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE HEARING
IS PROHIBITED. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO EVERYONE'S PEACEFUL
PARTICIPATION TODAY. WITH THAT I
WANT TO OPEN BY THIS IS MY FIRST
COMMITTEE TEARING HEARING
CHAIRING THE WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE AND WITHOUT I
WANT TO THANK THE SPEAKER FOR
ENTRUSTING ME WITH THE IMPORTANT
WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE- AND MY
VICE CHAIR WHO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THIS WEEK EMBARK ON
THIS JOURNEY. AND ALSO COMMITTEE
STAFF WHO WORK INCREDIBLY HARD
TO PREPARE FOR TODAY'S HEARING
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
PANEL OF EXPERTS ON THIS SUBJECT
THAT WILL PROVIDE US WITH GOOD
INFORMATION MOVING FORWARD. I
WANT TO WELCOME OUR WITNESSES TO
THE HEARING AND THANK THEM FOR
COMING TO DISCUSS SIGMAR THIS
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT IN THIS
PROCEEDING. TODAY AS WE ALL KNOW
WE'RE FACING YOU'RE REALLY
SIMILAR CONDITIONS TO THAT IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHEN SIGNAL WAS
PASSED. WE'RE EXPERIENCING A
THIRD CONSECUTIVE DRY YEAR AFTER
OUR SECOND DRIEST YEAR ON RECORD
JUST LAST YEAR. WE CAME OUT OF
OUR LAST ROUND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHICH IS CALIFORNIA'S MOST OF
YOUR ON RECORD AND WE THOUGHT IT
WOULDN'T HAPPEN AGAIN SO SOON.
WE HAD A BEAUTIFUL SNOWY AND
RAINY FALL AND THOUGHT THIS
WOULD BE A GOOD YEAR AND HERE WE
ARE WITH LITTLE TO NO RAIN.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE NUMBER THAT WE TALK ABOUT
ALL THE WAYS IN WHICH WE MANAGE
OUR WATER AND ENSURE THAT WE ARE
IN A GOOD POSITION DESPITE OUR
ONGOING DROUGHTS. WE HAVE TO GET
SIGNAL RIGHT. AND WE NEED TO
EXPEDITIOUSLY IMPLEMENTED SO
THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE WATER FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES AGRICULTURE AND
THE ENVIRONMENT BOTH NOW BUT
ALSO IN THE DECADES TO COME. THE
pMILESTONE IN SIGMA AND
IMPLEMENTATION IS NOW A REALITY
IN OVER NINETY GROUNDWATER
BASINS IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING TO HEAR
FROM ADMINISTRATION AND LOCAL
AGENCIES TO SEE HOW THE
IMPORTANT UNDERTAKE THIS
IMPORTANT WORK IS GOING AND TO
MAKE SURE ALL WORKING TO ACHIEVE
SUSTAINABLE MANAGEMENT OF
GROUNDWATER. I'M HONORED TO HAVE
THE AUTHORS OF THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION JOINING US IN
OPENING THE COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY TO OFFER THEIR KNOWLEDGE
IN PERSPECTIVE ON WHERE WE ARE
AND WHERE THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
US GO. WITH THAT I WANT TO HEAD
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE AND CHAIR
OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU UP FIRST OF
ALL THANK YOU. TO MY COACH I AM
IS BOUND HAND IN THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS WILL TAKE THE TIME
OUT OF THEIR BUSY SCHEDULES TO
ATTEND AND SPEAK ABOUT THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND I'VE
ALSO THANK YOU- MISQUOTING-
KILEY FIFTY NORTH FOR JOINING US
AS WELL. THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT WAS
ESTABLISHED DURING ONE OF THE
WORST DROUGHT ON RECORD TO HELP
CORRECT THE MISUSE OF OUR- MOST
IMPORTANT RESOURCES. THIS
HEARING IS PARTICULARLY TIMELY
AS WE CURRENTLY FACE ANOTHER
DROUGHT. WHICH WAY B. OUR NEW
NORMAL. BECAUSE OF THIS NEW
NORMAL IT REMAINS JUST AS
IMPORTANT TODAY TO CONTINUE THE
WORK STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND.
FOURTEEN WITH SIGMA.
UNFORTUNATELY WELLS CONTINUE TO
GO DRY ALARMING RATES LEAVING
MANY CALIFORNIANS RESIDENTS
WITHOUT A RELIABLE. SOURCE OF
DRINKING WATER. NOT JUST
WONDERFUL WILL FIX THIS THE
ISSUE WE HAVE A HELD. AS PERCENT
INTO THE FUTURE OUR GROUNDWATER
. WILL ONLY BECOME MORE
IMPORTANT. MANY OF THE CURRENT
MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT SERVING THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN CYGNET WAS
ESTABLISHED. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
HEARING IS TO EXPLORE SIGMA AND
EDUCATE OURSELVES ON THE ISSUE
WHICH ONE FOR OUR FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE CONVERSATIONS. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE HEARING
TODAY I HOPE IT'S A LIVELY
DISCUSSION FROM OUR PANELISTS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR SPEAKERS WHO
WILL BE PRETTY PARTICIPATING IN
THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETER NOTICES
LIKE TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM AND THINK YOU
ALSO CHAIR OF OUR CAN. AT THE
TOPIC OF TODAY'S HEARING REALLY
COULD NOT BE MORE URGENT I'M
JUST YESTERDAY AS SOME OF YOU
MAY HAVE SEEN. A NEW STUDY
PUBLISHED IN NATURE CLIMATE
CHANGE JOURNAL CONCLUDED THAT
THE CURRENT WESTERN MEGA DROUGHT
IS THE WORST IN ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED YEARS. THE WORST IN
TWELVE HUNDRED YEARS. I'M HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE SEEING THE
IMPACT OF THIS QUITE LITERALLY
ON THE GROUND WITH AS BAD IT'S-
CHAIR AGUIAR-CURRY NOTED.
CALIFORNIA GROUND BASINS IN MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED TODAY. WE CANNOT
BURY OUR HEADS IN THE SAND AND
JUST HOPE FOR A MIRACLE OR HOPE
FOR THAT NEXT BIG STORM WE NEED
TO PLAN FOR LESS WATER PURE AND
SIMPLE WE NEED TO DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S WATER
CONSERVATION INFRASTRUCTURE AND
MANAGEMENT. AND MORE BROADLY AS
THAT THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZES THE URGENCY OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS WE HAVE MADE
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS TO BUILD
CLIMATE RESILIENCE TO SHORE UP
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE AND ALSO
TEACH YOU ABOUT COMMUNITIES
PREPARE FOR SEA LEVEL RISE AND
TO HELP BETTER PREPARE FOR AND
RESPOND TO WILDFIRE THREATS. AS
WE ROLL OUT THESE INVESTMENTS IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE BUILD IN ROUTE BEST
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO
ENSURE THAT THESE HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS YIELD EQUALLY
HISTORIC RESULTS FOR CALIFORNIA
SO I WANT TO THANK BOTH OF OUR
TEARS TODAY FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE. AND FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AS WE MOVE A
GREAT STEP FORWARD AT THANK YOU
LOOKING FORWARD TO A AT REALLY
THOUGHTFUL AND DEBT AND
INFORMATIVE CONVERSATION TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
APPRECIATE WILL HAVE OTHER
COMMENTS FROM OUR MEMBERS LATER
DURING. THE CONVERSATION AT AS
WE GOT THIS AT THE END OF THE
PROGRAM TODAY. I FIRST LIKE TO
START- WITH THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT
SIGNAL ONE OH ONE. AND WE'RE
HONORED TODAY TO HAVE SENATOR
FRAN PAVLEY JOINED US TODAY WHO
IS ONE OF THE INSTIGATORS BEHIND
CIGNA AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROGER DIXON SINCE SO WE WILL
START WITH. SENATOR PAVLEY.
THREE OF SENATOR PABLO THEIR
COMPUTER SYSTEM YES WE DO HELLO
WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED. IN.
THE NEW FULL SCREEN MODE. OKAY
CAN YOU SEE THE PRESCRIPTION WE
SURE CAN WELCOME SENATOR. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
TO EVERYONE I WISH I COULD BE
THERE IN PERSON BUT- I DECIDED
TO INVADE MY FORMER STATE SENATE
OFFICE AND TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
HENRY STERN STAP THAT'S WHAT
THEY GET FROM HAVING THEIR
DISTRICT OFFICE THREE MILES FROM
MY HOME. SO- YEAH THAT'S THE
WORST THING ABOUT BEING OUT OF
OFFICE MAY END. UP WE MIGHT NOT
GET PENSIONS AND WE DON'T GET
HEALTH CARE BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY STAFF EITHER AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M STILL ADJUSTING TO. ANYWAY
THIS PICTURE I THOUGHT I JUST
START WITH REAL QUICKLY IN THIS
IS A ONE ON ONE CLASS AND START
FOR MANY OF YOU- YOU PROBABLY
ALREADY KNOW THIS INFORMATION
BUT WHO KNEW AND FUTURE SAID.
THAT WE WOULD BE FACING SORT OF
THE SAME KIND OF CONDITIONS WE
WERE FACING IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN WHEN WE PASSED THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT AND THAT'S A COPY
AT THE BILL SIGNING. WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DICKINSON AND I
JOINED BY A- PRIVATE PREMIER
GROWER FISCAL FARMS AND- A
MEMBER OF OCT WELL. CITY'S BIG
THE DEADLY OWNED CHAIRED OTHER
P. AT THE BILL SIGNING SO THAT
WAS IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
WHERE WE WERE. IN OUR FIFTH YEAR
OF DROUGHT. SO JUST MOVING ON
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO JUST GO OVER
THE KEY PROVISIONS OF
LEGISLATION UNLESS YOU'D LIKE TO
READ THE- MULTI PAGE. BILL BUT
IN SIMPLE TERMS. THE CONCEPT
WAS- CHIPS SUSTAINABLY MANAGE
YOUR GROUNDWATER BASIN AND THAT
MEANS YOU HAVE TO OVER APPEAR IN
TWO YEARS. NOT TAKE OUT MORE
WATER THAN IS COMING IN AND IT
TAKES A LOT LONGER TO HELP
GROUND WATER PARTICULARLY WHEN
WE FEEL ABOUT HUNGER BASIN- THAN
IT DOES TO PUMP IT OUT. IT
CONSISTENT WITH OUR CONSTITUTION
LOOKING AT WATER IS A PROPERTY
RIGHT UNDER STATE LAW. REQUIRES
LOCAL AGENCIES TO ADOPT
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT PLAN SO
WE STARTED WITH THE MOST.
MODERATE SEVERE. I'M BASINS THAT
WERE BEING OVER TO AND THAT'S
ABOUT HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE OF
FIVE AND FIFTEEN BASINS AROUND
THE STATE. IT GAVE TOOLS AND
ABILITIES TO THE LOCAL
GROUNDWATER BASINS TO IMPLEMENT
THE PLANTS ASSISTANCE BY THE
STATE WATER BOARD OF STAFF OR
FUNDS FOR PARTICULAR STUDIES.
THE DJUDICATED BASINS THAT THE
TERM FOR THE LEGALLY- JUDICIALLY
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE VERY
EXPENSIVE PROCESS WHERE PEOPLE
BODY AND- TOPWATER LAWYERS TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH EACH ENTITY
OVER RELYING A GROUNDWATER BASIN
HOW MUCH WATER THEY GOT THE
PERCENTAGE OF WATER THAT WOULD
CHANGE UP AND DOWN AS AS THE
WATER LEVELS INDICATE AND
FINALLY IT PROVIDED THE STATE TO
BE A BACKSTOP OF LOCAL
GROUNDWATER AGENCY SCANNER WILL
MANAGE THEIR BASE AND THEN I
LEARNED THAT THAT ACTUALLY WAS A
PRETTY GOOD THREAT- THE STATE
WATER BOARD WOULD COME IN AND
MANAGE IT FOR YOU IF YOU COULD
MANAGE IT SELF. BUT HERE WE ARE
A FEW YEARS LATER AND THE SOME
OF OUR- SEVERELY DRAFTED WATER
AGENCIES. DID NOT SUBMIT PLANS
ON TIME. SO THAT THREE DAYS AT
THE TOP OF THE PAGE WERE KEY TO
THIS EVERYTHING HAS TO BE
ONLINE- WE HAD THE RESEARCH DONE
BY AQUA WHO WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
PROVIDING BACKGROUND. TO THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AROUND THE
STATE AGRICULTURAL AND URBAN-
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND
THE WATER EDUCATION FOUNDATION.
THE RESOURCES LEGACY FUND WAS
INVOLVED- BUT VERY GOOD UP TO
DATE RESEARCH ALL THIS WAS
REQUESTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
UNDER GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN THE
CODE AT THE BOTTOM IS FROM THE
CHAIRMAN AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE
DRISKELL CLOSER YOU LIVE ALONG
THE CENTRAL COAST. PROPOSES A
BIG- BERRY OPERATION VERY
DEPENDENT SPECIALLY ALONG THE
CENTRAL COAST WHERE THEY'RE VERY
RELIANT ON GROUNDWATER. A TIME
FRAME AND YOU CAN LOOK THAT UP
LATER WAS SET INTO PLACE SO
WE'RE- REALIZING NOW WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE. ANOTHER EXTREME
APPROVED A DROUGHT YOU MAY NEED
TO ACCELERATE THIS TIME TABLE ON
THEM I'M SO- RICHARD OF YOU
HAVING THIS FORUM TODAY. I
PULLED THIS OUT OF MY OLD FILES-
BECAUSE I'M STILL LAST TO GIVE
PRESENTATIONS ON STICKING AROUND
THE STATE. THIS WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND IF YOU
JUST GLANCE THROUGH IT JUST THAT
FIRST PARAGRAPH ITSELF IT WAS
FROM UP OF STORYAND THE SAN
JOSE MERCURY NEWS. YOU WOULD
THINK WE'RE READING A
CONTEMPORARY STORY THAT WOULD BE
IN THE PAPER TODAY. ABOUT PROVED
DRILLING TECHNOLOGIES IN OUR
RACE TO THE BOTTOM BUT OVER
PUMPING A MORE MOISTURE
DEMANDING CROPS WERE DOING YEAR
ROUND CROPS THAT REQUIRE WATER-
FIELDS CAN'T BE LATE FELLOW AND
HISTORICALLY DRY CONDITIONS AND
WE'RE LEARNING OUR SOIL THREE
EVEN MORE DRY THAN WHAT THEY
WERE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
WATER TABLE COLLAPSES. THE LAND
SUBSIDES YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS SPECIALLY TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND HOW IT APPLIES TO
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE CANALS
AND AQUEDUCTS. AND IT'S OTHER
CAR PERSPECTIVE IT'S A LOT MORE
ENERGY NOW TO PUMP DEEPER AND
DEEPER AND ABOUT RIGHT NOW ABOUT
18% OF ALL OUR ENERGY USE IN THE
STATE IS MOVING TREATING HER
PUMPING GROUNDWATER. SO THIS
THIS IS JUST AN OVERVIEW OF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD I TEND TO TALK IN
POWER POINTS ANYWAY ARE BULLETS-
ON IDEAS THAT YOU MIGHT THINK OF
AND YOU'RE GOING TO CERTAINLY
ADD TO HIM- DURING THESE
DISCUSSIONS THE FRONT PAGE OF
THE TIMES TODAY AS WELL AS
YESTERDAY. IS ON THIS TOPIC AND
I'M GETTING A PHONE CALLS UP
WHAT CAN BE DONE TO WHAT MAKES
IT MUCH STRONGER AND COMPLY WITH
THE INTENT TO SO THAT WE- ARE
GROUND WATER WHICH IS 60% OF OUR
SUPPLY DURING. I YEARS. IS NOT.
OVER AND THE AND- PARTICULARLY
TO OTHER WATER USERS WHO ARE
LEFT HIGH AND DRY. SO WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS YOU CAN DO TO
STRENGTHEN SIGNUP PERHAPS. AND
YOU'RE THE EXPERTS NOW BUT BRING
IN EVERYONE YOU CAN MEET WITH-
ARE WE OPERATING TOO MUCH
INSIDE. SILOS IS THE PART IN A
WATER RESOURCES WHICH IS FOR THE
SUPPLY SIDE OF THE STATE WATER
BOARD CAN THEY BE. BETTER
COORDINATED HOW ABOUT THE
REGIONAL WATER- DISTRICTS IN THE
AREA. HOW DO WE ACCELERATE THE
TIMETABLE FOR CYSTS WITHIN
ABILITY COMPLIANCE. CAN WE WAIT
TWENTY MORE YEARS. PROBABLY NOT
. A GROWING PROBLEM AND I'M SURE
YOU'RE WELL AWARE OF IT IS TO
BOOST ENSURE ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER THERE WAS
ACTUALLY STATE LEGISLATION BY
MIKE INGLIS DUTY CHOOSE A
HUSBAND ON INTO AT THE STATE
RIGHT THAT EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER A
LOT OF PEOPLE DO NOT AND IT'S
GROWING- UP CONSIDER
CONSEQUENCES FOR PATIENTS WHO DO
NOT SUBMIT COMPLETE FANS HAVE A
DONE SO DID NOT IN. JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR WHAT ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES HOW CAN WE HELP OF
HOW WE CAN HELP WE MAKE SURE
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN. WE'RE
FINDING OUT THAT THERE'S A
REASONABLE USE OF WATER DUE TO
OVER PUMPING- IS THERE A WAY TO
MAKE THEM LEGALLY COMPLY. IT'S
NOT OVER PUMPING AND I USED THE
TERM AND REASONABLE USE BECAUSE
THAT'S A LEGALLY. IMPORTANT TERM
THAT CAN BE. THAT CAN RESULT IN
POSSIBLE LEGAL ACTION IF YOU ARE
OVER PUMPING IT'S IN A
REASONABLE NOT BENEFICIAL USED
TO THE WATER SUPPLY I'M A BIG
FAN OF WATER AND ENERGY AND
NEXUS I MENTIONED ABOUT 18% OF
OUR WATER. IS TIED IN TO- WATER
PUMPING. TRANSPORTATION AND
HEATING OF WATER IT'S TIED INTO
CLIMATE CHANGE WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THERE'S A GROWING INTEREST
BY THE PACIFIC INSTITUTE NEXT
TEND. AND FOUNDATIONS ALL OVER
THE STATE AND TYING AND OUR
OPPORTUNITIES OF. STRENGTHENING
OUR WATER SUPPLY WITH ALSO
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF. ALSO
FEELS REQUIRED TO MOVE TREAT
HE'S OUR WATER. ALSO WITH
PERHAPS AS PART OF THE THIRTY
THIRTY PLAN THAT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY IS LOOKING AT
YOU MIGHT LOOK AT WHAT WE CAN DO
TO RESTORE WATERSHEDS AND
WETLANDS AND HOW THAT WOULD
INCREASE OUR WATER SUPPLY I'M ON
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
RIGHT NOW AND- WATERSHEDS ARE
BEING FUNDED FOR RESTORATION AND
NEED FOR EXAMPLE IN THIS YEAR
AND ABOUT AS WHICH SHOULD
INCREASE DOWNSTREAM WATER.
AVAILABILITY HOW CAN WE REDUCE
WATER INTENSIVE YEAR ROUND CROPS
ESPECIALLY IN THE OVER DRAFTED.
BASINS THIS IS FAR DIFFERENT
THAN TWENTY YEARS AGO THE AMOUNT
OF SPECIALLY. ALMONDS AND
PISTACHIOS- THAT ARE GROWN THAT
REQUIRE INCREDIBLE BATTLE WATER
. DOES ILLEGAL CANNABIS
OPERATIONS TAKE. GROUNDWATER
FROM OUR LOCAL BASINS THAT'S A
GROWING PROBLEM THAT MAY NEED-
YOUR- YOUR- ADVICE- WHICH SHOULD
WATER AND HERE'S A POLITICALLY
VERY HOT LEGAL QUESTION BE
REGULATED AS A PRIVATE PROPERTY
RIGHT OR IS IT ANY PUBLIC
BENEFIT. THAT'S SOMETHING
BUILDING TO TALK ABOUT IT. UNDER
THE BILL- NINETEEN FOURTEEN
RIGHTS IS DETERMINED- MAYBE
THAT'S OUT OF DATE BUT I A AND
POLITICALLY THAT WOULD BE A
DIFFICULT DISCUSSION THAT
HAPPENED IT PROBABLY NEEDS TO BE
DISCUSSED. NEARLY 90% OF WHAT WE
GROWED REPORTEDLY NOW SENT
OVERSEAS AND NOT TO OUR STATE
AND THOSE ARE THOSE YEAR ROUND
CROPS. LOCAL GROUNDWATER BASINS
WANT TO REPORT MANAGER ON SUPPLY
WHAT WE DO SOME CAN'T OR WON'T
DO SO AND LASTLY ALL OF US ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO. LOOK AT WATER
AS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO OUR
SURVIVAL AS A STATE SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO USE T ONCE IF
NOT TWICE. REDUCED AMOUNT THE
USE AND RECYCLE WATER AND THAT
MEANS EVERYONE- COOLEY IN URBAN
AREAS AS WELL AS AGRICULTURAL
AREAS. THIS IS JUST A FEW
THOUGHTS OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
AND I'D BE GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS DURING THE DISCUSSION
AT A LATER TIME AND I'M VERY
HAPPY. TO BE SHARING THIS
PLATFORM WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROGER DICKINSON SORT OF THE
SECRET TO OUR SUCCESS IS THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY WORK
CLOSELY TOGETHER- ROGER
DICKINSON STAFF AT MY STAFF MY
STAFF HAD LED BY DENNIS O'CONNOR
IS STILL IN THE BUILDING- WE
WERE ABLE TO COME UP WITH THAT.
SEVERAL BILLS WHERE WE COULD-
MENDHAM IS THE PROCESS WENT
ALONG. AND OF COURSE COMPROMISES
IMPORTANT ONE PASSING A BILL
AND- IT BUT IT WAS A VERY-
WORTHWHILE PROCESS AND NOW IT'S
UP TO YOU TO MAKE SURE. THIS IS
UPDATED AT SIGMA IS DOING WHAT
IT'S INTENDED TO DO AND THAT'S
ESTABLISH. SUSTAINABILITY
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL GROUND BASIN
AND- SO YOU VERY MUCH ALLOWING
ME SPEND ON WITH YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR AND IF YOU
DON'T MIND HANGING ON WE WILL.
MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DICKINSON AND WE WILL CHAT WITH
YOU I'M SURE THEY'LL BE
QUESTIONS AFTER HIS
PRESENTATION. SO IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DICKINSON AVAILABLE. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING. THANKS FOR
THE INVITATION TO SPEAK TODAY-
I'M ROGER DICKINSON FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND ONE OF THE
AUTHORS OF THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT WHICH
YOU ALL KNOW IS SICK MONTH NINE
STEP BY THE WAY WAS NEVER- CALL
BACK DURING THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BUT- THAT NAME ROSE
AFTERWARDS SO WE'VE ALL ADOPTED
IT- I'M CURRENTLY THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CIVIC WELL FORMERLY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION.
AND I'M VERY PLEASED TO JOIN
SENATOR PATRICK LEAHY- THIS
MORNING- SHE'S GIVING YOU. SOME
VERY GOOD THINGS TO THINK ABOUT-
I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON THREE
AREAS AND GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF PERHAPS- MORE THE QUALITATIVE
FLAVOR OF A SICK MIND AND AS WE
WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
THOUGHT ABOUT HOW WE WOULD
ATTACK THIS ISSUE OF-
GROUNDWATER OVERDRAFT IN THAT
THAT WAS- SO DRAMATIC AS UNDER
PAPILLAE- HAS DESCRIBED AND SOME
OF YOU HAVE DESCRIBED IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS. AT THE AT THE
OUTSET LET ME LET ME SAY THAT
WORKING WITH SENATOR TAVALY
CLOSELY WAS ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL
TO OUR SUCCESS IN ENACTING
SIGMA- IN ADDITION THE ALIGNMENT
UNITY AND EXPERTISE OF THIS
ASSEMBLY STAFF THE SENATE STAFF
IN THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF WERE KEY
ELEMENTS IN MAKING. SIGMAR LAW.
AS SENATOR PER NO WE HAVE
SUPPORT FOR THE F. FROM A HOST
OF ORGANISE. RANGING FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES TO THE WATER FOUNDATION
AND THEY ALSO PLAYED. AN
INSTRUMENTAL ROLE. UNDENIABLE
REALITY COMPELLED THE ADOPTION
OF SIGMA IN DROUGHT YEARS 60% OR
MORE OF OUR WATER SUPPLY COMES
FROM GROUNDWATER. DECADES OF
OVER DRAFTING HAD LED TO AFFECTS
SUCH AS SERIOUS SUBSIDENCE IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY TO SEE
WATER INTRUSION TWO DRINKING
WATER WELLS SERVING ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES DRYING UP. ALTHOUGH
IT HAD BEEN DISCUSSED FOR FORTY
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAD NEVER HAD
STATE REGULATION OF GROUNDWATER
INDEED CALIFORNIA STOOD OUT AS
THE ONLY STATE IN THE WEST TO
NOT DO SO. FIVE TWENTY FOURTEEN
WE COULD SIMPLY NO LONGER AFFORD
TO WAIT ANY LONGER. THE DESIGN
AND STRUCTURE OF SIGMA IS
UNUSUAL IF NOT UNIQUE. AT THE
CORE IT WAS FASHIONED ON
EXPERIENCE- ACTUALLY THAT I HAD
AS A SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR. AT ONE POINT WE WERE
COME UP WITH THE PROPOSAL. FOR
MEASURES WHICH WOULD BRING US
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE CLEAN
AIR ACT HOWEVER AMONG THE
VARIOUS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
INTEREST GROUPS WE COULD NOT
SEEM TO COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON
MEASURES THAT WOULD PROJECT TO
MEET OUR FEDERAL OBLIGATIONS.
AFTER PROTECTED A PROTRACTED
PERIOD WITHOUT A RESOLUTION
USEPA TOLD US IF WE FAIL TO
OFFER A SUITABLE PLAN THEY WOULD
IMPOSE ONE ON US. THEY DANGLED
SUCH RESTRICTIONS AS ALLOWING
DRIVING ONLY EVERY OTHER DAY
BASED ON LICENSE PLATE NUMBERS
AND PARKING RANGE THAT WOULD BE
ASTRONOMICAL. THEY PLAYED THE
QUINTESSENTIAL BAD COP. GIVEN
THEIR THREAT TO NO SURPRISE WE
CAME UP WITH A PLAN. OF LOCAL
DEVELOPED MEASURES WHICH
SATISFIED BOTH EPA AND US. WE
APPLIED THAT LESSON WHEN
STRUCTURING SIGMA IT WAS FOUNDED
ON THE PRINCIPLE THAT LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND COMMUNITIES ARE IN
THE BEST POSITION TO ADDRESS
LOCAL CONDITIONS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN GIVEN CLEAR
DIRECTION AND SPECIFIC GOALS WE
GAVE LOCAL COMMUNITIES A LARGE
DEGREE OF DISCRETION AND FORMING
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES OR GSA'S. ALTHOUGH THE
STATUTE IS CLEAR THE GSA'S
EITHER ON THEIR OWN OR IN
COMBINATION WITH OTHER GSA'S
MUST ACHIEVE SUSTAINABILITY IN
THEIR BASE AND THEY COULDN'T
AVOID IT BY SOME ARTIFICE. OR
CONSTRUCT WE UNDERSTOOD THAT
MOVING TO SUSTAINABILITY WOULD
IMPOSE AN ARDUOUS TECHNICAL AND
PROGRAMMATIC CHALLENGE FOR LOCAL
ENTITIES. THEREFORE WE DIRECTED
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES WOULD BE GIVEN THE
ROLE OF ASSISTING GSA'S
INFORMING AND ONCE FORMED IN
MEETING THE CHALLENGES GSA'S
FACED. THE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY OF GSA'S IS TO
PRODUCE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS OR G. S.
P.'S WHICH IDENTIFY AN OUTLINE
THE ROADMAP TO SUSTAINABILITY.
SIGNAL STRUCTURE WAS ALSO BUILT
TO INCLUDE STATE REVIEW AND
APPROVAL OF G. S. P.'S SO THAT
THERE WOULD BE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR GSA'S TO DEVELOP AND ADOPT
REAL AND MEASURABLE PLANS SUCH
REVIEW IS ESSENTIAL SINCE WE
REALIZED THAT SOME LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND COMMUNITIES MIGHT
FIND IT TOO DIFFICULT OR BEYOND
WILLING TO DO WHAT WAS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE SUCCESSFUL.
IMPLEMENTATION FINALLY. WE
DESIGNATED THE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TO STEP IN AND
IMPLEMENT PLANS AND MEASURES TO
REACH SUSTAINABILITY IF
NECESSARY. WITH THE HOPE THAT
THE SPECTER OF THE STATE PLAYING
SUCH A ROLE WOULD BE COMPELLING
TO LOCAL OFFICIALS TO TAKE
ACTION ON THEIR OWN INSTEAD. SO
SIMPLY PUT SEGMENT IS STRUCTURED
TO GIVE LOCAL COMMUNITIES THE
AUTHORITY AND RESPONSIBILITY IN
THE FIRST INSTANCE TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT PLANS TO REACH
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY. IT
IS THE AUTHORITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES TO BOTH
ASSIST. LOCAL EFFORTS AND TO
REQUIRE ADHERENCE TO THE OVER
ARCHING PURPOSE OF CIGNA CIGNA
NAMELY REACHING SUSTAINABILITY.
AND IT IS THE ROLE OF THE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO STEP
IN AND TAKE THE PLACE OF LOCAL
ENTITIES THAT CANNOT OR WILL NOT
FULFILL THEIR OBLIGATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
WE WOULD BE ON TRACK TOWARDS
SUSTAINABLE. GROUNDWATER BASINS
. SECOND THE SELECTION OF TWENTY
YEARS AS THE HORIZON BY WHICH
BASINS MUST REACH SUSTAINABILITY
WITH THE BALANCING OF TWO
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS. FIRST
THE URGENCY OF RESTORING
GROUNDWATER VIABILITY WAS
MANIFEST WITH MANY BASE AND
SUBJECT TO SO MUCH OVER DRAFTING
FOR SO MANY YEARS BUT NOT ONLY
WERE PROPERTY OWNERS DRILLING
DEEPER AND DEEPER WELLS WITH
SHALLOWER WELLS DRYING UP. BUT
SIGNIFICANT SUBSIDENCE OF AS
MUCH AS FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FEET
HAD OCCURRED IN A NUMBER OF
AREAS. SECOND BECAUSE OVER
DRAFTING HAD TAKEN PLACE FOR
DECADES. IN BASINS INTO A
SUSTAINABLE CONDITION. OBVIOUSLY
WAS GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME. NOW
BALLOTS IN THOSE TEN THINGS
NEVERTHELESS A GSA CANNOT SIMPLY
DELAY TAKING ACTION UNTIL TEN OR
FIFTEEN YEARS IN THE FUTURE. ASK
OUR MAINS URGENT ESPECIALLY WITH
THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
MEASURABLE PROGRESS TOWARDS
SUSTAINABILITY REQUIRED
UNDERSTATEMENT IS AN ONGOING
TEST WITH PERIODIC FIVE YEAR
REVIEWS BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES OF EACH PLANT.
THE THIRD POINT. THIS MORNING I
WANT TO JUST. MAKE A COMMENT
ABOUT IS THAT CIGNA UNDERSCORES
THE PRINCIPLE OF ACCOUNTING FOR
THE INTERESTS OF ALL BENEFICIAL
USERS. HISTORICALLY THOSE WITH
GREATER ECONOMIC POWER AND
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN ABLE TO RELY
ON GROUNDWATER EVEN AS AQUIFER'S
HAVE DECLINED AND OTHER USERS
HAVE LOST. THEIR ACCESS OR
WATCHED IT DIMINISH ESPECIALLY
SMALL FARMERS AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. SIGMAR RECOGNIZES
THAT SUSTAINABILITY MEANS ALL
BENEFICIAL USERS MUST ENJOY
ACCESS TO GROUNDWATER ON A FAIR
AND REASONABLE BASIS EVEN AS WE
ENSURE THERE IS NO AS THE
STATUTE BUT SAID CHRONIC
LOWERING OF GROUNDWATER LEVELS
INDICATING A SIGNIFICANT AND ON
REASONABLE DEPLETION OF SUPPLY.
IN THE MIDST OF DROUGHT IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. THE LEGISLATURE
ACTED TO SEPARATE COURSE FOR THE
STATE TO REGULATE FOR THE FIRST
TIME A MOST PRECIOUS RESOURCE
OUR GROUNDWATER. SOME OBSERVERS
CALLED IT THE BIGGEST CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA WATER LAW IN MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED YEARS. THE
CURRENT DROUGHT AND THE GROWING
REALITY THE CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
ONLY INTENSIFY. DICTATES THAT WE
INSIST THAT SEGMENT BE
RIGOROUSLY AND FAITHFULLY
CARRIED OUT TO PROTECT OUR
HEALTH OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT. THANKS VERY MUCH.
AUSTIN'S THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- BEFORE GOING TO
IN AND OTHER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE. FOR COMMENTS. I DON'T
SEE YEAH SURE ASSEMBLY WERE
LACKING YEAH PLEASE PARDON ME IF
I MISSED BECAUSE I ARRIVED A
LITTLE BIT TARDY BUT- ONE OF THE
BIG CRISIS POINTS THAT WE HAVE I
LIVE IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AREA IN THE DESERT WHERE-
GROUNDWATER HAS ALWAYS BEEN. A
FOCUS BUT NOW WE HAVE THE
ILLEGAL OR ILLICIT CANNABIS
GROWERS THERE AND WE'RE WE'RE
DEALING NOT ONLY WITH WATER
CONTAMINATION AS AS A PROBLEM
BUT ALSO WATER THEFT AND OUR
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE HAVING A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME. MANAGING OF
THESE BOTH OF THESE PROBLEMS AND
I WONDERED IF YOU HAD AT LEAST
AWARENESS OF THE SITUATION. THE
SERVICE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DICKINSON RIGHT DOWN TO THAT OR
CENTER POWERPOINT- I WILL I
DON'T KNOW IF CENTER PROBABLY IS
STILL AVAILABLE BUT- AND IT'S
ONLY MEMBER LACKEY- CENTER
PAVLEY IN FACT MENTION THAT IN
IN HER REMARKS- IT WAS NOT AN
ISSUE FRANKLY- IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN SO IT IS NOT ADDRESSED-
IT LEAST IT WASN'T AN ISSUE THAT
AROSE IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
CONSIDERATION OF. OF THE
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
SO IT'S NOT ADDRESS DIRECTLY- BY
THE STATUTE I THINK IT IS.
CLEARLY A PROBLEM- NOT ONLY IN
IN YOUR PART OF THE STATE BUT IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE AS WELL
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT- I
THINK- YOUR GOOD ATTENTION TO-
CURRENTLY- IT DOES IS A VERY
MUCH NEEDED SO- WE WOULD EXPECT
I THINK UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
TYPICAL MECHANISMS FOR-
POLICING- AND ENFORCING THE LAW
WITH RESPECT TO CONTAMINATED
WATER. THE ILLEGAL USE OF WATER
TO APPLY BUT THERE MAY BE MORE
SPECIFIC MEASURES THAT- YOU YOU
AS THE CURRENT MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE BELIEVE. ARE ARE
NECESSARY AND APPROPRIATE. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION
FOR ME ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR
KIDS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
IN THANK YOU BOTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TAKEN SENATE CENTER
PROBABLY FOR LEADERSHIP IN THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AREA. AND
IT'S ALWAYS I THINK IMPRESSIVE
TO LOOK IN HINDSIGHT AND SEE HOW
HELPFUL IT IS TO GET US TO WHERE
WE ARE TODAY. IS ALREADY
CONTINUE MENTIONED THAT WHEN YOU
PASS THIS BILL. YOU BELIEVE THE
SCEPTER OF THE STATE TAKING OVER
WAS GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO GET
LOCAL AGENCIES TO DO WHAT WE
WANTED THEM TO DO TO SUSTAINABLY
MANAGE GROUNDWATER. WHEN WE LOOK
AT WHERE WE ARE TODAY WE SEE
THAT THERE ARE MANY THAT HAVE
NOT DONE THAT. AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT SORT OF IN. A LARGE NUMBER OF
IT MAY BE UNDER THAT- CONTROL
AND GIVEN THAT. I GUESS I WONDER
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT WHERE WE SHOULD GO FROM
THERE AND ARE THERE OTHER MEANS
OF ENFORCEMENT THAT YOU THINK WE
SHOULD CONSIDER. WELL I THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- ADAM CHAIR
I THINK THAT- WE TRYING TO
DESIGN AN APPROACH THAT WOULD
ULTIMATELY- STIMULATE. LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO IN EFFECT BITE THE
BULLET AND WE KNOW THAT THIS CAN
BE A VERY DIFFICULT. UNDERTAKING
AND A NUMBER OF PLACES AROUND
THE STATE BUT THE- BUT THE- THE
PROCESS OF. HAVING D. W. R.
REVIEW PLANS TO COMMENT ON PLANS
TO REQUIRE IMPROVEMENT- PLANS.
ARE UPGRADING THE PLANS AS THEY
ARE GOING THROUGH NOW WITH THE
WITH A NUMBER OF GSA'S. AND THEN
IF THERE'S A FAILURE TO DO SO TO
PUT THAT AND TO PUT THOSE BASINS
IN A PROBATIONARY STATUS THAT
BRINGS IN THE WHAT THE- STATE.
WATER BOARD. TO TAKE- I'M MORE
ACTIVE ROLE I MEAN ALL THESE ARE
STEPS THAT WE THAT WE DESIGNED
IN WITH WITH THE HOPE FRANKLY
THAT- THAT. LOCAL OFFICIALS AND
COMMUNITIES- WHAT DO WHAT WHAT
HAS TO BE DONE- IS THERE MORE
ENFORCEMENT OR- ADDITIONAL
MEASURES REQUIRED AT AT AT THIS
STAGE. IT MAY BE A LITTLE TOO
SOON TO KNOW THE ANSWER. TO
THAT. UNTIL WE SEE HOW THE
PROCESS WORKS WITH. WITH RESPECT
TO THE POTENTIAL FOR D. W. R.
REVIEW AND- PROBATIONARY STATUS
FOR BASINS TO SEE IF THAT. IF
THAT SEQUENCE. OF TEPS
ACTUALLY- IS EFFECTIVE IN IN
GETTING THOSE- BASINS AND GSA'S
THAT HAVE BEEN. SOMEWHAT MORE
RETICENT- TO STEP UP TO AND IN
FACT TO DO SO. TO LIVE UP TO
THEIR X. THERE- I THINK WE WILL
WAIT AND SEE. ANY OTHER AG CAN
WE HONOR THAT PLEASE YEAH OUT I
AGREE WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
DICKINSON THERE ISN'T ONE DIRECT
ANSWER HERE BUT I THINK THAT THE
COMBINATION OF CHOICES HERE
FIRST OF ALL WHY DID THOSE-
GALLAGHER BASIN TO HAVE FIVE
YEARS NOT COMPLY WITH THE
COMPLETED PLAN WHICH IS JUST
STEP ONE ON TIME. AND HOW MUCH
STAFF DOES THE STATE HAVE TO
PRINT WE CAN AND DO THAT FOR
THEM THAT'S GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE YET HOW MUCH ARE YOU
WILLING TO SPEND THIS IS A GOOD
TIME GENERAL FUND WISE IF THE
PRIORITY. BUT ALSO HOW CAN WE
STOP- THE- THAT ARE GOING ON
THAT ARE ACCELERATING THE
PROBLEMS SO YOU HAVE. THE
ENFORCEMENT STRATEGY BUT THEN
ARE THERE. ACTRESSES FOR EXAMPLE
IT SHOULD THOSE BASINS THAT ARE
SEVERELY OVER PUMPING THE
GROUNDWATER SPECIALLY IN AREAS
THAT ARE AFFECTING PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER SHOULD THEY BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO GROW YEAR
ROUND CROPS THAT ARE VERY WATER
INTENSIVE. SHOULD THEY BE ABLE
TO A FEW OF THOSE PEOPLE PUMP
ALL THE WATER TO THE BOTTOM IT
MAY TAKE SOME. LEGAL CHALLENGES
ON BENEFICIAL USE- I'M NOT A
LAWYER. OR MIDDLE SCHOOL TEACHER
BUT I THINK YOU HAVE TO PUT
EVERYTHING ON THE TABLE AND I
WOULD SUGGEST ALSO GOING BACK
AND LOOKING AT THE PEOPLE WHO
DID THOSE EXCELLENT REPORTS AT
THE BEGINNING WATER FOR THINGS
THAT THE RESOURCES LEGACY FUND.
MAY DO THEY HELPED WITH THE
FUNDING OF THAT WATER FOUNDATION
PLANS WHAT WOULD AWKWARD
SUGGESTION DOING BECAUSE WE KNOW
THE STATUS QUO IS NOT GOOD
ENOUGH THAT'S WHY THIS HEARING
IS IMPORTANT AND YOU SHOULD.
PROBABLY HEAR FROM A VARIETY OF
PEOPLE BUT I THINK YOU HAVE TO
STOP WHERE THE ABUSES ARE.
ESPECIALLY IN THE MODERATE TO
SEVERELY OVER DRAFT BASINS. USE
THE THIRTY THIRTY PLAN TO TRY
TO. SAVE THE FINALLY THE
GROUNDWATER BUT THE WATERSHED
FROM- BEING ABUSED AS WELL AND
CRACK DOWN ON PEOPLE THAT FOR
WHATEVER REASON CAN'T OR WON'T
MANAGE THEIR GROUNDWATER BASIN
CAN YOU IMAGINE SHARING A
PROPERTY WITH OTHER PEOPLE AND
ONE PROPERTY OWNER IN YOUR GROUP
OF FIVE NOT BEING ABLE. USING UP
ALL THE LAND SO- THAT SOMETHING
IS NOT WORKING AND I THINK YOU
NEED TO LOOK AT A VARIETY OF
REASONS. BUT AT IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THOSE INDIVIDUAL BASINS.
AND MANAGER TO ADD ONE FURTHER
NOTE ON ON THIS I ALSO THINK
THERE'S A ROLE FOR INCENTIVIZING
LOCALITIES TO DO THE RIGHT THING
SO- FUNDING THAT THAT- COMES
THROUGH THE DROUGHT AND WATER
RESILIENCE PACKAGE FOR EXAMPLE-
TO AUGMENT THE SWEET PROGRAM OR
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR MOVING TO.
TO MORE EFFICIENT USE OF OUR
WATER- THE- MULTI BENEFIT LAND
RE PURPOSING PROGRAM THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE IN THE BUDGET
LAST YEAR- I THINK HAS
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL TO HELP.
LAND LANDOWNERS IN VARIOUS
PLACES MOVE MOVE AWAY FROM- MORE
INTENSIVE USE OF WATER- TO- THE
USING PLANNED FOR- OTHER
PURPOSES AND- RECHARGING
GROUNDWATER IN THE IN THE
PROCESS SO I THINK THAT'S A
PROGRAM THAT THAT DEFINITELY-
SHOULD BE SHOULD BE AUGMENTED-
BUT THOSE KINDS OF THINGS I
THINK. CAN HELP ALTHOUGH I THINK
CENTER PAVEL IS. EXACTLY RIGHT
IN HER REMARKS AS WELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I JUST HAVE A
QUICK CMMENT IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN I SAID ON THE YOLO
COUNTY WATER AGENCY AND THAT'S
ONE. OF THIS BILL HAD GONE
THROUGH AND THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONVERSATION AND- AND-
CHALLENGES WORKING WITH OUR
FARMERS THEY WERE NOT REAL HAPPY
ABOUT SOMEBODY TELLING THEM WHEN
THEY COULD PUMP THE WATER WHEN
THEY COULDN'T PUMP THE WATER
AND- OF THE NUMBER ONE THING WE
HAD TO DO IS DO EDUCATION TO THE
FARMERS AND THEY ACTUALLY. CAME
AROUND IT TOOK SOMETIME BUT THEY
DID COME AROUND I THINK YOU'LL
COUNTY HAS A VERY GOOD PLAN FOR
THEIR GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT
PLAN BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU IN
THE SENATOR- AND- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DICKINSON FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU DIDN'T YOU HAVE A
VISION. JUST LIKE ANY BILL
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM HOW DO YOU
FIX IT BUT THE HARDEST PART IS
THE IMPLEMENTATION I'M GLAD
REVISITING THIS SORT OF WE NEED
TO FINE TUNE IT MAKE IT BETTER.
SO BE IT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE. HAND
THANK YOU MANAGE WHAT DID WE
HAVE. MISTER I DO HAVE A
QUESTION. SO I THINK BOTH FOR
PRESENTING TODAY AND WE ARE
DEFINITELY IN A- IN REGARDS TO
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROWS I THINK
I JUST REALLY WANNA AS I'M LIKE
KIND OF STIRRED HERE- WHAT DO
YOU. TRUCKLOADS OF WATER OUT OF
AG WELLS AND THE WATER RESOURCE
BOARD AS TIGHT AS THEY HAVE NO
ENFORCEMENT. TRUCKLOADS WATER
TRUCKLOADS WATER TRUCKS YOU SEE
THEM. FIFTY A DAY. FIFTY A DAY.
WHY HAVE FARMERS WHO SPENT A
MILLION DOLLARS OF THEIR OWN
MONEY TO COME UP WITH THE PLAN.
SMALL FARMERS WHERE I LIVE. SO
IF WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THESE
THINGS AND LOOK AT THEM WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THE WATER BOND WAS
ALSO. PASSED IN TWENTY. FOURTEEN
CORRECT SO WE'RE GONNA DO GROUND
WATER WE NEED TO WATER STORAGE
AS WELL THIS NEEDS A WHOLE
CONVERSATION AND WE DO NEED TO
BRING THE FARMERS IN HERE FOR
THE FIRST TIME EVER I'M A
THANKFUL I'M A DRYLAND WHEAT
FARMER. WE HAVE NO WATER WE HAVE
NO INDICATION SO I'M NOT BEING
REGULATED. COMES FROM THE SKY.
SO THERE'S A IT'S A HUGE
CONVERSATION AND TO TALK ABOUT I
MEAN I'M JUST THINKING OF KEVIN
MITCHELL AND- NOW BOUGHT MY LAST
OCCASION BRIGHTER A MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE SAKE PRODUCERS
TO COME UP WITH A PLAN. THAT IS
WE NEED TO INCENTIVIZE THE GOOD
ACTORS RIGHT WITH THEIR NEEDS A
WAY FOR THEM TO BE RE THEY'VE
SUBMITTED ON TIME THEY'VE DONE
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO YOU.
SHOULD BE A WAY THEY CAN GET
THAT MONEY BACK THAT CAME OUT OF
THEIR POCKET. IT WAS NOT GRANT
MONEY SO. I'M A LITTLE SCARED
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I AM A FORMER.
AND THIS LOOKS DIFFERENTLY ON
THE OTHER SIDE SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO OUR CONVERSATION I.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH WATER
STORAGE AS WELL AS MANAGING OUR
GROUNDWATER. I'M THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND- YEAH THIS IS THE FIRST OF
MANY CONVERSATIONS THAT I THINK
IN MY REMARKS AT THE BEGINNING I
SAID THAT AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS HAS TO BE AND ALL OF THE
ABOVE APPROACH TO WATER AND
STORAGE IS ABSOLUTELY. HAVE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT BUT SO IS
THE MANAGEMENT OR GROUND WATER
IN THE CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING
TODAY- AND WITH THAT YOU MENTION
WE NEED TO. HAVE A ROBUST
CONVERSATION WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS SO LET'S MOVE ON A
PANEL TO. WHICH WILL BE ON. THE
STATUS THE IMPLEMENTATION STATUS
OF SIGMA. AND THE GOOD AND THE
BAD IN THE SUSTAINABLE. THE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY PLANS
WILL START WITH PAUL GOSSELIN
DEPUTY DIRECTOR SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES- ARE YOU ONLINE PAUL.
CAN YOU GIVE ME YEP. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU- THANK YOU CHAIR THE
VICE CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM PAUL GOSSELIN
DIRECTOR FOR THE STATE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM- I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH AN UPDATE ON SEGMENTATION.
TO BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT AT THIS EARLY STAGE
SEGMENT IS FUNCTIONING WELL AND
MILESTONES ARE BEING MET. THE
PROCESS EVEN WITH- PLANS THAT
ARE INCOMPLETE- IS WORKING AND
WE'RE PUTTING OUR REGULATORY
RULES IN PLACE. ADDITIONALLY
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES HAVE STEPPED UP TO
ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT PLANS THAT
ARE LEADING TOWARDS
SUSTAINABILITY AND MANY HAVE. A
THEIR OWN INVESTMENTS IN
ADDITION TO WHAT THE STATE'S
BEEN PROVIDED. STRONG
FOUNDATIONS BUILT UPON AFFECT
NOT JUST WHAT WE DO A DEEP DIVE
YOU ARE BUT OUR PARTNERS AT THE
STATE BOARD AGENCIES- COUNTIES.
ACADEMIA NON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND JUST COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO PARTICIPATED
APPLYING IMPORTANT ROLES IN
IMPLEMENTATION. ALL THOSE BEEN
SOLID PROGRESS TO DATE AND WE
ARE EARLY THIS MUCH MORE WORK
AHEAD AN IMPORTANT. JUST TO BE
MADE- I'M GOING TO SHARE-
COUPLES. IS OF MY PRESENTATION-
AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT- DON'T
HAVE SHEER. YOU SHOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SHARE. I'M SHOWING.
TRY IT ONE MORE TIME. SOMEHOW MY
SHARE CONTENT IS. THE SYSTEMS
ARE GREAT WHEN THEY WORK WE
UNDERSTAND. EIGHT FIVE I
APOLOGIZE BUT I DON'T LEARN.
OKAY WHY I THANK. COMMITTEE
STAFF- SAYS HE HAS IS IT WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO PUT IT UP HERE
TO. OKAY. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY APOLOGIES.
SO WHAT I COULD DO
IN THE MEANTIME I COULD JUST
TALK THROUGH WITHOUT THE SLIDES
IF THAT WILL WORK. LET'S GO FOR
IT AND IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET IT UP WE WILL. ALL RIGHT.
IT IS WORTH A THOUSAND WORDS BUT
I'LL TRY TO KEEP MY EYE OUT.
PRESENTATION UNDER THE BOX. SO-
REALLY WHERE DOES NOT APPLY
THERE ARE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
SUBBASIN STOCKS STATE AND IT WAS
DECIDED IT'S PRESENTED EARLIER-
THE HIGH AND MEDIUM PRIORITY
BASINS WERE THE ONES THAT ARE WE
GONNA BE SUBJECT SIX MONTHS. THE
OTHER LOW AND VERY LOW OUR PARTY
BASINS COULD VOLUNTARILY SUBMIT
PLANTS- SO THAT NINETY FOUR HIGH
AND MEDIUM PRIORITY BASINS-
INCLUDING TWENTY ONE THAT ARE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED IN
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
HAD. UP TILL TWENTY TWENTY TO
SUBMIT PLANS AND THAT REMAINS OF
THE HIGH IN MEDIA HI IN MEDIA
PARTY BASINS I HAD TILL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE OTHER KEY ARE
MILESTONE THAT WAS REACHED EARLY
ONWARDS THE FORMATION OF OUR
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES- AND THE SUBMISSION OF.
PLANS- DID MEET THE MILESTONES
FOR TWENTY TWENTY IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO I'M PLEASED TO
ANNOUNCE ALL THE PLANS THAT.
WERE DUE IN JANUARY HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED AND ARE. NOW CLOSED
FOR COMMENT. I WOULD LIKE TO-
ELSEWHERE TO THE DISCUSSION OF
DELIVERY OUT TO ROLLING SIX
MONTHS- ONE IS OUR REGULAR.
OVERSIGHT ROLE- BUT FIRST OF
LIKE TO WITH HOURS BROUGHT-
THOSE. VERY WHAT DO BECAUSE IT'S
YOU KNOW IT IT IS OUR PRIME TASK. TO- INSURE THAT THESE BROWN
STAND AGENCIES- DO HAVE COMPLY.
PLANS THAT YOU'RE COMPLY WITH
THE LAW REGULAR BUT WERE ALSO
ASSIST IN THEIR EFFORT- TO GET
TOWARDS. BECAUSE AT THE END THE
DAY THAT'S REALLY REALLY AREN'T
IS TO ENSURE THE- CALIFORNIA'S
GROUNDWATER THE LOCAL.
COMMUNITIES IN BUYING A NEW CAR
EIGHT. HOURS WILL- EXXON THINK
THAT IS GOOD SO WE COULD GO.
FIVE FOUR. AND I'LL IN WITH US
OF THE SYSTEMS PRO. SO TOO MANY
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND-
INVESTED TO DATE- ONE PROGRAM SO
- A HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX NOW
DOLLARS HAS BEEN AWARDED TO AND
THOSE COVERS- HELLO OF ASPECTS
GROUNDWATER- TO STANDING BELOW
PLAN TO TELL. OUR AS WELL AS
SOME IMPLEMENT STEP THAT
INCLUDES- DEVELOPMENT OF- OUR
RECHARGE PROJECTS OTHER WATER
SUPPLY PROJECTS TO HELP SUSTAIN
THE BASIC- IT'S ALL. ENGAGED I
READ GAVE EFFORTS WHICH WAS SICK
MOST OF THEM VERY BAR- FOR
ENGAGED- AND WE'RE REALLY WHAT
TO THAT THOSE AGENCIES ON TAKING
. THE FACT THAT MONTH USE.
TECHNICAL IS ACTUALLY YOU A LOT
OF BASINS DID HAVE A SOLID
FOUNDATION ON WATER MANAGEMENT-
BUT ELECTED NOT AND WE ALSO
WANTED TO PROVIDE A FLOOR FOR
CONSISTENCY OF USING THE BEST
SCIENCE THAT'S AVAILABLE. ARE
ONE TOOL THAT WE HAVE COME OUT
WITH THIS- THAT GROUNDWATER DATA
AND TOOLS ARE READILY AVAILABLE-
I SHOULD POINT OUT JUST
RELEASED. THERE ARE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER THAT'S CALLED
BULLETIN ONE EIGHTEEN EARLIER
THIS YEAR AND ACCOMPANYING MATH-
WAS CALL CALIFORNIA GROUNDWORK
ALIVE WHICH TAKES A LOT OF OUR
DATA. SUBSIDENCE OUR WATER
SUPPLY- THE END USE IN A WAY
THAT IS EASILY ACCESSIBLE- COULD
NOT ONLY AGENCIES BUT THE PUBLIC
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO ARE
ENGAGING IN- THE- IMPLEMENTATION
OF STIGMA THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO OUR DATA AND TOOLS.
FANSERVICE. LICENSE DATA- WE'RE
- TO GET INVESTMENTS TO. ALL IN
DATA WHICH IS GOING TO GET WE
VERY SHORTLY AND DEMO THE READY
SIDE WE ARE CROSS STATE AND NOW
WE GOING TO BE ABLE TO RUN BACK
. AND THAT WILL GIVE UP- WHAT.
ARE SUBSIDENCE ARTHROPATHY ARE
IT WARNED ALECTO MATT MEDICAL
ARE YOU SEE THAT ON THE RIGHT
HAND SIDE WITH THE WHO- THIS
WILL A NOTHER- DRUG RESULTS-
FUNDING THE WE GOT THIS YEAR UT
ALL TIED CLOSE TO WHAT AGENCIES
NEED FOR. WHAT IT DOES IS ALMOST
LIKE A AND M. R. FOR- THE SORT
IT CHOOSE A LOT OF MAGNETICS
DOWN AND- ALLOWS US TO-
BASICALLY MAP OUT THE GEOLOGIC
ARCHITECTURE DOESN'T FIND WATER
BUT IT ABSOLUTELY. G. A LOCKET.
OCT OF THE SOIL. NOT A LOT OF
THE BETTER PLACE OF WELL I.
RECHARGE I THANK SUPPORT WE DO
INSTALL MONITOR WELLS- WELL THE
STATE WITHOUT A HIGH TWENTY
MARCH THOUSAND TODAY. I GONNA
HUNDREDS OF EIGHT MARCH WELLS IN
THE PROCESS. BEING INSTALLED IN
A DAY. TO STREAM. AT- BECAUSE-
STE. ARE IS CRITICAL AS WELL AS
BOB TO AND THEN HE GOES- AND
AGAIN- NEW EFFORTS ON WHY COME.
WATER TRAY- ANY. ARE THAT ARE
LOOKING TO BALANCE THEIR ARE
BROWN WANTED BASED OUT. ARE
GOING TO HELP OUR FOR AND LIMIT
THE ALLOCATION OF GROUND. HAVING
TOOLS BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND
IT'S IT WAS GOING TO BE- I THINK
OUR REGIONAL OFFICES HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL- WE ALSO PROVIDE-
WE HAVE- ENGAGING WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS- AND WE'VE PRODUCED
MANY OUR COMMUNICATION
ENGAGEMENT GUIDANCE THE GUIDANCE
DOCUMENTS ARE TO HELP ASSIST AND
GUIDE THE AGENCIES ON NOT JUST.
YOUKNOW APPROACH IS THE NEED TO
TAKE BUT WHAT WE DO IS THE
COMPLIANCE THEY'LL TAKE IN
REVEALING HOW THE CONDUCTING
THEIR BUSINESS AND- STAND
ABILITY. ONE ASPECT THAT'S BEEN
ABSOLUTELY CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FACILITATION SUPPORT SERVICES-
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT DURING
THE GROUND WATER GOVERNANCE
DEVELOPMENT- IN THE
FACILITATORS- WORK. WITH THE
AGENCIES BUT ALSO A LOT FOR
GOING TO ENJOY OUR COMMUNICATION
WITH PUBLIC OF PUBLIC MEETINGS
TO REALLY ALLOW THE. AGENCIES TO
GET BOTH- FOR ENGAGEMENT THE
PUBLIC AND IT'S BEEN A NUMBER SO
IMPORTANT FOR GSA FORMATION AND
NOW THROUGH DEVELOPMENT OF THE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS- THAT WORKS CONTINUED AND
NOW IN THEM IMPLEMENTATIONS
BECOMING EVEN MORE IMPORTANT.
ARE WRITTEN LIKE TRANSLATION
SERVICES- WE HAVE TRANSACTION
SERVICES FOR DOCUMENTS AGENCIES
HAVE UP TO EIGHT DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES R. AS WELL AS OTHER
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND- MATERIALS
. NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU NOW I'M
GONNA SWITCH TO OUR REGULATORY
ROLE- AND THE NEXT SLIDE WILL
DESCRIBE THE OF THE PROCESS.
WE'RE FOLLOWING- YES NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE- SO THAT'S ANOTHER NUMBER
PATHWAYS WE HAVE TWO YEARS TO
REVIEW PLANS IS THAT IS THE
CEMENT- ONCE THEY SUBMIT THEM
INTO THE DEPARTMENT I SHOULD
NOTE THAT WHEN AGENCIES EVEN THE
PLAN THAT WAS SUBMITTED IN
TWENTY TWENTY THEY DID NOT WAIT
FOR US TO REVIEW AND APPROVE OF
THE PLANTS ARE GIVE THEM
FEEDBACK- THEY WERE IMMEDIATELY
TASKED WITH STARTING TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE PLANS IN A
NUMBER OF AGENCIES WAS TAKEN-
VERY MEANINGFUL STEPS TOWARDS
SUSTAINABILITY. WHILE WE
COMPLETED THEIR REVIEW- SO WHEN
I REVIEW IS DONE WE HAVE A
COUPLE PATHWAYS- ONE IS
APPROVING THE PLAN- AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT EVEN UPON PLAN
APPROVAL AND WE HAVE APPROVED A
PLANS. YEAH DOESN'T AND THE
PROCESS THAT ACT BEGAN- THE
PROCESS OF OUR CONTENT OVERSIGHT
OF- IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT PLAN
SO YOU KNOW ONCE WE APPROVE THE
PLAN AS ITS COMPLIANCE- BUT WE
EXPECT PLANS TO ADAPT OVER TIME
ON AND WE HAVE A NUMBER
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS- FOR
APPROVED. SO JUST BEGINS THE
OVERSIGHT- WE ALSO HAVE A
PROCESS FOR THE INITIAL REVIEW
INCOMPLETE- WHICH REALLY
IDENTIFIES A NUMBER OF
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS AND
DEFICIENCIES IN THOSE PLANS THAT
WE HAVE FOR THOSE AGENCIES A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS SIX MONTHS
TO CORRECT THOSE ARE AND IF
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO CORRECT
THOSE CONSULTATION WITH OUR
PARTNERS STATE BOARD WE CAN DEEM
THE PLANTS AND ADEQUATE AND THEN
IT'LL RESULT IN STATE BOARD
EMPLOYEE- INTERVENTION- SO. WE
RECOGNIZE- YOU KNOW FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY PLANS- YOU KNOW
OUR OUR STANDARD WAS SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE- ARE THE REGULATIONS
IN THE SCHOOLS. I THINK IT- VERY
EASTSTRICT STANDARD WE WERE
LOOKING AT ME- YOU KNOW IT-
VERY- MINDFUL THAT WE WANT THESE
LOCAL AGENCIES TO RETAIN LOCAL
CONTROL AND ACHIEVE
SUSTAINABILITY BUT THEY MUST DO
IT UNDER A PLAN THAT IS
COMPLIANT WITH THE LAW AND
REGULATIONS. THOSE DEFICIENCIES
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THE
NUMBER OF AGENCIES DID FIND THAT
THEY ARE WORLD LOOKING TO
ELIMINATE OVER DRAFTED IN TWENTY
YEARS- BUT WE WANTED IT IS LAW
CALLS FOR THEY MUST DO THAT IN A
WAY THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT ALL
THE BENEFICIAL USES AND USES THE
GROUNDWATER. AND THAT INCLUDES
DOMESTIC WELL USERS- ARAB
WILDWATER PREPARES- WETLANDS AND
GROUNDWATER DEPENDENT
ECOSYSTEMS- AND WHAT THEY NEED
TO WORK OUT ITS. TWENTY YEARS.
WHAT- I'M WAS ARE GOING TO. FIND
WHAT BROUGH LEVEL SECTION
STORAGE OF TITANS TO WATER
QUALITY C. WATER INTRUSION INTO
OF INTERCONNECT SERVICE WATERS
ALL THESE SECTION. ABOUT WORKING
BY DO WE ARE TO COMPLY WITH THE
RAGS- BUT WE REALLY FOCUSED
INITIALLY ON THIS DENTAL
MANAGEMENT CRITERIA HAVE THEY-
ADEQUATELY DETERMINED- WHETHER.
IS SIGNIFICANT REASONABLE TAX ON
ALL OF OUR USERS FROM THE SIX
UNDESIRABLE RESULTS. SO WE
WANTED TO- BESIDES THAT IDENTIFY
WHETHER THEY USE THE BEST
SCIENCE AND DATA- WHAT WAS
REALLY THEIR PLAN TO MITIGATE OR
ELIMINATE OVERDRAFT AND DO THEY
HAVE A- ADEQUATE SUITE OF
PROJECTS OF MANAGEMENT ACTIONS-
THAT WOULD. LEAD AND IF I CHOOSE
TO STAND ABILITY OVER TWENTY
YEARS- WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
INITIAL LIST OF PROJECT
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS- MAYBE OUR
PULLING IN AREAS PROJECTS NEED
TO BE DEVELOPED FOR THE
DEVELOPING ALLOCATION SCHEMES.
AND SO ONE OF OUR CORRECTION
ACTIONS AS WE DO WANT IT A
PRETTY BROAD SUITE OF OUR
CONTINGENCIES IN THE EVENT SOME
OF THOSE PROJECTS MANAGEMENT
ACTIONS- DOCTOR FOR WHICH- WE
WILL ALSO IN. BY COMMENT- WE PUT
OFFER PUBLIC COMMENT AS WELL AS
- FOR THE LOW AGE. TO HAVE A COM
PERIOD- WE DO REVIEW ALL THE
COMMENTS WE'VE GOT OVER FIVE
HUNDRED COMMENTS. FROM THE
PUBLIC ON THE PLANS- AND MORE
MORE THAN EIGHTY INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS. SO NOW I'M GOING
TO SWITCH- AND TRIED TO THE
CURRENT STATUS OF WHAT WAS BEING
IMPLEMENTATION THAT'S NOT PLEASE. SO WE DID IT OUT OF THE TWENTY
PLANS ARE SUBMITTED- WE DID
APPROVED EIGHT PLANTS- AND THE
MAP ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE I
IDENTIFIES- THOSE BASINS WORK-
AND AGAIN WE FOUND YOU KNOW EVEN
WITH APPROVED PLANS NO PLAN IS
PERFECT- WE DO RECOMMEND A
NUMBER OF CORRECTIVE ACTIONS.
ALL THE STAFF IN A MOMENT- AND
THEN REALLY THE SUB SUB FOR THE
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS AND THOSE
OTHER- FILE ITEMS WE IDENTIFIED-
FOR OUR FULL REVIEW OUR FULL
FIVE YEAR REVIEW WHICH IS A
NOTHER COMPLIANCE CHECKPOINT.
ARE TO DETERMINE ARE THEY ON
TRACK OTHER YOU KNOW THAT PLAN
IS COMPLIANT- BUT- THEY WALKING
THE WALK THEY ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING AND TAKING THOSE
ACTIONS ARE NEEDED TO REACH
STAND ABILITY AND IT ANYTIME IF
WE FIND AN AGENCY IS FAILING TOP
LIVE. LIVE UP TO WHAT THEY HAVE
PUT INTO THEIR PLAN OKAY NOT
GOING TOWARD SUSTAINABILITY WE
CAN GO BACK AND CALL THE PLAN
AND ADEQUATE AND HAVE THE-
RESULT IN. ORDER TO PENSION AND
TELL THEY GET THEIR PLAN. AND
THEIR ACTIONS BACK ON TRACK-
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO THE
TWELFTH PLANS THAT WE'RE
GETTING- INCOMPLETE WE'RE BASED
UPON NUMBER OF DEFICIENCIES AND
THEY NEED TO- CORRECT THOSE
DEFICIENCIES- WITHIN A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS. OUT ONE THING ON
OUR- OUR REFUSES WE REVIEWED THE
PLANS AS THEY WERE SUBMITTED IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY A
NUMBER OF THE AGENCIES SINCE
TWENTY TWENTY IT- ADAPTED THEIR
PLAN BASED UPON NEW INFORMATION
HEARD GOTTEN- THE DATA. OR HAD
TAKEN DIFFERENT APPROACHES- SO
AS WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE- YEP
SPOCK THE DEFICIENCIES WE EXPECT
THAT THEY MAY BE PROVIDING US
MORE UPDATED INFORMATION ON THE
PLAN OR MANY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO REDO OF THE APPROACH THAT
TAKEN TO BE COMPLIANT- BROWN
SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT EVEN THESE
PLANTS THAT HAVE. BEEN DEEMED
COMPLETE AND HAVE CERTAIN
DEFICIENCIES MANY HAVE TAKEN
CONSIDERABLE STEPS TO- TOWARDS
SUSTAINABILITY INCLUDING
RECHARGE WATER SUPPLY
AUGMENTATION AND- ALLOCATION
REDUCTIONS TO REDUCE THE DEMAND
ON THE BASIS. SO WE'RE EXPECTING
THEM TO CONTINUE THAT AS WE GO
THROUGH THAT CORRECTING THE
DEFICIENCIES IT MAY WE WANT THEM
TO CONTINUE ON THAT PATH TO
SUSTAINABILITY BUT IT MIGHT JUST
CHANGE WHERE THE GOAL LINE IS
THAT THEY NEED TO GET TO
RESPECT BOTH OF THE CRITERIA.
NOW I'D LIKE TO GO THROUGH. SO
THAT MAKE IT OVER ARCHING ISSUES
WITH PHOTOS. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
SO SOME OF THE COMMON ERROR
DEFICIENCIES- ONE WAS-
SUBSIDENCE- AND THAT WAS COMMON
IN A NUMBER OF BASINS AND THE
ONE THING THAT SIGNAL DOES CALL
FOR IS THE ELIMINATION OR
MINIMIZATION OF SUBSIDES- NUMBER
PLANS REDUCE FINE BASED UPON OUR
REVIEW. I DID A LOT FOR
CONTINUED SUBSIDENCE- AND ALSO
DID NOT FULLY ADDRESS ALL THE
GROUND WATER USES AND USES THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MAY BE
AFFECTED AND DESCRIBING THAT.
WITH WATER QUALITY A NUMBER OF
THE PLANS DID- RESULTED IN A AND
IT'S ACTUALLY HELPING- WIND OR
HUNDREDS OF WELLS THAT COULD BE
DE WATERED- AND GO DRY UPON
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PLANT. NOW
WHAT WE ARE. REQUIRED THEM TO DO
IS TO- DO COOL THINGS IS EITHER
COME BACK AND JUSTIFY HOW THEY
FEEL THAT THAT IS NOT SIGNIFICAN
AND REASONABLE SOMEONE'S WATER
SUPPLY GOING DRY. GIVEN THE- A
MANDATE ON HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
OR ALTERNATIVELY COME BACK AND-
BUT IN MITIGATION MEASURES AND
OTHER AUGMENTATION TO EITHER BE
PROTECTIVE OF OUR DRINKING WATER
SOURCES OR TO MITIGATE- WELLS
GOING DRY NUMBER OF AGENCIES
HAVE PROPOSED DOING THIS BUT A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THEY DID NOT-
WE FOUND THAT. ALSO PROMPTED US
TO PUT OUT AND DEVELOP GUIDANCE-
WHICH WE'RE LOOKING TO DO AND-
WHAT THE NEXT STOP FOR SIX
MONTHS OR SO GUIDANCE ON ON
WATER QUALITY AND PROTECTION IN
JACKET WATER- IN WATER QUALITY
ONE OF THE THINGS WE FOUND- IS
BASINS THAT ARE ARE GOING TO
HELP THE CHRONICLE OF PATIENTS
GLOBAL OF HISTORIC LOWS I HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO DESCRIBE TO
KEEP CLOSER TRACK ON WHAT THAT
IS GOING TO DO FOR WATER QUALITY
ISSUES WITHIN THEIR BASE. SO
WE'LL BE LOOKING FOR M. SCRIBE
OR OVERSIGHT ON AND TRACKING OF
WATER QUALITY DEPLETION OF
INTERCONNECTED SURFACE WATERS
THIS WAS A COMMON DATA GAP THIS
IS A. AREA THAT IS NOT- READ
ONLY FLUSHED OUT OF MATH. ARE
IT'S CLEAR IMPORTANT AS MANY OF
KNOW THE FIRST WATER GET TAKEN
OF THE BASIN IS IF IT'S
CONNECTED TO A SERVER WATER PUMP
THE CREEK IN STRONG. THAT'S VERY
FOR BROWN ONE ECOSYSTEMS AND
AQUATIC- SPECIES SO- METHODOLOGY
IS BEING DEVELOPED AND I'M BURKE
AGENCIES JEWS ARE PROXIES OR
GROUNDWATER LEVELS AS A PROXY.
ENTERING THINGS DATA GAPS ARE
FILLED WHICH- IS ALLOWABLE BUT
WE WANT SPECIFIC MINIMUM
THRESHOLD BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
FOR DEPLETION OF INTERCONNECTED.
SURFACE WATER AND LASTLY A
NUMBER OF PLANS HAD- LACK OF
COORDINATION THEY HAD MULTIPLE
PLANS WITHIN THE BASIN WHICH IS
A LOT. BUT PROVIDED THEY NEED TO
HAVE THE SAME DATA AND SAME
METHODOLOGY AND WE FOUND THAT-
THEY DID NOT SO THOSE ARE. OUR
COMMUNICATIONS ARE ARE.
CONTINUING- OTHER AREAS OF THE-
IN THE THESE ARE THE MAIN ERROR
THAT WOULD DESTROY THAT LED TO
INCOMPLETE- BUT WE FOUND FOR ALL
THE PLANS WE WANTED A BROADER
SET OF CONTINGENCY FOR PROJECTS
FOR THE FUTURE- WE WANTED OUR-
CONTINUED GREATER TRANSPARENCY
ON THAT PROCESS WITH THE PUBLIC-
MORE DETAILS ON HOW THEY INTEND
TO FILL DATA GAPS. IN AND AGAIN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT-
IS SOMETHING THAT IS GONE YOUR
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING TO- WORK WITH
THE AGENCIES AND PROVIDE TOOLS
AND GUIDANCE- TO IMPROVE THAT-
AND THEN INTERFACE IN
COORDINATION IS ALSO GOING TO BE
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO- TRACK AS WE GO THROUGH THOSE
FIRST EARLY STAGES OF. THE FIRST
FIVE YEARS OF IMPLEMENTATION AND
THIS ENSURES THAT ONE BASINS
PLAN IS NOT GOING TO PRECLUDE
ANOTHER JOHNNY GRAYSON FROM.
NICHOLS AND LASTLY- WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER THE- DATA ON
THE MOST OF YOUR CHANGE
CONDITION THE STRAW WE HAVE
THAT'S- THE MOST HISTORIC WENT
YEAR FOLLOWING. THE BUT MAJOR
DROP WE HAD. YOU KNOW THE PLANS-
NO ONE REALLY WOULD PROTECT IT
THIS TYPE OF HYDROLOGY DOUBLE
CAB BUT IT'S THE REALITY AND
IT'S THE FUTURE- SO WE'RE GOING
TO BE WORKING OVERTIME TO HAVING
PLANS- ADDRESS IN AND BE ALMOST
STRESS TEST TOWARDS THE MORE
SEVERE DROUGHT AND CLIMATE
CHANGE SCENARIOS OVER
EXPERIENCING SO. THAT MAY LEAD
TO FURTHER ADOPTION OF THESE
PLANS OVER TIME SO AT THE END OF
THE DAY IN TWENTY YEARS. WE'RE
GONNA EXPECT THESE PHARMACIST
AND ABILITY PLANTS TO BE
RESILIENT TOWARDS THE MOST
SEVERE. DROUGHT CONDITIONS WE'RE
GOING TO FACE. LIKE WITH. SO
SOME GOOD NEWS ON. AND SOME
MILESTONES- WE HAD TWENTY TWENTY
PLAN SUBMITTED IN JANUARY SIXTY
FIVE PLANES FROM- SIXTY THREE
BASINS- WE HAD FIVE PLANS FROM
ALL THAT WOULD VOLUNTARY LOW AND
VERY LOW PRIORITY BASINS- WE ARE
ALL POSTED FOR A SEVENTY FIVE
DAY COMMENT PERIOD AND WE'RE BUT
WE DO WHICH WE DON'T. ACCEPT
COMMENTS AT ANY TIME WE HAVE A
TWO YEAR CYCLE TO REVIEW THESE
PLANS AND WORDS JUST INITIATING
THAT PROCESS SO- WE WILL ACCEPT
COMMENTS- AS CLOSE TO REACHING
OUT FORMAL DETERMINATION ON
THESE PLANTS ARE. EXCELLENT WITH
. SO WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE
FOR THE PLANS- YOU KNOW THE NEXT
STEP FOR GSA'S THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO PLANS AGAIN- WAS SUBMITTED
AND EIGHT ARE. ACCEPTED AND
AGAIN THEY WERE JUST BEGINNING
THE PROCESS OF CONTINUING DOWN
THAT PLOWED PATH WILL BE-
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT AND WE DO
HAVE CORRECTIVE ACTIONS- AND FOR
THE PLANS THAT ARE INCOMPLETE
THEY'RE THEY'RE ON THE CLOCK FOR
A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS. TO OUR
RESOLVE THE DEFICIENCIES- WE'RE
CONSULTING WITH THEM- TO EXPLAIN
WHAT WE FOUND- I BY THE END OF.
IT'S GOING TO BE A BINARY JUST
IF THEY DO NOT GET THEIR-
UPDATED PLAN INTO US- OR IF WE
REVIEW WHAT THEY SUBMITTED AND
FINED IF THEY FAIL TO ADDRESS
ALL THE DEFICIENCIES- THAT WILL
RESULT IN US DEEMING THE PLAN
INADEQUATE AND RESULT IN STATE
BOARD- INTERVENTION. WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A SIXTY DAY
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THE PLANS
THAT ARE- AMENDED PLANS OF THE
SUBMITTED AND THEN IN JANUARY
TOOL FOR THE PUBLIC TO COMMENT.
ON THAT ALSO- AND AGAIN FOR
BONTA BASIN PLAN'S GONNA NEED TO
ALL THE- COORDINATOR AND UPDATED
- I GET THROUGH THIS. WE HAVE
WITH THE BOARD OF WORKING
RELATIONSHIP IS ARE. WORKING
VERY WELL AND- BURKE TREES
WITHOUT. WITH THE STATE BOARD.
ARE WE ARE EXPECTING ALL THE
PLANS TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THEIR ANNUAL REPORTS EVEN THE
PLANTS OF THE SUBMITTED IN
JANUARY AB PEOPLE FIRST ALL I'M
JUST THERE AND FIRST IN RIVER.
WILL GIVE CLOSE AT FIVE YEAR
UPDATE- IN THE FUTURE YOU KNOW
OUR SYSTEMS AND THE. INVESTMENTS
THAT ARE MADE OF. SHE WAS THESE
AGENCIES ARE GOING TO NEED TO
MAKE. OUR A LOT OF THE AGENCY TO
ARE WHO. ARE AND THEY'RE NEW TO
WHY MANAGEMENT OR- STILL. GOING
TO SOME. GROWING PAINS FUNDING
AND THAT JUSTIN. TO LOOKING INTO
AGENCY- AND SO IS WHY IS. VERY
IMPORTANT BUT WE ARE GOING TO
GROW THAT THESE. WHAT HOW THEY
CONDUCT SO. THERE TATIAN IS TO
BECOME EVERYCHOICE TO STAND-
THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT ALL OF
OUR WATER USES AND USERS- SO
WITH THAT OUR NEXT LOVE. THANK
YOU- I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY CHANCE YOUR QUESTION
. YOUR THOUGHTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT OVERVIEW
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL WILL MOVE TO
JAMES KNOCK OUR DIRECTOR OF
OFFICE OF RESEARCH PLANNING AND
PERFORMANCE AT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. CAME TO
THEIR- YES GOOD MORNING- THANKS
I HAVE A SINCE IT LOOKS LIKE
I'VE GOT SHARON ACCIDENTS IT
WOULD GO. SO GOOD MORNING THE
SHARES OF VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I AM JAMES KNOCK POWER THE
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH PLANNING
AND PERFORMANCE FOR THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
I'M HAPPY TO BE FOLLOWING DUE TO
BE ARE HERE- I WILL BE JOINED
SHORTLY BY TWO OF MY COLLEAGUES-
NATALIE STARK CONTAMINATED I'LL
START BY GIVING OUT. AN
OVERVIEW- SO IN SIGNAL THE STATE
ROLE IS LIMITED BUT IT IS CLEAR-
ACID SAYS THE ACT WHERE LOCAL OR
LOCAL GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY IS NOT MANAGING ITS
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABLY THE
STATE NEEDS TO PROTECT THE
RESOURCE UNTIL A LOCAL
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY. CAN SUSTAINABLY MANAGE
THE GROUNDWATER BASIN. AND THIS
IS A GREAT TIME FOR THIS HEARING
IT COMES AT A REALLY GOOD TIME
BECAUSE WE ARE AT THIS POINT OF
TRANSITION POTENTIALLY- FROM THE
DEPARTMENT- MAKING ITS
DETERMINATIONS TO THE STATE
BOARD CONSIDERING- FURTHER
ACTIONS. BUT I DO WANT TO LOOK
BACK A LITTLE BIT WHAT WE AT THE
STATE WATER BOARD HAVE BEEN
DOING TO DATE UNDER CIGNA- AND
SHOWN HERE ON THE SLIDE WE'VE
BEEN SUPPORTING THESE LOCAL
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES AND A NUMBER OF WAYS.
YES THEY HAVE BEEN CREATING
THERE ARE LOCAL PLANS WHICH ARE
REALLY REALLY COMPLICATED IN
MANY CASES- THE COMPLICATED
BECAUSE THEY NEED TO TRACK. I'M
WATER CONDITIONS- THE LOCAL
NEEDS- THE FUTURE CONDITIONS
THEY'D LIKE TO ATTAIN. AND THEY
ALSO NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW THE
VARIOUS PROJECTS FOR MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES THEY CAN CONSIDER
WHAT ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTE TO
THEIR GOALS AND OBJECTIVES. SO
THESE PLANS ARE REALLY DETAILED
AND REALLY COMPLICATED. WE HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- WE'VE BEEN. GIVING
INFORMATIVE PRESENTATIONS AND
CREATING FACT SHEETS WE'VE ALSO
SUPPORTED A FACILITATION- GET A
COUPLE BASINS. INCLUDING THE ST
LOUIS RAY AND SIERRA VALLEY
BASINS. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
CONSULTING WITH T. W. R.
THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE PROCESS-
HANNAN'S PROVIDING. YOU KNOW
JUST PERSPECTIVES AND THAT. HAS
TAKEN ON THE ROLE- THE TAKEN ON
THE FORM AND SOME CASES OF
FORMAL COMMENT LETTERS FROM THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD TO THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. THAT WE PROVIDED
TWELVE COMMENT LETTERS TO THIS
POINT- IN THESE ARE SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON TOPICS WITHIN THEWATER BOARD'S- JURISDICTION
INCLUDING DRINKING WATER ISSUES
WATER QUALITY ISSUES ISSUES OF
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN. SURFACE
WATERS LIKE WETLANDS. AND
GROUNDWATER. AND SO THAT'S WHERE
WE'VE BEEN TO THIS POINT AND WE
ARE NOW POTENTIALLY AT A
TRANSITION POINT WHERE WE MAY BE
MOVING INTO- WHAT'S CALLED STATE
INTERVENTION STATE INTERVENTION
UNDER SIGNAL HAS TWO PHASES. IS
A LARGE CIRCLES HERE ON THE
SLIDE A BASIN CAN BE PUT ON
PROBATION OR- AND MAYBE LATER A
BASIN CAN BE MADE SUBJECT TO AN
INTERIM PLAN DEVELOPED BY THE
STATE WATER BOARD. EACH OF THOSE
TWO PHASES OF INTERVENTION- CAN
ONLY OCCUR FOLLOWING A DECISION
BY THE STATE WATER BOARD BOB
STANFORD IN THE FIRST CASE STILL
BE EVALUATING AND CONSIDERING IF
INTERVENTION IS WARRANTED- AND
IN THE SECOND CASE BEFORE AN
INTERIM PLAN IS DEVELOPED- AND
IMPOSED THE WATER BOARD WILL BE
CONSIDERING IF THE ISSUES- IN
THE BASIN HAVE BEEN FIXED. OR
NOT. AND NOW I WILL- HIM THINGS
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE NATALIE
STARK. OKAY THANK YOU JAMES HI
MY NAME IS NATALIE STARK I'M A
SENIOR ENGINEERING GEOLOGIST IN
THE STATE WATER BOARDS GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IN THE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH FUNDING AND
PERFORMANCE. NOW THAT WE'VE HAD
A BIT OF A SUMMARY OF STATE
INTERVENTION. I'M GOING TO DIVE
IN AND TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE TODAY. AND THE
PROCESS FOR MOVING TOWARDS A
PROBATIONARY DETERMINATION. SO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY IS IN THIS
FIRST BOX HERE THIS TIME TO CURE
PERIOD. THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES HAS DETERMINED THAT
SEVERAL PLANS ARE INCOMPLETE.
NOW LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS TO FIX
THE ISSUES WITH THE PLANS. AT
THE END OF THAT PERIOD D. W. R.
WILL MAKE A DETERMINATION. ARE
THE PLANS ADEQUATE OR INADEQUATE
. IF THE PLANS ARE IN ANY OF THE
PLANS ARE INADEQUATE THE BOARD
WILL ASSESS THE DEFICIENCIES AND
DETERMINE WHETHER IT IS
WARRANTED TO MOVE TOWARDS A
PROBATIONARY HEARING. IF THE
BOARD DECIDES TO MOVE TOWARDS A
HEARING. THE PORT HAS NOTICING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN THE
STATUTE. THE BOARD HAS TO
PROVIDE NINETY DAYS OF NOTICE TO
CITIES COUNTIES AND GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES TO
NOTIFY THEM OF THE HEARING. THE
BOARD ALSO HAS TO PROVIDE SIXTY
DAYS OF NOTICE TO ALL OF THE
KNOWN AND- EXPECTED GROUNDWATER
PUMPERS IN THE GROUNDWATER BASIN
. THE BOARD MAY OPT TO HOLD
WATER MORE PUBLIC MEETINGS TO
REACH OUT TO STAKEHOLDERS AND
INTERESTED PARTIES TO LET THEM
KNOW WHAT A PROBATIONARY
DETERMINATION COULD MEAN FOR THE
BASIN. BAND THE PORTAL TO
HEARING AND DECIDES WHETHER OR
NOT TO ADOPT AN ORDER DECLARING
THAT THE SECRETARY. IF THE BOARD
PUTS THE BASE ON PROBATION.
TSA'S HAVE ONE YEAR TO ADD SORRY
IF THE BOARD- PUTS THE BASIN ON
PROBATION. I'M THERE'S AT LEAST
ONE YEAR BEFORE THE STATE WATER
BOARD CAN DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
AN INTERIM PLAN AND THE LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE TIME TO WORK ON
FIXING THOSE ISSUES THAT. BUT
THE BASE ON PROBATION. THE WHOLE
TIME WILL BE CLOSELY
COORDINATING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES SINCE THE
GOAL IS FOR BASS AND STICK IT
BACK ON THE D. W. R. TRACK.
EXCITED PLEASE. SO NOW THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW. WE'VE
MOVED TOWARDS A PROBATIONARY
DETERMINATION IF IT IS WARRANTED
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT IT MEANS FOR BASS AND TO BE
ON PROBATION. THE FIRST THING IS
THAT THE BOARD. AFTER THE
DETERMINATION WOULD IDENTIFY THE
DEFICIENCIES THAT RESULTED IN
THE BASIN BEING PUT ON PROBATION
AND TRACK THE PROGRESS OF LOCAL
AGENCIES AS THEY WORK TO FIX
THOSE ISSUES. SINCE THE BOARD
HAS TO WAIT AT LEAST ONE YEAR
BEFORE DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING AN INTERIM PLAN
THIS PROVIDES TIME FOR AGENCIES
TO WORK TO ADDRESS THOSE
DEFICIENCIES. IN CASE THE BOARD
NEEDS TO DEVELOP ITS OWN PLAN-
AN INTERIM PLAN THE BOARD NEEDS
TO COLLECT DATA AND INFORMATION
SO THAT IT'S ABLE TO DO SO AS
SUCH THE BOARD WILL REQUIRE
REPORTING. AND MAY REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IN THE
FORM OF INVESTIGATIONS. IN ORDER
TO COLLECT ACCURATE DATA THE
BOARD MAY REQUIRE METERS. AND
THE STATUTE REQUIRES THE BOARD
TO RECOVER THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM AND SO ANYONE WHO IS
REQUIRED TO REPORT THEIR
GROUNDWATER EXTRACTIONS THE
BOARD WILL ALSO BE REQUIRED TO
PAY A FEE. I WANT TO ADD IN HERE
THAT. AT ANY TIME IF THE LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE ABLE TO FIX THE
ISSUES THAT RESULTED IN THE
BASIN BEING PUT ON PROBATION.
THEY CAN PETITION THE BOARD AND
THE STATE INTERVENTION PROCESS.
WE DON'T WANT TO PUT ANY BASINS
ON PROBATION OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
LOCAL AGENCIES BE SUCCESSFUL AND
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING TOWARDS THE ENTIRE TIME
INCLUDING INFORMATION. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. SO FAR WE STEP
THROUGH WHAT IT MEANS TO.
HEADWORDS PROBATION TO BE PUT ON
PROBATION- AND I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IF ISSUES AREN'T FIXED
DURING THAT PERIOD WHAT SENATE
TERM PLAN. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
YOU'RE A FREAK FEW BRIEF DETAILS
. THE CORNERSTONE OF THE INTERIM
PLAN AS CORRECTIVE ACTIONS IN
THOSE ARE TO GET THE BASIN BACK
ON TRACK AN INTERIM PLAN WILL
ALSO INCLUDE MONITORING TO
MEASURE HOW THOSE ACTIONS ARE
WORKING. SCHEDULE FOR THE
ACTIONS AND ENFORCEMENT TO
ENSURE THE PLAN IS FOLLOWED. THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING HERE IS
THAT AN INTERN PLAN IT'S
TEMPORARY IT'S NOT MEANT TO
REPLACE THE GST- IT'S MEANT TO
GET THE BASE AND BACK ON TRACK
TOWARD SUSTAINABILITY WELL GSA'S
FIX THE ISSUES AND THEIR
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY PLANS
SO THAT MANAGEMENT OF THE BASE
AND CAN BE HANDED BACK. TO LOCAL
AGENCIES. THAT WRAPS UP MY
SUMMARY OF WHERE WE ARE TODAY
WITH STATE INTERVENTION- NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE AT AN INTERESTING
SIDE NOTE IS THAT THE SEVERAL
BASINS I HAVE RECENTLY MOVED
TOWARDS COMPREHENSIVE
ADJUDICATIONS AND SO I WOULD
LIKE TO HAND IT OFF TO TINA
CANNON LAZY TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE ADJUDICATION PROCESS.
AND IN LINE WITH THE STREAMLINED
EDUCATION ACT. SO GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIRS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE IN FRONT OF YOU IT'S A
LITTLE BIT INTERESTING FOR ME
SINCE I WAS THE PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT FOR WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE. DURING THE TIME THAT
WE WERE DRAFTING SICKNESS AND I
FIND MYSELF ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE VIRTUAL TABLE BUT IT'S VERY
NICE TO BE HERE- SO I'M JUST
GOING TO. ADDRESS WOULD YOU TO
CATIONS VERY QUICKLY SO THAT'S
HOW WE CAN MOVE TO ANY
QUESTIONS. SO EDUCATION IS A
COMPREHENSIVE IT'S LIKE WHEN A
COURT DOES A COMPREHENSIVE
DETERMINATION OF ALL OF THEIR
RIGHTS EITHER STREAM WATER
SYSTEM OR INTO GROUNDWATER BASIN
SO THAT SENATE JUDICATA. ANNA
SENATOR PROBABLY MENTIONED YOU
KNOW THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
WORK VERY CLOSELY IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SIGMA AND
FOLLOWING SIGNAL THE NEXT YEAR
SENATOR PROBABLY WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE SAME REMEMBER
LITTLE LISTEN LATE HOW IN ORDER
TO- MAKE SURE THAT.
ADJUDICATIONS WERE INTEGRATED
WITH CIGNA THERE WERE
STREAMLINED- PROVISIONS IN THE
CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE FOR
ADJUDICATIONS AND SO CURRENTLY
WHAT WE HAVE IS WHAT WE CALL
THIS COURT AFTER SUSTAINABILITY.
SO IT REQUIRES THAT COURTS. IN
CONDUCTING GROUNDWATER
ADJUDICATIONS ARE COGNIZANT OF
THE FACT THAT IT'S A BASIN IS
SOMETHING IS SUBJECT TO STIGMA
IS A HIGH OR MEDIUM PRIORITY
BASIN SUBJECT TO CIGNA THE DATA
JUDICATA IS NOT SUPPOSED TO
INTERFERE WITH THE ACHIEVEMENT
OF THE SUSTAINABILITY CALL
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH THE BOTTOM
LINE. AND IT DOES NOT IN VARIOUS
WAYS THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS
NOTIFIED THE DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCY- THE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES
REFUSE ANY FINAL ADJUDICATION
THE COURT CAN ASK THE STATE
WATER BOARD IN VARIOUS WAYS TO
ASSIST IT EITHER IT COULD
REFERENCE SOMETHING OVER TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD OR IT CAN ASK
FOR ASSISTANCE. FOR EXAMPLE AND
I'M BRINGING EXPERTISE TO THE
EDUCATION. SO THE COURT CAN ALL
. IMPLEMENTED A STAY PLATE.
JUDGMENT SO OAK IS ABLE. SORT OF
SIMILAR TO THE WAY THAT THE
BOARD PERHAPS IN IMPLEMENTING AN
INTERN PLAN. MIGHT TO RESTRICT
SMOKING THE COURT IS ABLE TO
PREVENT ANY NEW- WELLS OR
CAMPING OR TO LIMIT EXISTING
WELLS AND PUMPING. SO THERE'S
REMEDIES WITHIN THAT STREAMLINED
EDUCATION STATUTE FOR THE COURT.
TO LIMIT PUMPING AND AS I SAID
THERE'S VARIOUS CROSSOVERS
BETWEEN THE COURT PROCESS AND
THE SIGNAL PROCESS. SO I KNOW
THAT WAS KIND OF A BRIEF THE FLY
OVER BUT WITHOUT I'LL LEAVE IT
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL A
PRESENTATION AND NOW WE'RE GOING
TO TURN TO OUR WITNESSES THAT
ARE HERE WITH US IN THE ROOM SO
WILL INVITE AND- ALLEN. HEY NICK
AND OVER S. B. ABOU I GOT THAT
RIGHT APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T FROM
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN US. TRYING
THIS OUT FOR THIS IS THE FIRST
FIRST TIME THE BUILDING IN TWO
YEARS. GOOD MORNING WE LOVE BACK
THE CHANCE CHANCE TO SEE YOU ALL
IN THREE D. WAS WAS TOO MUCH. TO
RESIST. SO A GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRS NOT VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I'M ELLEN HANNEKE I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE WATER POLICY
CENTER AT THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I'M
HERE WITH MY COLLEAGUE OF OURS
GREW ABOUT WHO IS A SENIOR
FELLOW. AT PPA C. AND WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT ARE.
THE SOME OF THE BASES THAT ARE
ON THAT LIST OF INCOMPLETE. THAT
YOU HEARD ABOUT FROM. THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS IN THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSING ON. ISSUES
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. WHICH
ARGUABLY IS. SORT OF THE PLACE
THAT. REALLY MOTIVATED SEGMENT
TO BE ADOPTED IN THE FIRST PLACE
BECAUSE THIS WAS BACK DURING THE
LAST DROUGHT A LOT OF ISSUES
THERE WITH. LONG TERM OVERDRAFT
BUT THEN REALLY ACCELERATED
PUMPING LEADING TO ALL KINDS OF
PROBLEMS SO WHAT I'M GOING TO
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE FOR YOU IT'S
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF AN OVERVIEW
ON. SOME OF THE BIG ISSUES IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S THE NATURE OF
THE OVERDRAFT PROBLEM THERE. A
BIT ON SOME OF THE ON GOING
CHALLENGES. AND SOME. IDEAS FOR
WHAT THE STATE CAN DO AT THIS
POINT TO REALLY SUPPORT THE
LOCAL PROCESS SO. WITH THAT I
JUST ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS IS WORK THAT'S BEEN.
COLLABORATION OF A LOT OF FOLKS
FROM. ACROSS THE STATE AND MANY
VALLEY STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL AS
RESEARCHERS HAVE BEEN. INVOLVED
IN IN PROVIDING INPUT ON ON OUR
RESEARCH OVER THE- PAST FIVE
SEVEN YEARS. SO WITH THAT PLEASE
NEXT SLIDE. SO YOU'VE HEARD ALL
ABOUT SIGNAL ALREADY WHAT I JUST
WANTED TO. HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU
HERE IS THAT LAST LITTLE BIT
WHICH IS. THIS IDEA OF YOU KNOW
ARE WE MOVING FAST ENOUGH AND
SHOULD SET THE PACE BE PICKED UP
AND I THINK. THE KEY ISSUE THERE
IS THAT SAME AS KIND OF A
BALANCING ACT IT DOES PROVIDE A
FLEXIBLE TIMELINE. IT DOESN'T
SAY OVER BREATH TEST AND
TOMORROW. YOU KNOW YOU SUBMIT
YOUR PLANS THEN GOT TWENTY YEARS
TO GET TO FULL SUSTAINABILITY
BUT THERE ARE GUARDRAILS. AND
THIS IS THE KEY THING NOW WHEN
YOU'RE HEARING ABOUT. ADDRESSING
THE SIGNIFICANT UNREASONABLE
UNDESIRABLE RESULTS THAT YOU
HAVE TWENTY YEARS TO GET THERE
BUT IF YOU'RE CAUSING
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS ALONG THE
WAY. YOU'VE GOT TO ADDRESS
THOSE. IMMEDIATELY YOU CAN'T
WAIT TWENTY YEARS TO ADDRESS
THOSE SO I THINK THAT'S KIND OF
A KEY THING AND WHAT YOU SAW
FROM THE W. OURS REVIEW. AND
IT'S GOING TO BE I'M SURE A KEY
ISSUE FOR THE STATE BOARD TOO.
SO NEXT NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO
THIS IS JUST A LITTLE BIT OF A-
KIND OF HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU OF.
THE ISSUES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. WHICH ARE KIND OF CIRCLE
THERE WITH THAT. WHITE WHITE
OBLONG- AREA YOU CAN SEE MOST OF
THAT REGION IS COLORED ORANGE
THAT'S BECAUSE THOSE OF THE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASIN SO
MOST OF THESE BASINS DID HAVE TO
SUBMIT PLANS BY. JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY. IN ALL THERE WERE
ELEVEN THAT WERE SUBMITTED OR
ELEVEN BASINS THAT HAD TO SUBMIT
PLANS- THIS WAS. IT THIS IS A
BIG DEAL THIS IS THE OF THE
STATE'S BIGGEST AGRICULTURAL
REGION OVER HALF OF ALL
AGRICULTURE OUTPUT MISSION
DOLLARS. COMES FROM THIS REGION-
AND IT'S A IT'S A BIG OVERDRAFT
IT'S ABOUT TWO MILLION ACRE FEET
WE ESTIMATE OF ANNUAL AVERAGE
OVERDRAFT WHICH IS ABOUT 11% OF.
OF NET WATER USE ON AVERAGE MOST
OF THIS IS AGRICULTURE ABOUT 90%
IS AGRICULTURE BECAUSE OF THE
REALLY BIG IMPORTANCE OF YOUR
GATED AGRICULTURE IN THIS
REGION. SO CONSEQUENCES THAT WE
SAW BIG TIME IN THE LAST ROW AND
WE'RE SEEING AGAIN IN THIS
DROUGHT. DRY WELLS THIS INCLUDES
A LOT OF DRINKING WATER WELLS
DOMESTIC WELL SMALL COMMUNITY
WELLS BUT ALSO ACT WELLS-
SINKING LANDS YOU HEARD ABOUT
SUBSIDENCE. IT'S BEEN A LONG
TERM ISSUE BUT IT IT GETS WORSE
WHEN THERE'S A LOT OF PUMPING.
AND THAT THAT CELEBRATES DURING
TRIPS. AND THEN JUST THREATS TO
THE LONG TERM AVAILABILITY OF
THAT A REALLY IMPORTANT DROUGHT
RESOURCE WHICH IS THE GROUND
WATER RESERVES GROUNDWATER
RESERVES. THAT THAT PEOPLE USE
WHEN THERE ISN'T SURFACE WATER
AVAILABLE SO. DEALING WITH THIS
AND KIND OF SOLVING IS SOLVING
THIS PROBLEM IS. A COMBINATION
YOU HAVE TO KIND OF THINK ABOUT
THREE PIECES OF THIS PUZZLE THE
FIRST IS THE GROUNDWATER MATH
PROBLEM AND THAT IS THAT IF
YOU'VE GOT LONG TERM OVERDRAFT.
YOU GOT IT FIXED THE BALANCE BY
EITHER ADDING SUPPLIES. REDUCING
PUMPING REDUCING DEMAND OR SOME
COMBINATION. AND THEN THE COMES
THE SOCIO ECONOMIC PROBLEM WHICH
IS THAT. SOME SOLUTIONS ARE MORE
COSTLY THAN OTHERS AND YOU
REALLY NEED TO THINK ABOUT WHICH
COMBINATION WHICH PORTFOLIO OF
SUPPLY AND DEMAND SOLUTIONS. IS
GOING TO BE THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE FOR THE REGION AND
THIS IS THINKING ABOUT THE
GROWERS THEMSELVES AND THEIR
BOTTOM LINE BUT ALSO. YOU KNOW
THE JOBS THAT THAT AGRICULTURE
GENERATES AND SORT OF THE
OVERALL PACKAGE FOR THE FOR THE
ECONOMY. SO WE DID AN ANALYSIS
ON THIS AND WE FOUND THAT
BASICALLY FOR THIS REGION AS A
WHOLE- ABOUT THREE QUARTERS OF
THE DEFICIT IS GOING TO BE NEEDS
MET BE MET THROUGH DEMAND
MANAGEMENT. WHICH BASICALLY
MEANS TAKING. TAKING LAND OUT OF
PRODUCTION AND THAT'S A BIG THE
HARD THING AND THAT'S- PART OF
THE REASON YOU'RE SEEING
CHALLENGES IN. IN SOME OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE PLANS SO
FAR. THE THIRD ISSUE A THIRD
PROBLEM. AND THAT KIND OF
RELATES TO ALL OF THIS AND HOW
YOU PUT TOGETHER IS THE
GOVERNANCE CHALLENGE. THESE ARE
BIG BASS SINCE THEY'RE NOT TINY
BASINS THERE'S A LOT OF
DIVERSITY. IN THE CONDITIONS
THERE AND THAT REALLY MAKES.
PUTTING THIS PACKAGE TOGETHER
HARD AND I WANT TO SAY THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF REALLY
GREAT WORK DONE. TO IT TO TRY TO
TRY TO PULL THIS TOGETHER SO
WHAT WAS WHAT WAS SUBMITTED INTO
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY. WAS
ALREADY. YOU KNOW A MAJOR
ACHIEVEMENT RELATIVE TO WHERE WE
WERE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WHEN
THIS LAW WAS PASSED. THAT IS NOT
TO GIVE PEOPLE A PASS BUT IT'S
JUST TO SAY. IT'S NOT LIKE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SITTING ON YOU
KNOW BUT NOT DOING ANYTHING
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF HARD WORK.
SO NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. I WANT TO
GIVE YOU JUST THIS MAP WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DRILL INTO IT BUT IT
JUST GIVES YOU A SENSE. OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF. MANAGING
ORGANIZING ACCORDING ON WATER IN
THE SPACES SO THIS IS ALL OF
THE- THE BASINS ON THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY FLOOR. AND THE-
THE ONE FOR THIS TO YOUR- I
NEVER GET RIGHT AND LEFT RIGHT
THE ONE THIS IS IRRIGATED
CROPLAND. ON TOP THERE THAT'S
GOT ALL THOSE COLORS THOSE
DIFFERENT COLORS ARE. HOW MUCH
AVERAGE HOW MUCH ON AVERAGE OR
SURFACE WATER AVAILABLE FOR.
IRRIGATED AGRICULTURE. IF IT'S
QUITE BLUE THAT MEANS THERE'S
GENERALLY ENOUGH THAT YOU DON'T
YOU GROUND WATER. IF IT'S DARK
RED IT MEANS YOU'RE ALWAYS USING
GROUND WATER AND THAT'S ALL
YOU'RE USING. AND IF IT'S
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN IT'S CEMEX AND
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SOME YOU KNOW
SOME SOME COMBINATION OF THE TWO
OR MORE GROUND WATER IN DROUGHT
YEARS. AND THE OTHER MAPS TO
SHOW YOU THE MIX BETWEEN
PERENNIALS AND ANNUALS BUT THE
KEY ISSUE I THINK THAT. THAT
THIS HIGHLIGHTS IS THAT. EVEN
WITHIN BASINS WITHIN MOST BASINS
THERE'S A LOT OF DIVERSITY. AND
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE NOT SEEING
PEOPLE ALL COMING TOGETHER IN
ONE SINGLE AGENCY TO DO THIS
PLANNING WITHIN THE BASES
BECAUSE- THEY THEY'RE HAVES AND
HAVE NOTS AND KIND OF FIGURING
THAT OUT. HAS BEEN HARD FOR THEM
AND THEN THE OTHER THING IS JUST
ACROSS BASINS. THERE'S A LOT OF
DIVERSITY TO AND WATER MOVES
AROUND. AND SO THERE'S POTENTIAL
THERE FOR THINKING ABOUT ABOUT
THIS NOT JUST AS A BASE AND- BUT
AS A REGION OKAY NEXT NEXT I
PLEASE- THIS ONE I DON'T I'M NOT
GOING TO GO INTO THE DETAILS OF
THIS BUT- IT'S JUST A WAY TO
GIVE YOU A VISUAL. ON ON THE-
SORRY. SPEAKING THROUGH A MASK
IS IT IS AN EXPERIENCE THAT I'M
NOT USED TO IT- WHAT WHAT. WHAT
WHAT WHAT THIS SHOWS YOU IS A
SUMMARY OF SOME OF THE ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS THAT WE DID ON THIS
QUESTION OF SORT OF RECONCILING
GROUNDWATER MATH AND SO ON THE
SOCIOECONOMIC PROBLEM THIS IS
WORK LED BY BY ALL OVER AND A
COLLEAGUE AT UC MERCED A
PROFESSOR WHO'S WITH WHO'S IT
BECAUSE WAY MEDINA SWARA AND
WHAT WHAT THIS LOOKS THAT IS
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS FOR MANAGING
DEMAND AND SUPPLY AND WHAT IT
BASICALLY SHOWS YOU IS YOU'VE
GOT CROP REVENUES YOU'VE GOT
LOCAL REGIONAL FARM GDP FARM
RELATED GDP THAT BECAUSE ALL THE
PROCESSING. DOWNSTREAMOF
AGRICULTURE AS WELL FARM RELATED
JOBS AGAIN DEALT WITH INCLUDING
OF ON FARM IN DOWNSTREAM AND
THEN LAND FOLLOWING AND THE
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS LOOK AT OKAY
HOW CAN YOU MANAGE THIS DEMAND
IN WAYS THAT ARE MORE OR LESS
COSTLY FOR THE REGIONAL ECONOMY
AND WHAT IT SHOWS IS BASICALLY
THOSE HIGH BAR THE HIGHEST BARS
OF THE BROWN THOSE ARE IF
EVERYTHING IS DONE IN A REALLY
INFLEXIBLE WAY WHERE EVERYBODY'S
JUST TOLD. YOU ALL CUT THE SAME
PERCENTAGE AND NO MATTER WHAT
CROPS YOU'RE GROWING WHETHER
IT'S HIGH VALUE OR LOW VALUE ALL
OF THOSE THINGS THE ORANGE AND
THE YELLOW ALLOW MORE TRADING
WATER BOOKS GROUNDWATER AND
SURFACE WATER WITHIN THE BASIN
AND THEN THE YELLOW IS EVEN
WITHIN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
MORE PROBABLY NOT GROUNDWATER
BUT SURFACE WATER MOVING AROUND.
THE LAST ONE THE GREEN IS IF YOU
ALSO ADD IN THE COST EFFECTIVE
SUPPLIES THAT WE ESTIMATE OUR
EARTH ARE WORTH ARE OF A VALUE
THAT FARMERS WILL BE WILLING TO
PAY FOR AND STILL MAKE IT WORTH
THEIR WHILE TERMS THEIR CROP
BUSINESS THAT'S ABOUT YOU KNOW
ABOUT. HALF A MILLION HALF A
MILLION ACRE FEET. WHAT YOU SEE
THAT THE- WE DOWN WITH THESE
COMBINATION OF SOLUTIONS AND SO
THIS IS WHERE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
COOPERATE. AND MANAGE DEMAND IN
WAYS THAT ARE FLEXIBLE- AND THAT
INCLUDES HAVING ALLOCATIONS AND
AN ABILITY TO TRADE WATER. SO
LET'S GO AHEAD. TO THE NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE SO W. OURS REVIEWS
I'M NOT GOING TO GO INTO DETAIL
BUT JUST YOU KNOW I WANT TO
APPLAUD THEM THAT THEY TOOK A
BASIN LEVEL. PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
RATHER THAN JUST LOOKING AT EACH
INDIVIDUAL PLAN- INDIVIDUALLY
THEY REALLY TRIED TO LOOK AT
THE- AT THE HOLD COORDINATOR
HOLE THEY EMPHASIZE THINGS THAT
A LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS AND HAD
POINTED OUT IN THEIR REVIEWS
ABOUT THE UNDESIRABLE RESULTS.
LIKE IMPACTS ON DRINKING WATER
IMPACTS ON SUBSIDENCE AND THE
OTHERS THAT PAUL MENTIONED TO
YOU. AND THAT THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT'S THOSE
GUARDRAILS. THAT ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR SIGMA TO WORK IN
THE MEANTIME NOT JUST IN TWENTY
FORTY. AND THEN YOU KNOW THEY
ALSO HIGHLIGHTED ISSUES AROUND
COORDINATION CHALLENGES MAY ALSO
HOW TO HIGHLIGHT ISSUES OR ON
SOME PLANS. NOT REALLY
ADDRESSING THE SUPPLY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT OPTIONS THAT COULD
GET TO SUSTAINABILITY SO NEXT
SLIDE. PLEASE AS THE WEED WE DID
A DETAILED REVIEW OF THE PLANS
FOR SOME THINGS BACK WHEN THEY
WERE SUBMITTED IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND OUR OUR WORK KIND OF
HIGHLIGHTS SOME ADDITIONAL
ISSUES THAT ARE KIND OF WHO IS
STEPPING BACK FROM INDIVIDUAL
PLANS A LOOKING AT THE REGION
AND HOW IT ALL FITS TOGETHER AND
WHAT WE WHAT WE FOUND WERE UP A
COUPLE OF THINGS WHERE THE PLANS
WERE OVERLY OPTIMISTIC A NUMBER
OF THEM. DO THEIR GROUNDWATER
MATH AND THEIR ESTIMATE THEIR
OVERDRAFT BUT THEY USE YEARS.
THAT DON'T REALLY GIVE YOU
ENOUGH DRY YEARS. IN IN YOUR
HISTORICAL AVERAGE SO THERE IF
IT COULD SAY THAT THERE THE
BALANCES THAT THEY SAY THEY NEED
TO. TO FIX OUR LOW COMPARED TO
COMPARED TO FOR EXAMPLE IF THE
LAST DROUGHT. THE SECOND THING
IS THAT IF YOU ADD UP ALL OF THE
SUPPLY OPTIONS. THAT THE PLANS
PROPOSED. YOU HAVE TWO OR THREE
TIMES MORE WATER THAN IS
AVAILABLE PEOPLE ARE MAKE ANY
INDIVIDUAL PROJECT MIGHT BE
FIN. BUT WHEN YOU ADD THEM UP
FOLKS ARE COMPETING FOR THE SAME
DROP THE WATER. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THESE PLANS ARE MADE
LOCALLY YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT NECESSARILY LOOKING AT THEIR
NEIGHBOR IN THE OTHER PLANNING
AREA TO SEE- THAT THEY WANT THAT
WATER TOO. SO THERE'S A REAL
CHALLENGE THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
ALL WORK OUT FOR FOLKS IN TERMS
OF. YOUR ON THE KINGS RIVER FOR
EXAMPLE EVERYBODY WANTS THE SAME
WATER MULTIPLE TIMES. HEY YOU
ARE THIS UP YOU WE ESTIMATE FOR
RECHARGE WHAT REACH GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
SOLUTION WE ESTIMATE THOUGH THAT
THERE'S PROBABLY TWO TO THREE
TIMES MORE. DESIRE FOR RECHARGE
AND THERE IS WATER FOR RECHARGE
AND SPACE AND- SO ON THE FLIP
SIDE OF THIS GETS TO THE KIND OF
TOO LITTLE EMPHASIS IS ON
MANAGING DEMAND. WE'RE IN
UNDERSTANDABLY THE PLANTS
HAVEN'T WANTED TO GO HARD ON
THAT IN THE BEGINNING BUT THAT'S
WHERE THEY'RE GOOD THEY'RE GOING
TO NEED TO GO MORE AND QUICKER
AND- THIS YOU KNOW THE LAST
POINT IS ESPECIALLY. GIVEN THAT
IT'S TURNING OUT TO BE DRIER AND
HOTTER THAN. THAN THE HISTORICAL
AVERAGES WHICH IS WHAT THE PLANS
FOCUSED ON SO WITH THAT I GUESS-
WE WILL GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE AND
- JUST. SOME COULD EMPHASIZE FOR
YOU YOU KNOW WE'RE BACK IN
DROUGHT- THIS MEANS. FEWER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RECHARGE WHICH
IS THE SUPPLY SIDE. FULLER
PUMPING MORE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE SURFACE WATER AND THAT'S
LEADING TO MORE THESE
UNDESIRABLE RESULTS SO IT'S
REALLY PUTTING THE PRESSURE ON
THAT ON THOSE GUARD RAILS THIS
IS SOME ESTIMATES THE AUBURN
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE DR RICH PALU.
DID ON WELLS THAT ARE LIKELY TO
GO DRY IF THIS COMING YEARS IS
ALSO DRY AND VISITED A DOMESTIC
WELL SO YOU KNOW IT'S A HUMAN
ISSUE FOR COMMUNITIES. THAT THAT
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HERE.
OKAY NEXT SLIDE. FINAL ONE FOR
YOU. FIVE AREAS WHERE WE THINK
THAT THE STATE COULD REALLY BE
HELPFUL HERE- THE FIRST IS YOU
KNOW ADDRESSING. REALLY REALLY
ENCOURAGING PUSHING. OF ENTICING
LOCALS TO REALLY ADDRESS THE-
THE UNDESIRABLE RESULTS OF
OVERDRAFT AND FOR THIS THE KEY
ACTION IS TO USE THE USE THE
REGULATORY PROCESS THE WAY IT
WAS WRITTEN INTO THE LAW. AND I
THINK YOU KNOW DO YOU HAVE YOUR
HAS HAS MADE THAT. MADE THAT
CLEAR NOW IN THEIR REVIEWS AND
THIS IS THIS IS AN AREA WHERE IT
DOESN'T DO THE GUARDRAILS THAT
NEED TO BE. ADDRESSED THEIR WAYS
IN WHICH THE STATE CAN ALSO
PROVIDE A SUPPORT. FOR AGENCIES
THAT ARE THEY WANT TO REALLY DO
THIS BUT THIS IS SORT OF THE-
YOU KNOW. THIS THIS IS WHERE YOU
YOU CAN'T GIVE YOU CAN'T GIVE
THE ENTITIES A PASS ON THIS YOU
HAVE TO HOLD HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE. THE SECOND ONE IS
PROMOTING ACCELERATION OF DEMAND
MANAGEMENT. AND THIS IS WHERE I
WOULD SAY I DON'T THINK THAT THE
SIGMA TIME LINES. NEED TO BE
SHORTENED. BUT I THINK THAT THIS
MEASURABLE PROGRESS ALONG THE
WAY AND- DEALING WITH THE
GUARDRAILS OF NOT CAUSING THE
UNDESIRABLE RESULTS. MEANS THAT
YOU'VE GOT TO MOVE FASTER ON THE
DEMAND SIDE. THAN THE THAN FOLKS
WERE HOPING IT HAD WE BEEN FIVE
YEARS OF WET RECHARGE YEARS WE
MIGHT HAVE HAD A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW. BUT IT'S
DRY AND SO THE FACT MEANING YOU
HAVE TO ADOPT AND ACCELERATE
DEMAND MANAGEMENT. WHERE THE
STATE CAN REALLY HELP PAUL
MENTIONED- SOME SOME SUPPORT THE
DEED OF YOURS PROVIDING
ACCOUNTING TOOLS AT ALL OF THOSE
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT CAN
CAN HELP WITH THIS A LOT. THE
THIRD IS PROMOTING REALISTIC
EFFORTS ON NEW SUPPLIES. AND
THIS IS WHERE YOU KNOW GETTING
SO PEOPLE ARE NOT COUNTING THE
SAME DROPS MULTIPLE TIMES. I
THINK THAT THE STATE OF THE BOTH
THE OF YOU ARE IN THE STATE
BOARD THEY BOTH BEEN DOING A LOT
TO TRY TO PROMOTE RECHARGE.
THROUGH IN VARIOUS WAYS BUT THIS
IS WHERE JOINT COORDINATED
EFFORTS CENTER PROBABLY
MENTIONED ARE THERE WAYS TO.
HAVE YOU KNOW YOUR IN THE STATE
BOARD COORDINATE. MORE THIS IS
THIS IS ONE OF THE- RELIEF THAT
DETERMINE OF- TO HELP REALLY
ENCOURAGE COORDINATION AMONG
PARTIES ON THOSE RECHARGE
EFFORTS RATHER THAN JUST
FIGHTING OVER THE SCRAPS AND
FACILITATING PERMITTING WHICH IS
A BIG ISSUE. FOUR IS- ASSESSING
WATER THE SMART INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS THERE ARE GOING TO
BE SOME REGIONAL INVESTMENTS NOT
JUST LOCAL ONES THAT ARE GONNA
BE IMPORTANT AND THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT STATE ROLE TO THINK
ABOUT THAT- AND HELP AND ANALYZE
THAT AND THEN FIFTH IS START.
HELPING TO PLAN FOR SUCCESSFUL
FARMLAND TRANSITIONS IN BOTH
CENTER PROBABLY AND I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DICKINSON
MENTION THIS. IN THEIR REMARKS
THAT YET LANCE GOING TO COME OUT
OF PRODUCTION OVER TIME WITH
THIS WE ESTIMATE THAT AT LEAST A
HALF MILLION ACRES IN THIS
REGION IS GOING TO COME OUT
THAT'S THAT'S THE IF ALL GOES
WELL- AND THAT'S A LOT OF LAND
THAT'S 1015% THAT'S GOOD THAT
THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT
COMING OUT. NOBODY WANTS TO SEE
THAT DONE IN THE HAPHAZARD WAY-
THEY WANT TO SEE IT DONE IN WAYS
THAT. YOU DON'T DON'T CAUSE HARM
TO THE ENVIRONMENT TO PUBLIC
HEALTH WITH DUST- AND THAT.
BRING AS MUCH REVENUE AS
POSSIBLE AND SO THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE VALLEY FOR
THE SOLAR IS ONE OF THEM. WHICH
REALLY ALIGNS WITH STATE CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS- BUT THERE ARE
OTHERS IN TERMS OF HABITAT TO
THIRTY BY THIRTY- THAT THAT
CENTER PROBABLY MENTIONED. THERE
MAY BE SOME OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOU KNOW DRYLAND CROPPING AS
WELL IN SOME CASES. PLANNING IS
GOING TO BE KEY FOR THIS AND
THIS IS WHERE IT'S GOT TO BE LED
LOCALLY BUT THE STATE CAN REALLY
PROVIDE IMPORTANT SUPPORT. THE
NEW DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
FARMLANDS YOUR REPURPOSE SAYING-
SUPPORT IS A GOOD START TO START
THERE BUT THERE'S A LOT MORE
THAT THE STATE CAN DO TO HELP
THIS. AND WITH THAT I WILL. STOP
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR THIS
PRESENTATION- QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SALLY. SO IN ALL THE
DATA ANALYSIS THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE IN REGARDS TO- IN CAPTURING
THOSE WATERS- BABY BEING. IS
THERE ANY TALK OR I GUESS
CONSIDERATION ABOUT THE WATER
STORAGE SO IF WE HAD. THE
PROPOSED WATER STORAGE THAT WERE
IT WAS IN THE WATER BOND BUILT
AND WE STORING THOSE. GALLONS
RIGHT NOW DURING THE WHAT YEARS
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN FOR THE
REST OF THE STATE AND THE FARMER
SPECIFICALLY I MEAN YOU TALK
ABOUT HALF A MILLION ACRES
COMING OUT OF PRODUCTION I'M
SURE THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW LISTING THAT ARE.
HAVING SOME IN A MAJOR ANXIETY
OVER THAT SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT AT ALL. SHOP ASSISTANT THE
A MAYBE OVER WILL ALSO WANT TO
CHIME IN- SO- IN IN THIS REGION.
AND WE LOOK WE LOOK AND I WAS
SAY WHENI SAY WE ARE ALL OF OUR
SPECIALLY LOOKED AT ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS AND WHAT
THAT WOULD BRING INTO THE INTO
THE VALLEY. YOUR TEMPERANCE FLAT
WAS ONE. WHAT LOCAL RESERVOIR
THAT A LOT OF FOLKS HAD HOPES
FOR. IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE WATER
AND IT IN THE END. THE IT WHAT
DIDN'T MAKE SENSE TO FARMERS IN
THE IN THE VALLEY TO. PROVIDE
THE CARSHARE FOR THAT- SO THERE
ARE SOME. SOME FOLKS IN THE
VALLEY WHO ARE ARE THINKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW HAVE SOME
INVESTMENT SHARES INSIGHTS AND
THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT ST
LOUIS EXPANSION THING SO THAT.
THERE MAY BE SOME SURFACE WATER
EXPANSIONS THAT. COULD BE
HELPFUL BUT THE BUT THE BIG
PLAYS IN THE VALLEY ARE REALLY
AROUND. THE SMART ECONOMIC PLAYS
AROUND RECHARGE ABOUT STORAGE TO
AND THERE'S REALLY SOPHISTICATED
GROUNDWATER STORAGE. ALREADY
TAKING PLACE IN THIS REGION FROM
YOU KNOW PEOPLE LOOK AT THIS
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD. SO THE
KEY IS KIND OF MAKING MORE OF
THAT HAPPENED AND OVER MAYBE YOU
WANNA. ADD ON YOU KNOW SORT OF
WHAT IT WOULD HAVE HELPED THIS
YEAR IF WE ALREADY GOT MORE.
THANKS BUT QUESTION. YES FOR
SURE THAT YOU KNOW WOULD HELP
HOPE SOME- IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY I'M JUST TALKING ABOUT
HOW ABOUT I THINK THAT THE- THE-
YIELD THANK YOUR MIKE. IS ON
BECAUSE BEACON TIME THANK YOU-
THE DEALFROM THE REST OF US
ABOUT- JUST EMITTED IN THE BLOOD
WAS ALL TWO HUNDRED OR TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY. THOUSAND ACRE
FEET PER YEAR ON AVERAGE THESE
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WILL HAVE MUCH
LESS THAN THAT. JUST FOR
REFERENCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE FEET-
OFF. NEW POTENTIAL ONE AVAILABLE
ON WHAT WE ARE ESTIMATING IS
MORE MORE IMPORTANT TO ME THAT I
COULD FEED. OFF OTHER DRAFT SO
YES IT COULD HAVE HELPED A
LITTLE. BUT EVEN WITH. SOME OF
THESE INVESTMENTS- WE ESTIMATED
THAT THE IT'S KIND OF ESSENTIAL
TO REDUCE SOME- FOREMAN SOME
PROBLEM. MISTER CAR. THANK YOU.
AND IS IN REGARDS TO- NUMBER
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE LONG
TERM PLANNING WHAT HAVE YOU AND
THERE WAS A LITTLE MENTION OF
BUTLAND'S DURING THE COURSE OF
PRESENTATIONS BUT- AND THIS
QUESTION GO TO MIGRANTS FROM ONE
ROOM FEELS THEY CAN THEY CAN
THEY HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT IT
HOW ARE AGENCIES ENSURING THAT
THE STATE'S REMAINING WETLANDS
BUT CONTINUE TO HAVE THE WATER
THEY NEED DURING SIGMA
IMPLEMENTATION- BECAUSE
SOMETIMES I MEAN OBVIOUSLY IS A
LOT OF ISSUES HAVE BEEN RAISED
REGARDING FARMLAND TRANSITION.
ARE CRITICAL BOOK BUT- THOSE
WEAPONS OBVIOUSLY ARE INCREDIBLY
SENSITIVE HABITATS WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE VERY MUCH OF
IMPORTANT PART. OF THE
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD. SO
THIS IS A REALLY INTERESTING
QUESTION IN THIS REGION WHICH IS
A PRETTY DRY REGION I MEAN ONE
OF THE REASONS IT'S- IT'S GOT A
BIG OVERLAP PROBLEM IS BECAUSE-
IT DEPENDS A LOT ON ON SURFACE
WATER THAT'S- NOT ALWAYS THERE
RIGHT- SO THERE ARE MANAGE
WETLANDS THAT RECEIVE THAT HAVE
PRETTY SENIOR ALLOCATION SENIOR
RIGHTS IN A WAY TO IS TO THE
SURFACE WATER- THAT ARE PART OF
THIS CENTRAL VALLEY MANAGED.
WETLANDS COMPLEX AND THERE
THERE'S A LOT OF COOPERATION
THERE- WITH WITH LOCAL GROWERS
IN SOME PLACES AS PART OF THE
WATER PROJECT PLANNING SO YOU'RE
SEEING PLACES LIKE CROSSINGS
WATER DISTRICT THAT IS
COOPERATING WITH LOCAL ATTIC AND
THEY'RE FINDING WAYS TO KIND OF
GROW THE PIE THROUGH SOME
THROUGH LOCAL INVESTMENTS. THE
BIG CHALLENGE FOR- WATER SUPPLY
FOR THE MANAGE WETLANDS IS THAT
THERE ARE SOME PRIVATE WETLANDS
ESPECIALLY THAT ALSO PUMP THAT
THAT'S HOW YOU KNOW THEY FART
THEY FARM WETLANDS BY BY PUMPING
GROUNDWATER AND SO THERE'S A
CONCERN THAT SOME OF THOSE ARE
NOT GOING TO HAVE. YOU IN THE
SAME WAY THAT AG WILL BE CUT IN
SOME PLACES THAT THEY'RE ALSO
GOING TO BE PUT ON A DIET SO
THERE THERE'S CONCERN ABOUT THAT
BUT THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF
INTEREST RIGHT NOW IN.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MULTI BENEFIT
RECHARGE AND THAT'S WHERE A
PLACE LIKE THE KERN WATER BANK
IS A REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE OF. YOU
CAN HAVE- A WETLAND INTERMITTENT
WETLAND THAT'S RECHARGING
GROUNDWATER IF YOU STRUCTURE IT
IN A IN THE WAY THAT IT KIND OF
IS AMBLING INTO IT'S A GREAT
PLACE TO VISIT AND YOU'LL SEE
YOU KNOW WHEN THERE'S WATER
THERE. THERE'S ALL DIFFERENT
KINDS OF WILDLIFE AND SO IT'S A
REALLY VALUABLE PART OF THE
ECOSYSTEM AND SO YOU KNOW SOME
OF THE DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION
FUNDING I'M GUESSING IT KINDA
HOPING WILL GO TOWARD PROJECTS
THAT LOOK THAT AIM TO DO THAT
KIND OF MULTI BENEFIT RECHARGE
SO THAT'S THAT THAT'S A NICE USE. OF A FORMER FARMLAND ACTUALLY
. DID FOLKS FROM THE WATERY. ONE
AWAY IN THE- SHE- YES AND-
ALANKO COVER THAT VERY WELL BUT
THAT'S ANOTHER AREA WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON THE
SPECIALLY THOSE PRIVATE WETLANDS
THAT ARE REALLY DEPENDENT ON
GROUNDWATER PUMPING IN AND FOR
BASINS THAT. ASCETIC
ALLOCATIONS- YOU KNOW THE
ALLOCATIONS MAY NOT BE
SUFFICIENT SIMILAR TO TWO OF OUR
CROP- SUFFICIENT TO KEEP THA.
GOING AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER
ASPECT FOR BOTH BASINS DURING
IMPLEMENTATION WE'RE GOING TO BE
POSED THE QUESTION HOW THEY'RE
ADDRESSING- BUT WHAT USES AND
USERS AND GROUNDED ECOSYSTEMS-
BUT THEY'LL ALSO PROBABLY NEED
TO BE SOME OF THE CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T LOSE. MORE OF THE STATE'S-
WEAPONS SO THIS PROCESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IF I GO IS A
QUICK I HAVE IS I BELIEVE THE
DOUBLE OR WHAT SICK GO
CHALLENGES YOU HAVE SEEN
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE BASINS THAT
HAVE MULTIPLE GSA'S AND THAT ARE
CREATING. THE FULL ARTICLE GSA
IN MULTIPLE GEOGRAPHIES WHICH
IS- ALLOWED FOR IN THE LAW- DOES
CREATE COMPLEXITIES AND ITS
COMPLEXITIES THAT BOTH LOCAL
AGENCIES- CHOSE TO TAKE ON TO
THEMSELVES. THEN THEY BASE THEM
ON THEIR OWN IT DOES REQUIRE
THAT WHEN IT MORE THAN ONE
PLANTS IT IS THE SAME DAY THE
SAME METHODOLOGY SO FROM OUR END
WE WANT TO SEE. THOSE PLANS. IN
THE AGGREGATE SPEAK ON THE BASE
AND THERE'S A WHOLE- SO DOING
THAT IT MAKES IT DIFFICULT IF
THEY'RE NOT USING THE SAME DATA
METHODOLOGY WHICH IS
INCONSISTENT BLOCK SO THAT'S ONE
OF THE DEFICIENCIES ARE WE
IDENTIFIED BUT- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE AWESOME. AREAS WHERE
THERE HAVE BEEN MORE THAN ONE G.
AS INTERFACE AND THEY WORK
TOGETHER ONE- WHICH IS- ANOTHER
. IN THAT MAKES OUT A LOT LESS
COMPLEXITY- AND THEN THE BEEN
SOME BASINS THAT HAVE HAD ONE OF
MY GSA. MORE THAN ONE GST. AND
DID IT IN A WAY THAT WAS. WITH
ALSO DOES RUN THE BEFORE YOU GET
INTO WATER ONE PLAN DOES- SOME.
THAT ARE. YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
OVERCOME WE LOOK CLOSELY AT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS I HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS MYSELF- FIRST PAUL
WELL YOU'RE ON CAN YOU I'M
THERE'S A LOT OF INTERESTED
PARTIES HERE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THE INTERESTS OF THE FARMERS BUT
ALSO THE DOMESTIC WEALTH HOLDERS
WHO ARE REALLY AFFECTED BY THIS-
INCREASED PUMPING SO COULD WE
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND HOW
THEY HAVE BEEN AT THE TABLE AND
WIDE HOW WE CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THERE AT THE TABLE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THIS PROCESS. YEAH
THAT THAT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AND- AGAIN. YOU KNOW POINTS CAME
OUT. YOU KNOW THESE ARE LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES SEVEN PRODUCT
BOB WHAT PROCESS. BUT SIGNATURE
CREATED A MUCH HIGHER BAR FOR
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT FOR
BURKE. A LOT OF GOOD REASONS
JUST THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS- SO
REMEMBER RIDING- TOOLS AND
GUIDANCE OCT AGENCIES. I DON'T
GATE. OF THE PUBLIC FACILITATION. SERVICES HAS BEEN REALLY
CREDIT- BUT WE'VE SEEN THAT
THERE. ARE SOME CHOI IN SOME
BASS- ON STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT-
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
. LAYING OUT TO ALL THE AGENCIES
THAT WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO WORK
WITH THEM TO IMPROVE-
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENTS MAKE
SURE EVERYONE AT THE TABLE- THE
COMMUNITY IS FULLY ENGAGED WHEN
THESE IMPORTANT DECISIONS ARE
MADE- SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT OTHER TOOLS AND OTHER
REQUIREMENTS- IN THE PLAN THEY
THEY ARE REQUIRED IN THE PLAN TO
HAVE A COMMUNICATIONS AND
ENGAGEMENT PLAN. SO THOSE ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE LOOKED AT AND
WE DO HAVE- IN THIS SUBJECT
GRANT- FUNDING TO UPDATE THOSE
IN. AND IMPROVE TALK. THANK YOU
IS YOU KNOW. ACCESS TO CLEAN
DRINKING WATER IS ONE OF THIS
LEGISLATURE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
AS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE ACCESS. TO THAT WATER AS
WELL. A QUESTION FOR MAYBE
JAMES- BUT THE STATE WATER
BOARD. SO THERE'S QUITE A FEW
PLANS THAT ARE WE'RE HOPING
WE'LL GET THEM FIXED IN THE
COMING MONTHS BUT- IF THEY DO
NOT AND IF WE END UP WITH. SAY
SIX PLANS THAT THE STATE WATER
BOARD NEEDS TO INTERVENE ON CAN
YOU TALK A LITTLE ABOUT CAPACITY
AND THE ABILITY TO DO THAT THAT
SEEMS CONCERNING THAT YOU
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO.
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
YOU LAID OUT. DURING YOUR
PRESENTATION. YEAH THANK YOU
GREAT QUESTION SO ABSOLUTELY
BOTH THE PROCESS OF CONSIDERING
WHETHER A BASIN SHOULD BE PUT
INTO PROBATION- AND THEN
ASSESSING AND TRACKING THEIR
PROGRESS DURING PROBATION. THOSE
ARE BOTH GOING TO BE VERY LABOR
INTENSIVE- AND WE DO NEED TO
UNDERSTAND. BOTH THE PLANS FOR
THESE BASINS BUT ALSO THE
CONDITIONS IN THOSE BASINS- IT'S
ALSO HIGHLY UNCERTAIN AT THIS
POINT- HOW MANY BASINS MAY COME
IN TO THE BOARD'S JURISDICTION.
WE'RE HOPING THAT EVERYONE WILL
RESOLVE ALL THE DEFICIENCIES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. ACCIDENT OF FIDE- BUT
YEAH IT'S THEIR MEDICALLY
POSSIBLE- THE BILL ALL FIX THEIR
DEFICIENCIES OR MAYBE. MANY MANY
WILL NOT- BE ABLE TO DO SO IN
TIME IN THE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS- WINDOW THAT WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF NOW. IN THAT CASE THE
WATER BOARD WILL BE
PRIORITIZING- OUR WORK AS BEST
AS WE CAN. I AM WOULD JUST YOU
TO. YOU KNOW- ASSEMBLY BLOOM WAS
HERE EARLIER BUT I KNOW HE'S
LISTENING AS WELL BUT IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE ENSURE SUCCESS
FOR THE SUSTAINABILITY PLANS AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVING THE
RESOURCES TO DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IS CRITICAL SO. I HOPE THAT
CONVERSATION WILL CONTINUE.
LASTLY A QUESTION FOR HIM. YEAH
I SEE WHICH IS. I'M BOTH SENATOR
PAVEL IN YOU SPOKE ABOUT DEMAND
MANAGEMENT WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
PIECE OF THIS BUT YOU TALKED
ABOUT FARM TRANSITION WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT FARM TRANSITION YOU
TALKED ABOUT- HOME SOLAR AND-
WETLAND OPPORTUNITIES AND I
GUESS I REALLY WANT TO TOUCH ON
THE IMPACT OF THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT YOUR TIME AND A LOT OF
JOBS AND A LOT OF PEOPLE'S.
INCOME AND THAT'S REAL AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT AND WE CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND CLIMATE CHANGE BUT
WE ALSO CARE ABOUT ECONOMIC
JUSTICE I WANT. YOU TO TOUCH ON
PLEASE. RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S IT
THAT'S IT A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT I THINK IT'S TOP OF MIND
FOR EVERYBODY IN THE VALLEY- AND
IT IS DEFINITELY AN IMPORTANT
LINES FOR US IN IN THE WORK. IN
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THINKING ABOUT DEMAND MANAGEMENT
IN A IN A DOING DEMAND
MANAGEMENT IN A FLEXIBLE WAY IS
IMPORTANT IF YOU REMEMBER THAT
SET OF CHARTS YOU KNOW IF THERE
CAN BE WELL MANAGED TRADING. OF
GROUND WATER IN THE BASIN AND
WELL MANAGED MOVEMENT OF SURFACE
WATER SO THAT THE WATER IS GOING
TO YOU KNOW THAT THE THINGS THAT
ARE THE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
GENERATING THEM THE MOST.
ECONOMY COMFORT FOR THE AREA
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS FOR THE FARMERS
BOTTOM LINE- AND SO THAT THAT
HAS TO BE DONE IN A WAY THAT
ALSO IS MAKING SURE THAT IT'S A
YOU KNOW PEOPLE HAVE WHAT
DRINKING WATER IN THEIR WELLS
BUT THERE ARE WAYS TO IF YOU IF
YOU TAKE THAT WIDE LANDS ON IT.
AND CONSIDER THOSE PERSPECTIVE
YOU CAN SET UP PROGRAMS THAT DO
THAT WELL AND- THIS IS YOU KNOW
WHY KIND OF GETTING THE BASICS
IN PLACE FOR DEMAND MANAGEMENT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO DO NOW
AND IT'S- YOU. IT'S INTERESTING
THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME
PROGRESS IN SOME PLACES OVER
LAST COUPLE YEARS AND I. HAVE A
LITTLE TO SHOUT OUT TO THE TULE
BASIN WHICH IS ONE OF THE ONES
THAT. HAS SOME SERIOUS ISSUES IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW. FOLKS DO IT
DEFENSE COMMUNITIES WITH.
DRINKING WATER RISKS ALSO LAND
SUBSIDENCE THEY HAVE TO IN WATCH
OUT PARTS OF PARTS OF THE OF THE
AREA ARE. IMPACTING THE FRANK
FROM CANAL. THOSE DISTRICTS HAVE
ALREADY PUT IN PLACE ALLOCATION
SYSTEMS WITH FEES IT'S ENFORCED.
THE SO LAST YEAR THIS PAST
GROWING SEASON THEY ALREADY
WERE. OPERATING ON A ON A WATER
DIET ON UNDERGROUND WATER DIET
BECAUSE- THEY RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY'VE GOT TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND- THOSE THAT'S A- A
GOOD. IT THESE KIND OF PILOTS
THESE KIND OF INNOVATIVE IN THE
FOR THE FRONT INNOVATORS ON
THIS. CAN BE REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR. KIND OF HELPING HELPING TO
SET THE TONE FOR HOW YOU CAN DO
THAT AND WORK OUT SOME OF THE
KINKS. SO THAT'S THAT'S IT BUT A
KEY PIECE FOR THE ECONOMY. THANK
YOU WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT BACK
TO. FIVE AGUIAR-CURRY. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO NOW TO.
SIGNAL ON THE GROUND LOCAL
AGENCY PERSPECTIVE ON GOVERNANCE
AND IMPLEMENTATION- I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PRESENTERS SO FAR
THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN VERY GOOD
AND VERY INFORMATIVE- WELL FIRST
IT WAS SIERRA RYAN WITH THEIR
WATER RESOURCE MANAGER FROM
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. AND I BELIEVE
SHE'S ON THE LINE SIERRA. YEAH
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. WELCOME
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH. RIGHT
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TO YOU ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCES THAT I HAVE HAD THE
STIGMA. MY NAME IS SIERRA RYAN
AND I'M A LOT OF RESOURCES
MANAGER FOR THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CRUZ. THANK IS A SMALL COUNTY
OTHER CENTRAL COAST BETWEEN
MONTEREY AND SAN FRANCISCO WITH
THE POPULATION AROUND TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. JOHNNY IS NOT
CONNECTED TO ANY OF THE STATE OR
FEDERAL WATER SUPPLY PROGRAMS.
ALL OF OUR WATER SOURCES ARE
LOCALLY DERIVED SURFACE WATER
AND GROUNDWATER THERE IS A SMALL
AMOUNT AND NOT ALL RECYCLED
WATER CURRENTLY USED FOR
IRRIGATION. AN INCREDIBLE REYES
PROJECT IN DEVELOPMENT
BACKGROUND WATER IS STILL
CRITICAL FOR OUR WATER SUPPLY
HERE IN THE COUNTY. DESPITE THE
COUNTY RELATIVELY SMALL SIZE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE THREE TSA IS THAT
REFLECT THE RANGE OF APPROACHES
THE THING THAT COMPLIANCE. LARA
VALLEY WATER MANAGEMENT AGENCY
OVERSEES A CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BASIN AND SUBMITTED AN
ALTERNATIVE PLAN TO A DSP WHICH
WAS APPROVED BY DNR IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. THEY COMPLETED THEIR
FIVE YEAR UPDATE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SANTA CRUZ MID
COUNTY GROUNDWATER AGENCY
OVERSEES ANOTHER CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BASS AND BASS EMITTED
MERRY TST IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
IT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST TWO DSPS
IT WAS APPROVED TANK YOU HAVE
YOU ARE IN JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SANTA MARGARITA GROUNDWATER
AGENCY IS A MEDIUM PRIORITY
BASIN BUT STILL NEEDED ITS D. S.
P. DECEMBER. TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WE ARE FORTUNATE THAT THERE HAD
THE ARE ALL ONE. BECAUSE ONE IN
AN SUBMITTING ONE AS YOU PLEASE
SAYS THAT THE AND THE COME. TINA
PARTS THE STATE WE'RE NOT
PROBLEM. THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY
BACKGROUND WHAT. BASINS IN ABOUT
. URBAN MASTER WATER I THINK
MINUTES WELL NUMEROUS NOT WATER
SYSTEMS AND INTERCONNECTED
SURFACE WATER SUPPORTING
ENDANGERED SPECIES- AS FOR MY
ROLE IN THESE AGENCIES THE
COUNTY IS A MEMBER OF THE JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY IS THAT FORMED
BOTH THE SANTA CRUZ NAY COUNTY
AND THE SANTA MARGARITA GROUND
WATER AGENCIES. I SERVE ON THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEES OF BOTH
AGENCIES AND HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH THEM SINCE THEIR INCEPTION
. LARA VALLEY WATER MANAGEMENT
AGENCY WAS ACTUALLY FORMED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND WAS
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT IN A
SINGLE LEGISLATION. BUT I DID
SERVE ON THE AD HOC COMMITTEE
THAT THEY CREATED TO INFORM
THEIR FIVE YEAR UPDATE LAST YEAR
- I WITH US TODAY TO DISCUSS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE FEEL
LIKE HAS BEEN WORKING- WELL AT
THE INDIVIDUAL GSA LEVEL. AS
WELL AS THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE AN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FURTHER SUPPORT FROM THE STATE
LEVEL. WHAT'S WORKING FOR US
THEY MIGHT HAS BEEN A REALLY
IMPORTANT CATALYST FOR PROGRESS
IN BOTH GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
AND REGIONAL COLLABORATION. IT
HELPS TO REINFORCE THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF GROUNDWATER
ISSUES AND IT PROVIDES LEVERAGE
AND INCENTIVES TO BASINS THAT
HIS STRUGGLE TO PRIORITIZE THESE
ISSUES IN THE PAST. IMAGINE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
IN THE COUNTY THE WATER
INTRUSION REPRESENTS AN ALMOST
EXISTENTIAL THREATS IN THE WAY
OF LIFE IN THOSE AREAS. AT RISK
IS NOT NEW HOWEVER IN THE BASINS
THANKFULLY DIDN'T WAIT UNTIL
SAYING THAT WAS PASSED THIS ARE
WORKING TOGETHER TO PROPOSE
SOLUTIONS. IF THE COLORS HAVE
BEEN WORKING TOGETHER FOR
DECADES ON ON THE PROJECT
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS NEEDED TO
PROTECT THE BASE AND WE'RE
ALREADY IN DEVELOPMENT AT THAT.
AT THE TIME SAYING THAT WAS
PASSED. YES YES HE IS IN A- CASE
AND THAT'S- WHERE IN ANYWAY A
LOT NEXT FOR ORGANIZING AND
ADVANCING- THE EXISTING AFTER
IT'S- BEEN IN A MEDIUM PRIORITY
BASIN. THEY MIGHT HAS LED TO A
MUCH MORE FORMALIZED EFFORTS TO
STUDY THE BASIN- AND TO DEVELOP
AGREEMENT AMONGST THE
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT EVEN WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS. AND HOW TO
PRIORITIZE THE APPROACH TO MOVE
FORWARD. ALL OF THE GSA I AM IN
WITH THE FEDERAL PLEASANT
EXPERIENCE WITHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AND THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD STAFF AND WE'VE
WORKED WITH. OURDATA YOUR DATA
CONTACTS ARE REGULARLY ATTENDED
PART IN STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS-
WHICH IS EASY ENOUGH TO DO NOW
AND ORIGINAL THAT PRE TWENTY
TWENTY THEY WERE DRIVING UP FROM
FRESNO ON A MONTHLY BASIS FOR
THESE EVENING MEETINGS. I'M THEY
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN EXTREMELY
RESPONSIVE AND HELPFUL WHEN WE
NEED THEIR INPUT AND ADVICE-
STAFF AND THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD EVEN
CANNOT PRESENTED AT ONE OF OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATIONAL SESSIONS THAT
WE HELP FOR ONE OF OUR BASINS.
AND ALL VERY NICE PEOPLE WE'VE
JUST REALLY ENJOYED WORKING WITH
THEM- ALL OF ALL THREE OF THE
CASES IN THE COUNTY HAVE
RECEIVED GRANTS- HOUSE LIMIT
ALREADY DISCUSSED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE GRANT FUNDS THAT WERE
MADE AVAILABLE- AND THAT HAS
BEEN MONUMENTALLY IMPORTANT TO
THE ABILITY OF THESE. AREAS TO
COMPLY WITH CIGNA IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY. I CANNOT
OVERSTATE HOW CRITICAL THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FROM THE THAT
THE STATE HAS OFFERED HIS
BENEFIT THESE BASINS- WE'VE ALSO
REALLY GREATLY APPRECIATED THE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
RELEASED THEY'VE BEEN THEY WERE
VERY HELPFUL- AS WE WERE
DEVELOPING OUR PLANS. IN TERMS
SHALL. WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT
SANTA. COUNTY THAT THE MANY- IN
THE COUNTY HAVE BEEN WORKING.
FROM TIME. AS I SAY IF YOU'RE-
OVER. BY ALREADY HAD A HEAD
START IN TERMS OF COLLABORATION
AND PLANNING. I THINK I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU TODAY. IT A
CHALLENGE IT HAS TIME OUT OUT
THE PATH FIRST DATES FOR
SUSTAINING. AND THE MEDIUM.
BASIN ALONE LOS WATER SUPPLY
PROJECTS TAKE YEARS TO DECADES
OF PLANNING. AND IMPLEMENT- AND
THAT MEANS THAT WELL WE HAVE
SEVERAL PROJECTS NOW KIND OF AND
IS VERY INITIAL PLANNING PHASE.
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL MORE STUDY
AND PILOT TESTING THAT NEEDS TO
BE AS- THE FIRM CAN EVEN
ESTABLISH OUR BEST WAY FORWARD
AND START DEVELOPING THESE
IMPLEMENTATION PROJECTS THROUGH.
YOU KNOW IT IS A SEAT BY GETTING
FUNDING AND IMPLEMENTING. I
SUSPECT THAT MANY OF THE DSPS
EVEREST AMENDED LAST MONTH WILL
FACE WELL I'VE BEEN FACING
SIMILAR CHALLENGES- BUT YES FEES
ARE CONSIDERED A LIVING DOCUMENT
DOCUMENT AND IT IS ALLOWABLE TO
NOT KNOW EVERYTHING YET BUT WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT IF IT'S
GOING TO TAKE OVER A DECADE TO
IMPLEMENT PROJECTS. THAT DOESN'T
LEAVE A LOT OF TIME FOR THOSE
PROJECTS TO BRING THE BASIN TO
SUSTAINABILITY BY. OUR- TWENTY
YEAR DEADLINE. IN TERMS OF ON
GOING SUPPORT THE NAME THAT I
WILL AND YOU WILL FROM OTHERS AS
WELL AS THEIR- ON GOING
FINANCIAL. SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE TO THE GSA'S IN OUR
EFFORTS TO RENDON'S AGENCIES TO
COMPLY WITH THE MONITORING AND
REPORTING. AND ULTIMATELY WITH
IMPLEMENTATION IS FOUNDATIONAL
TO THEIR ABILITY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL- TO EXPLAIN WHAT THAT
IS I'LL GIVE YOU SOME
INFORMATION FROM THE SANTA
MARGARITA GROUNDWATER AGENCY
WHICH- OVERSEES AND MEDIUM
PRIORITY BASIN. THERE ARE ONLY
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND PEOPLE
LIVING WITH IN THE BASIN
BOUNDARY AND THEY'RE USING ONLY
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED ACRE FEET
OF. GROUND WATER PER YEAR. AND
THAT IS. VERY SMALL COMPARED TO
SOME OF THESE YES A SENSE ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE SOMETIMES TWO
ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE SMALLER SO
THERE'S JUST NO ECONOMY OF SCALE
HERE. RDSA BUDGET IS AROUND FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR JUST AROUND THE TSA AND
MEET THE MONITORING AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF
STIGMA. THAT NUMBER DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROJECTS ARE MANAGEMENT ACTIONS
NEEDED TO REACH THE SAME
ABILITY. AND IT DOESN'T REALLY
INCLUDE THE MONITORING THAT THE
MEMBER AGENCIES WERE ALREADY
DOING IN TERMS OF THEIR
GROUNDWATER ELEVATION. THE DSA
IS MEMBER FUNDED- FROM THAT
MEMBERS OF THE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY. AND SO THAT IS A LOT
OF ADDITIONAL COST TO PUT ON
PRIMARILY WATER RATEPAYERS
BECAUSE AND IN THIS SPACE AND WE
DON'T HAVE. REALLY ANY LARGE. AB
IS IF WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
AGRICULTURE IT'S REALLY JUST
DOWN TO URBAN AND RURAL
RESIDENTIAL- IT'S NOT AN
AFFLUENT AREA BUT IT'S ALSO NOT
CONSIDERED TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY OTHER PARTS THAT HAVE
BEEN IN THE PAST THEY WERE IN
THE MOST RECENT- ITERATION OF
THOSE ITS ADVANTAGE COMMUNITY
MAPS. WE ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO OPERATIONALIZE OUR
COSTS IN A WAY THAT IS BOTH
EQUITABLE AND SUSTAINABLE. IN
ORDER FOR THIS BASIN AND I'M
SURE MANY OTHERS JUST TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE GSA ONGOING
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE NEEDS TO
BE AVAILABLE. IT DOESN'T ONLY
MEAN DIRECT FUNDS BUT IT COULD
ALSO MEAN ADDITIONAL GUIDACE
DOCUMENTS FROM THE STATE ON
OPTIONS TO RAISE FUNDING IN
SUPPORT OF SAME MATH- FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONFUSION ABOUT- EXACTLY WHAT.
WHAT FEES WERE ALLOWED TO CHARGE
AND HOW WE WOULD USE PROP TO
EIGHTEEN WHETHER WE CAN GET.
SOMETHING FEES THINGS LIKE THAT
SEVEN MORE GUIDANCE WOULD BE
REALLY REALLY HELPFUL. WHEN
FINANCIAL SUPPORT IS AVAILABLE
FROM THE STATE IT NEEDS TO BE
ABLE TO GO TOWARDS OPERATING
EXPENSES LIKE ADMINISTRATION
MONITORING AND REPORTING AND NOT
JUST PROJECTS- FINALLY THAT
SUPPORT SHOULD ALSO BE EASY FOR
THE TSA'S ACCESS. IT IS A REALLY
HUGE LEFT FOR IT- ARE TAKING A
MEMBER AGENCY STAFF TO WRITE
LONG ARDUOUS GRANT APPLICATIONS.
AND THE BUDGETS OF THE AGENCIES
ARE SO TIGHT THAT. IT'S REALLY
NOT AN OPTION TO HIRE A
CONSULTANT WHEN WE DON'T KNOW
THAT THE- GRANT. FUNDING WILL
EVEN BE RECEIVED. I'M ONE
FUNDING DIRECTED AT PROJECT
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THE HISTORIC
SPAN OF. SPENDING ON SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS PUT SOME OF THESE
SMALLER BASINS THAT WERE ALREADY
BEHIND IN PROJECT DEVELOPMENT.
EVEN FURTHER BEHIND. THERE'S A
HUGE AMOUNT OF FEAR THAT THE
STATE IS GOING TO SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY NOW. WELL THINK NIGHT
STILL NEW AND THERE'S A BUDGET
SURPLUS- AND THAT THAT FUNDING
WILL BE FOCUSED ONLY ON SHOVEL
READY IMPLEMENTATION PROJECTS OR
AT LEAST PRIORITIZE FORCE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTATION PROJECTS
FOR THE TSA'S. AND BY THE TIME
THESE MEDIUM AND HIGH PRIORITY
BASINS WILL BE ABLE TO DEVELOP
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS. THIS IS.
A WOMAN OF DON. AND THERE WON'T
BE ANY FUNDING AVAILABLE. BELT
BACKING MACRON FOR NOW THAT I.
VERY HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THAT ANY MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT WAS A GREAT
OVERVIEW AND UP FOR PRE **** ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE ALL DOING-
WE ALL KNOW HOW VALERIE KING.
PARTNERSHIP PERRIS KING CAME THE
WORST CHEF SKI. LLP REPRESENTING
CURRENT GROUNDWATER AUTHORITY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR
AND- ADVICE CHAIR I I'M GONNA
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE- WE
ACTUALLY OUR OFFICE REPRESENTS
GSA'S WATER DISTRICTS- CITIES
AND COUNTIES FROM SISKIYOU
COUNTY DOWN TO KERN COUNTY SO. I
MIGHT MY DAILY LIFE IS FILLED
WITH- GSA'S CALLING ME AND
ASKING ME QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW TO
COMPLY WITH SAID MA HOW TO FORM
I'M TRYING TO DO SEVERAL THINGS
SO I'M I'M GONNA TOUCH ON FOUR
ISSUES. THAT I SEE- COME UP
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ARE ARE
CONSISTENT AMONG GSA QUESTIONS
ABOUT SITE MAP. BEFORE YOU DO
THAT THAT WAY I DO WANT TO TALK
REALLY BRIEFLY ABOUT WHERE WE'VE
COME AND SOME PEOPLE TALKED
ABOUT THIS BUT- GIVEN MY NAY
THIS IS BOSTON TWENTY FOURTEEN.
A HUNDRED YEARS AFTER THE
SURFACE WATER SYSTEM- AND
STATEWIDE PERMITTING. RULES WERE
PASSED AND WHEN WE ARE
DEVELOPING SICK MY AND FOLKS
WERE GIVING FEEDBACK TO THE
AUTHORS OF SIGMA ONE OF THE
INTERESTING THINGS WAS TO SEE
THE LEGISLATIVE. HISTORY IN
NINETEEN FOURTEEN. DISCUSSED
POSSIBLE GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT
AND HOW THE LEGISLATURE THAT
TIME SAID WE CAN'T DO THAT IS
JUST TOO DIFFICULT IT TOOK AN
ENTIRE HUNDRED YEARS. TO KIND OF
RECOVER FROM THAT. CASICH LESSON
A VERY DIFFERENT LAW. THAN
SERVICE WATER RIGHT. SERVICE
WATER REGULATIONS HOUSE. FROM
THE TOP DOWN I THE STATE WERE
RESOURCES CONTROL. AND IT'S A
PERMITTING LOCK RIGHT SO WE HAVE
A VERY LOCAL. PLANNING BOX THAT
IS THAT IS NOT NO ONE IS ISSUING
GROUNDWATER PERMITS UNDERSUPPLY
SO IT'S A VASTLY DIFFERENT- THE
PLAN IT'S MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
AND FRANKLY MUCH MORE- LOCAL
BASED. SO WHAT HAPPENED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I THINK LARGELY
GSA'S DID A GREAT JOB OF THIS.
WAS THAT YOU HAD A HUGE NUMBER
OF NEW PUBLIC AGENCIES BEING
FORMED. RIGHT GSA'S OUR
PUBLICATION SEES SOMETIMES THEIR
GPAS SOMETIMES THERE ARE JUST A
NEW HOT THAT IN EXISTING
AGENCIES WEARING. BUT THAT WAS A
HUGE AMOUNT OF WORK. AND TAKING
ON THAT THE SIGMOD KIND OF
CHARGED AS IT HAS BEEN DIFFICULT
AND I'M I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT
I'M AMAZED DAY TODAY TO CD'S
AGENCIES STEP UP. AND DO THE
WORK AND PUT IT TO THE WORK AND
NOT ONLY FORMING. BUT YOU KNOW
W. R. AND- OTHER FOLKS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT HOW MANY AGENCIES
GOT THROUGH THAT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DEADLINE- THERE WERE
THERE WERE NO. LOCAL AGENCIES
THAT SAID WE'RE JUST NOT DOING
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO TRY IT
STATE YOU CAN TAKE IT FROM HERE
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN. SO THERE'S A
HUGE AMOUNT OF WORK DONE AT THE
GSA LEVEL I MEAN PEOPLE REALLY
DEDICATED TO GETTING IT DONE AND
YOU SEE THAT ALSO WITH THE
COMPLETION OF PLANTS BOTH IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY DEADLINE. AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- IN TWENTY
TWENTY THERE WAS ONE PLAN THERE
WAS A LITTLE BIT LATE AND IT
CAME IN A MONTH OR TWO LATER.
AND TWENTY TWENTY TO BRING UP
THE PLANSAND- SO I DON'T WANT.
THIS COMMITTEE TO MISUNDERSTAND
THAT THE- HUGE EFFORT BY LOCAL
AGENCIES AND IT HAS BEEN LARGELY
SUCCESSFUL. AND HAVING SAID THAT
I THINK THERE ARE FOUR QUESTIONS
THAT COME UP CONTINUALLY IN MY
PRACTICE. A FROM. FROM LIKE I
SAID STATEWIDE. ONE IS FUNDING
SIERRA JUST TOUCH THAT QUITE BIT
SO I'M NOT GOING TO GO IN. THAT
IN GREAT. BUT ADAM SAID WHAT IS
THIS FOR NOT FOR CLEAR. ON THE
AUTHORITY OF FUNDING- HOW TO
EIGHTEEN. TWENTY SIX AND- THE
SICK MY THIRTIES THEMSELVES-
WHAT IS WHAT IS THOSE PROVIDE.
IN A RELACIONAMENT MENTION
GROUNDWATER PUMPING- FUNDING
WHICH IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT SO
YOU HAVE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
FUNDING THE GSA'S VASTLY
DIFFERENT LIKE SUMMER MEMBER
FUNDED LIKE SEARS SOME HAVE DONE
IT TO EIGHTEEN SOME HAVE RELIED
ON PROP TWENTY SIX. SOME PEOPLE
THINK THAT SAID MY GIVES YOU THE
AUTHORITY WITHOUT TO EIGHTEEN
AND TWENTY SIX TO JUST EXACT
FEES. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
CONFUSION THERE AND THESE ARE
VERY VERY COSTLY REGULATIONS TO
COMPLY WITH YOU HAVE ANNUAL
REPORTS YOU HAVE FIVE YOUR
UPDATES YOU HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT'S NOT
EVEN TALKING ABOUT PROJECTS TO
GET TO SUSTAINABILITY. SO THERE
ARE A FLEET OF BRAND NEW PUBLIC
AGENCIES THAT HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO THAT'S VERY EXPENSIVE- I
KNOW D. W. R. FUNDING HAS BEEN
CRITICAL IN GETTING THROUGH THIS
FIRST STEP. BUT ADMITS THAT DIES
OFF OR IF THAT FUNDING DRIES UP-
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A LOT OF
TROUBLE SO FUNDING IS A HUGE
ISSUE. SECOND D. AVID LAND USE
COMPONENTS OF SIGMA AND REALLY
SAID MUCH SPECIFICALLY LEFT LAND
USE AND WHILE PERMITTING WITH
AUTHORITY WITH COUNTIES. THEY
DID NOT GIVE THAT TO GSA IS THAT
HAS BEEN ATTENTION AND I THINK
WILL BE A CONTINUING TENSION OF
HOW GSA'S WORK WITH EXISTING
COUNTIES. IF WHILE PERMITTING
AND WELL APPLICATIONS FOR NEW
WELL PERMITS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
OR NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE G. S.
P. ON THE GROUND. SIGNET DOESN'T
TALK ABOUT THAT AT ALL SO
THERE'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE SOME
COMMUNICATION THERE I KNOW SOME
COUNTIES HAVE KIND OF. TRIED TO-
FILL THAT GAP AND I THINK WITH
MIXED SUCCESS SO FAR I'M NOT SO
THAT'S AN OPEN ISSUE THAT I
THINK EVERYBODY'S AND HAS ASKED
ME ABOUT- THIRD THE ROLES OF
GSA'S AND TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT IT TODAY. WITH WITH THE
RIGHT TO DRINKING WATER. AND
MITIGATION. ABBOTT HOUSE. AS
POWERFUL AS GSA'S IN IT AND I
AND A NUMBER OF AUTHORITIES THAT
SEGMENT GIVES CSA'S GSA'S ARE
NOT WATER PROVIDERS THEY'RE NOT
WATER SUPPLIERS. AND SEGMENT
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE REQUIREMENT
TO MITIGATE. DOT HAS KIND. OF
BEEN READ INTO THE LOCK- AND-
YOU KNOW WE SEE HOW THAT GOES
BUT BUT- GEN ARE GONNA HAVE TO
WORK WITH THE STATE. WAS SAFER
WITH COUNTIES AND WITH OTHER WE
HAVE THE TOOLS. TO MITIGATE AND
PROVIDE FOR AND GOOD QUALITY
DRINKING WATER OFTENTIMES. SUCKS
THINK THAT GSA'S ARE SADDLED
WITH THIS YOU HAVE TO FIX ALL
THE DRINKING WATER PROBLEMS. I'M
JUST A FRANKLY DON'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITIES OR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OR THE ON THE
GROUND I'M ABILITY TO DO THAT.
SO THAT'S AN EXPECTATION WHICH
FRANKLY ISN'T INCLUDED IN
SEGMENT CURRENTLY. BUT WE'RE
GONNA READ THAT INTO SIGMA GOING
FORWARD WE'RE GONNA NEED TO GET
THESE YES IS A LOT OF HELP. A
LOT OF FUNDING. AND TAKE IT TAKE
A DIFFERENT LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THAT'S NOT INCLUDED.
AND THEN FINALLY AND I THINK
PROBABLY THE TENSION THAT WE'VE
SEEN THROUGHOUT STATE MY FROM
ITS INCEPTION. AND I THINK IT'S
ONLY GOING TO INCREASE- IS THE
STATE ROLE BEGINS TO POTENTIALLY
COME ON. ON BOARD HERE IS THE
TENSION BETWEEN LOCAL CONTROL
AND STATE REGULATION THAT IS A
HUGE ISSUE. YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
IT IN RECHARGE SOMEONE BROUGHT
UP THE CURRENT WATER BRING WHICH
IS A GREAT. BANKING PROGRAM- BUT
IT'S LARGELY BECAUSE IT WAS
LOCALLY DRIVEN LOCALLY
CONTROLLED. THERE'S NOT. YOU
KNOW A HUGE AMOUNT OF STATE
REGULATION. DIET IT IS THAT THEY
HAVE TO JUMP IT'S AN ESTABLISHED
GREAT MULTI BENEFITS- BANKING
PROGRAM. BUT IF WE WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN STATEWIDE WE'RE GOING TO
REALLY HAVE TO THINK CRITICALLY.
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
LOCALS. GETTING THINGS DONE ON
THE GROUND AND- THE STATE.
HAVING KIND OF AN OVER
REGULATORY COMPONENT. SO WE ARE
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THAT WE'RE
GONNA SEE THAT END OF THE DAY
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH REVIEW OF
PLANS THE STATE LOCAL TENSION.
AND OF COURSE THE STATE WATER
BOARD WALKED US THROUGH A VERY
KIND OF FRAMEWORK VERY HIGH
LEVEL PROCESS FOR THE STATE
WATER BOARD. AND DETERMINING
BASINS WHEN THEIR PROBATIONARY
SIGMA FRANKLY DOESN'T HAVE A LOT
OF INFORMATION ON THAT IT'S VERY
VERY FRAMEWORKDRIVEN. DECISIONS
AT THE STATE WATER BOARD AND YOU
DO WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
ON THE GROUND WITH REGARD TO HOW
TO KEEP LOCALS IN CONTROL. EVEN
IF THEY GO PROBATIONARY AND HOW
TO GET LOCAL STEP TO TAKE BACK-
AT LOCAL CONTROL OF BASINS WHEN
THEY DO GO PROBATIONARY IS VERY
MUCH UP IN THE AIR. IT'S GOING
TO BE ATTENTION THAT CONTINUES
TO REAR ITS HEAD AND I THINK WE
SHOULD BE VERY VERY CAREFUL-
ABOUT LEADING LOCALS- NOT ONLY.
BE ABLE TO DO PROJECTS THAT THAT
NEED THAT THEY NEED TO DO TO GET
TO SUSTAINABILITY BUT TO GIVE
THEM BACK THAT LOCAL CONTROL IF
THEY HAVEN'T MET- THE MARKS
THAT. ARE SET OUT SO WE'RE GOING
TO BE A LOT OF ATTENTION TO
THAT- AGAIN LOCALS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE FROM REALLY ROLLED
UP THEIR SLEEVES. I WORK WITH
THEM DAY TO DAY SO I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THEY ARE. WORKING- DO
YOU GET TO TELL DATA GAPS. I
WHICH WERE GIANT. AT THE
BEGINNING WAS SICK MONTH- THEY
JUST WORKS SO HARD. SO I AM I
KNOW THAT THE STATE WATER BOARD
INDEED WE ARE HAVE BEEN BOTH
TREMENDOUSLY. ON KEEPING LOCAL
CONTROL- BUT I THINK FROM A
LEGISLATIVE PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE
TO KEEP THAT- AB COMPONENTS
SEGMENT AS WELL. SO THOSE ARE
THE FOUR ISSUES THAT I SEE DAY
TO DAY AND I THINK- WILL
CONTINUE TO COME UP. AND AGAIN
STATEWIDE- FOLKS ASK ABOUT EVERY
DAY. SO HOW DO YOU TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AND AGAIN THANKS
THANKS FOR LETTING US PROVIDE
KIND OF THIS LOCAL- ON THE
GROUND PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS CAN CAVE- IT WAS
VERY INSIGHTFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I AGREE WITH LOCAL CONTROL
COMPLETELY SO. LET'S MOVE ON TO
OUR- FINAL ONE IN- DAVID
MORRISON DIRECTOR OF PLANNING
BUILDING ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES
FROM NAPA COUNTY. AND. WELCOME
MY FRIEND DAVID MORRISON. YES
IT'S BEEN A WHILE HER YEAH. GOOD
MORNING SURE ZAGRA. AND BARRY K.
AND- ARE UNDER FOR THE PRO OF
SPEAKING BEFORE IT MORNING. I'D
LIKE TO BRING REVIEW WHAT NAPA
COUNTY'S BEEN DOING. WHERE WE
ARE NOW AND WHAT THE NEXT FEW
YEARS LOOK LIKE. NEVER COUNTIES
BEEN STUDYING GROUNDWATER FOR
OVER SIXTY YEARS AND HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY MANAGING IT'S OUR
PERSONAL PASSED THIRTY YEARS IS
NOT A NEW SUBJECT FOR US. OUR
LAND USE THE SENATE ON
AGRICULTURE THE GENERAL REQUIRES
MUCH LESS WATER THAN OTHER CROPS
. IN FACT MANY VINEYARDS OR EVEN
TRY FARM WITH. PROBLEM WATER OR
SERVICE WATER. OUR LAND YOU ARE
CITIES ALMOST REAL ON SURFACE
WATER RECYCLED WATER TO RELIEVE
THE AQUIFER. AND WE HAVE STRUCK
FARMAN OPEN SPACE PRESERVATION
POLICIES IN PLACE SINCE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE NATION'S
FIRST AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. AS A
RESULT OF THIS FORWARD THINKING
STRATEGY NAPA GROUNDWATER LEVELS
ARE HISTORICALLY STABLE WITH
LITTLE TO NO SUBSIDENCE OR WATER
QUALITY ISSUES THAT WE SEE
ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE. THERE
ARE SOME OF THE ACTIONS OF
CALIFORNIA NAP WAS TAKEN TO
PROTECT AND CONSERVE GROUNDWATER
OVER THE YEARS. IN NINETEEN
NINETY WE ADOPTED OUR WATER
AVAILABILITY DALLAS'S GUIDELINES
TO EVALUATE THE IMPACTS TO
GROUNDWATER EXTRACTION ON NEARBY
WELLS. ROTATED TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
LOOK AT POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO
OCCUR FIRST AND AGAIN TOOK A
SURFACE WATER INTERACTION. AND
GROUNDWATER DEPENDENT ECOSYSTEMS
. OUR SYSTEM UPDATING THOSE
AGAIN. IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
WE DESIGNATED PUTS CALLED
MILLIKAN SARCO TOOK LATE TO THE
CASE WATER DEFICIENT AREAS THIS
IS EVERYWHERE YOU SEEN
SIGNIFICANT GROUNDWATER
WITHDRAWALS AND WHAT WE SAID WAS
THAT IT WITHIN THAT AREA
MOLANDER MORE WATER THAN THEY
WERE USING AT THE TIME IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. SO IF YOU
WANTED TO PUT IN A QUARTER ACRE
HALF ACRE VINEYARD YOU HAVE TO
TAKE OUT YOUR LOCK YOUR TAKE OR
JUST WEARING COOL YOU HAD TO CUT
BACK ON RESIDENTIAL CONSUMPTION
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE ANOTHER
HOUSE YOU MIGHT HAVE TO DO THE
SAME TAKE OUT TO LANDSCAPING-
VINEYARD- THERE'S NO THAT. ARE
KNOWN IMPACT. WITH THAT AREA. WE
DESIGNATE THE SECOND. TO
EIGHTEEN IN THE NORTHEAST AREA.
WE CREATED A WATERSHED
INFORMATION CONSERVATION COUNCIL
TWENTY THOUSAND TO LOOK AT THE
WATERSHED WHICH VIDAK AQUIFER'S
. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BUT PARTED
BASIN ANALYSIS REPORT THAT WAS
SUBMITTED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
CIGNA AS THE ALTERNATIVE
GROUNDWATER SOMEPLACE. WE FORM
THE GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
THAT'S PROBABLY A LITTLE TO WORK
VERY VERY HARD VERY VERY FAST
YOU CAN CLEAR PLAN WITHIN TWENTY
FIVE MONTHS. THAT MAKE THE
DEADLINE. A SENIOR WE ALSO
JOINED WITH THE CITY OF NAPA AND
ENJOY WATERSHED MONITORING STUDY
TO SEE WHAT THE IMPACTS OF LAND
USE OUR OF THEM JUST RESERVOIRS
. TWENTY TWENTY WE CREATED WE
WORK WITH THE CITIES TO PREPARE
DROUGHT CONTINGENCY PLAN. AND
JUST IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR WE
FORMED A DROP OF WATER SHORTAGE
TASK FORCE AS A CONSISTENT WITH
STATE REQUIREMENTS. ALL THE WORK
WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST IS STILL
NOT ENOUGH TO MEET OUR CURRENT
CHALLENGES. WHAT RANGE OCTOBER
DECEMBER IT CERTAINLY HELPED.
THE TOTAL FOR THIS YEAR
REPRESENTS ONLY 66% OF THE HAD
AVERAGE ANNUAL RAINFALL FOR NOW
BUT- OUR LOCAL RESERVOIRS ARE
NEARLY FULL BUT THEY PROVIDE
ONLY ABOUT A THIRD OF MUNICIPAL
WATER. REMAINDER COMES FROM THE
STATEWATER PROJECT WHICH WILL
RECEIVE ONLY 25% OF OUR NORMAL
LOCATION. THE AMOUNT OF
GROUNDWATER STORAGE STABLE BUT
HAS DECREASED ABOUT 15% OVER THE
PAST TWO THREE YEARS. ALTHOUGH
EXISTING CONDITIONS ARE
CONCERNING THE FUTURE OUTLOOK IS
MORE WORRISOME. EXPERIMENTAL
LONG RANGE MODELS RUN BY THE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE AND
OTHER AGENCIES INDICATE THE NAPA
COUNTY MAY RECEIVE BELOW AVERAGE
RAINFALL ALL THE WAY THROUGH
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
NOT ONLY BE MAYBE LOOKING AT A
THIRD YEAR DROUGHT THIS SUMMER
BUT A FOURTH YEAR DROP NEXT YEAR
. BECAUSE OF THESE POTENTIAL
THREATS THAT WAS FULLY ENGAGED
MISTAKE WAS THE CENTERPIECE OF
THEIR EFFORTS TO CAREFULLY STORE
ARE PREFERRED TO THE FUTURE. BUT
THERE'S A LOT TO DO IN A VERY
SHORT TIME SO WHAT ARE WE DOING.
THAT'S A PASSED WE'RE WE DOING
NOW. OUR GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN WAS
SUBMITTED TO D. W. ARE JUST LAST
MONTH IS CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW.
HOWEVER WE'RE QUICKLY MOVING
FORWARD WITH IMPLEMENTING THE
TOPIC PLAN. WE'RE CREATING A
TECHNICAL ADVISORY GROUP. WEREUSING THE WATERSHED
INFORMATIONAL AKA AND
CONSERVATION COUNCIL IS A
STAKEHOLDER GROUP EXPANDING IT.
WE'RE DEVELOPING FOR WORK THANKS
TO ADDRESS INTERCONNECTED
SURFACE WATER AND GROUNDWATER
DEPENDENT ECOSYSTEMS WATER
CONSERVATION. GROUNDWATER
PUMPING REDUCTION IN STRONG
WATER RESOURCES. AND WERE
EVALUATING FUTURE FUNDING
OPTIONS FOR THE GSA. AT THE SAME
TIME ALL THIS IS GOING ON WELLS
ACCORDING TO SOME OTHER
GROUNDWATER RELATED STATE
PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE GENERAL
ORDER ONLINE OR JUST CHARGES
RECENTLY ISSUED BY THE REGIONAL
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD
WHICH IS A GREAT AFFECT YOUR
NAPA. OKAY USED TO LET US FOR
GENERAL STORMWATER PROGRAM FOR
URBAN AND STORMWATER RUNOFF. OUR
LOCAL AGENCY MANAGEMENT PLAN TO
ADDRESS WASTE WATER. THE GROUND
WATER SHORTAGE PLAN THAT WAS
REQUIRED SB FIVE FIVE TWO LAST
YEAR. RECENT COURT DECISIONS ON
DISCRETIONARY WELL APPROVALS AND
PUBLIC TRUST THE GOVERNOR'S
ORDER ON STATEWIDE WATER
CONSERVATION ISSUES LAST MONTH.
FIRST WE ARE ALREADY GETTING
READY FOR NEXT FIVE YEAR REVIEW
AS WELL AS WAITING TO RESPOND ON
ANY COMMENTS THAT YOU KNOW WE
ARE MAY HAVE OVER THERE TO YOUR
REDUCE. WHILE SUPPORT APPROACHES
WE'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTING. AND
THIS GOES BACK TO SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I VALUE WAS SAYING
ABOUT THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
GSA'S THE COUNTIES. IS
CONSOLIDATING ALL OF THE WATER
RELATED PROGRAMS WITH AMONG THE
PARK. MY DEPARTMENT- OVERSEAS
WELL IN WASTEWATER PERMITTING.
LAND USE PLANNING FLOOD
REGULATIONS STRONGWATER-
MONITORING COMPLIANCE. WATERSHED
PLANNING DROUGHT PLANNING. AND I
ALSO SERVICE THE MANAGER FOR THE
GSA. AS SUCH I'M EXCITED TO SEE
THE ASSEMBLY HOLD THIS HEARING
REVIEW SEGMENT ALL RIGHT
LEGISLATION WAS A BOLD STEP FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT CLIMATE ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
CHANGED ENORMOUSLY SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN. AS A SCIENCE BASED
PROGRAM SAID QUESTION NOT REMAIN
STATIC IT SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE
EVALUATED AND REFINED. AS WE
LEARN MORE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW
ABOUT WATER WORKS BUT HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO BEST MANAGE THE
RESOURCE. AND THAT'S WHAT I LIKE
TO OFFER A FEW THOUGHTS ABOUT
THE FUTURE. EXPECTATIONS FOR
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANNER. BY BOTH THE W. R.
EMPIRE PUBLIC IT WILL BE
DIFFICULT TO BE FRANK YEAH
DEFINITELY WATER RELIES ON
GROUNDWATER EXTRACTION OF COURSE
BUT IT ALSO INVOLVES A LOT OF
OTHER FACTORS THAT ARE SOMEWHAT
OUT OF GSA'S CONTROLLER THE
COUNTIES CONTROL SUCH AS WEATHER
EXTREMES SURFACE WATER
DIVERSIONS WHAT IMPACT OF
HISTORICAL FLOOD CONTROL AND
CHANNEL GEOMORPHOLOGY. THE MANY
NATURAL AND HUMAN STRESSORS ON
BOTH WATER RESOURCES AND
ECOSYSTEMS. COMPLICATE DECISION
MAKING ON ISSUES THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO OUR COMMUNITIES. THE
SOLUTIONS WILL BE NEVER QUICK
NOR EASY OR CHEAP. RIGHT NOW
DECISION MAKING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COULD USE MORE
QUANTITATIVE INFORMATION ON THE
INTERCONNECTEDNESS OF SURFACE
WATER AND GROUNDWATER AND BETTER
CHARACTERIZATION OF GROUNDWATER
DEPENDENT ECOSYSTEMS ARE
STATEWIDE RACES AS WELL AS
EXPANDED GUIDANCE FROM STATE
AGENCIES ON WHAT THOSE
INTERACTIONS MEAN FOR
GROUNDWATER PLANNING. BOB THAT'S
PROBABLY ONE OF THE LEAST
UNDERSTOOD- FACTORS OF THE
GROUNDWORK TO STAND ONLY
PLANNING EFFORT- I THINK NOT
ONLY FRUSTRATE OTHER LOCAL
AGENCIES AS WELL. AND SO MORE.
UNDERSTATEMENT AND GUIDANCE AND
AMBASSADOR HELP ALL. WE ALSO
WOULD APPRECIATE A GENERAL
CLIMATE CHANGE MODEL THAT'S
ACCEPTED BY THE STATE- AS ALSO
THE MANAGER FROM CLIMATE ACTION
PROGRAMME I OULD ECHO THAT
THROUGH CLIMATE ACTION PLAN AS
WELL- AND ONE THAT CAN BE SCALED
DOWN TO LOCAL CONDITIONS- THERE
ARE THRESHOLDS FOR CLIMATE
ACTION STATEWIDE- THEY'RE DONE
ON A LOCAL BASIS I HOPE OUR- AIR
QUALITY DISTRICTS CURRENTLY
REFINING THEIR SECRET
THRESHOLDS. AND THERE'S NO- I'M
OTHERS ACCEPTED METHODOLOGY- IT
WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE A MORE
UNIFORM APPROACH TO GIVE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THE FOUNDATION THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO CONSTANTLY
TAKE CLIMATE ACTION PANNING
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT A
POTENTIAL COURT CHALLENGES. AS
OREGON SAID THE IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS OF SIGMA ARE VERY STEEP
ESPECIALLY IN THE INITIAL YEARS.
THAT'S WERE RAPIDLY AND
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
QUALITY AND QUANTITY OF PROGRAMS
SUCH AS MONITORING AND DATA
COLLECTION AND BASE LINE
ANALYSIS. AND COORDINATION NOT
RICHARD RICH. MORE STATE FUNDING
IS ESSENTIAL TO ENSURING THE
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME OF LOCAL
PROGRAMS. AND I LIKE TO ECHO
SIERRA ISN'T DOLLARS COMMENTS
REGARDING THERE'S ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE ESPECIALLY FOR THE
UNIQUE ASPECTS OF PROPOSITION
TWO EIGHTEEN AS IT RELATES TO
SIX. LAST YEAR NOW. HI PUBLIC
EXPECTATIONS DEMAND FOR
IMMEDIATE AS A RESULT THE
CURRENT DROUGHT. LARA CONCEPTS
OF SUSTAINABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
YIELDS ARE APPLIED TO
GROUNDWATER BASINS OVER A VERY
LONG TIME BUT A FEW MONTHS OR
EVEN A FEW YEARS. THE PUBLIC MAY
NOT WANT TO WAIT TWENTY YEARS
FOR THE PLAN TO TAKE AFFECTED
THEIR WELLS ARE RUNNING DRY THIS
SUMMER. THIS IS WHERE THE TO PUT
THIS ORDER HAS TO BE A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH. THE COUNTY
ONLY TO TAKE IMMEDIATE STEPS TO
ALLEVIATE RESIDENTS COMMUNITIES
AND PRIVATE WATER SYSTEMS. IN
ORDER RUNNING OUT OF WATER
THAT'S MANDATED THE TROUT WATERS
THE PROBLEM WATER SHORTAGE TASK
FORCE. THE SAME TIME THE GSA
NEEDS TO ACT RESPONSIBLY TAKING
THE TIME IT NEEDS TO DEVELOP
IMPLEMENT AND EVALUATE EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS TO AVOID THE
UNDESIRABLE EFFECTS. OF
GROUNDWATER EFFECT- SOLUTION TO
GET ARE GOING TO COME QUICKLY.
THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO IN
THE INTERIM WHILE WE ARE TAKING
THE RESPONSIBLE STEP TO STARTING
AND COMING UP WITH SOLUTIONS FOR
THE LAW IN THE LONG TERM. THAT
WILL WHAT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND LIKE
THE OTHERS ON THE BILL CREDIT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THAT THE
ATTORNEYS MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MR MORRISON OF YOUR GREAT
WORDS AND LOVE ALL OF THE-
THINGS THAT YOU'RE DOING IN NAPA
COUNTY WE APPRECIATE IT. OKAY
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE-
NO I HAVE NO QUESTIONS NO ONE
FROM THE AUDIENCE. OKAY I THINK
THAT EUROPE FOR. YEAH. AWESOME I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT-
AGUIAR-CURRY SAID WHICH IS THANK
YOU TO ALL OF THE PRESENTERS
HERE TODAY WHO WERE SO HELPFUL.
IN HELPING US REALLY THINK ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE WITH THAT MAN WHERE
WE NEED TO GO TO GET TO
SUSTAINABILITY WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE DOING
THAT AND IF THEY'RE INDIVIDUALS
THE ROOM. WANT TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL START THERE AND
THEN WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE SO
IF YOU'RE WAITING TO CALL IN TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT NOW WOULD
BE A GREAT TIME. TO USE THE
PHONE LINES. WE'RE GOING TO
LIMIT PUBLIC COMMENT TO ONE
MINUTE SO WE HAVE TIME FOR
EVERYBODY WHO'S ON THE PHONE AND
IN PERSON PLEASE. LOG OUT AS
FAST AS I CAN. HELLO ANON WE CAN
HEAR YOU YEAH MY NAME IS-STEPHANIE- WHEN YOU GUYS ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE GROUND WATER
AND STUFF I DON'T THINK. ANY OF
YOU REALIZE THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL GROUND. WATER WATER
DISTRICTS OUT THERE THAT BOARD
MEMBERS. AND DISTRICT EMPLOYEES
ARE BYPASSING THEIR METERS. I
HAVE PROOF OF IT OKAY NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER TWO. WHY IS SEVEN
POINT SEVEN BILLION GALLONS.
WENT OUT TO THE PACIFIC OCEAN
TODAY. SECOND OF ALL WE'VE HAD
NINE. NINE BILLS PASSED. PROP
TWO OH FOUR PROP THIRTEEN PROP
TWELVE PROP. PROPOSITION FORTY
THIS ADDS UP ALL OF THIS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN OVER
THIRTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS. WHY
ARE WE DEALING WITH THIS NOW WHY
DIDN'T WE DEAL WITH IT BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AS OUR
POPULATION WAS GROWING. IT MAKES
NO SENSE WATER RESOURCES JUST
APPOINTED PEOPLE THEY'RE NOT
EVEN ELECTED. SO WHY ARE WE
ALLOWING THEM TO GUIDE US
THROUGH THIS. AND NOTHING IS
BEING DONE IT DOESN'T MAKE NO
SENSE NONE OF THIS MAKES SENSE
WATER IS THE MOST PRECIOUS
COMMODITY ON EARTH. THANK YOU.
IT LOOKS LIKE THERE ARE NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
ROOM SO WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. MODERATOR CAN YOU OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. CERTAINLY IF YOU HAVE A
PUBLIC COME UP PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AND THAT'S ONE ZERO WE'LL
GO NOW TO LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED THE MEMBERS- MESSAGING
YOU CAN USE- WITH THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS.
CAST CAP REPRESENTS OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND SMALL AND MID CAL
COUNTY FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
HAS WORKED. OVER FORTY YEARS TO
PRESERVE FAMILY SCALE
AGRICULTURE AND PROMOTE
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY WE
WERE A STRONG SUPPORTER OF TAKE
MY IT PASSED. AND OR OR DURING
THE PROCESS AND WE JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY-
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER IN THIS
HEARING. OUR LOCAL SMALL SCALE
AND UNDERSERVED- PRODUCING
FARMERS HAVE BEEN. LEFT OUT OF
THIS SIGMA CONVERSATION. ABOUT
UA ATION BY THE CLEAN WATER
ACTION REVIEWED OVER FOURTEEN
GSA'S AND ALL FAILED TO INCLUDE
SMALL SCALE FARMERS IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- WITHOUT THEIR
VOICES AT THE TABLE. THESE
FARMERS WILL NOT BE ALLOCATED
THE WATER THEY NEED TO SURVIVE-
THIS PROCESS- WE'RE REQUESTING A
TEN MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
SMALL SCALE IN HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED FARMER ENGAGEMENT.
TO ASSEMBLY ALLOW FOR THE
GREATER PARTICIPATION FOR THESE
FARMERS TO PARTICIPATE IN CHIANG
MAI. ENERGY ESSAYS AND WE HOPE
THAT ALL OF YOU WILL SUPPORT
THAT ASKIN AND SUPPORT. SMALL
SCALE FARMERS PARTICIPATING IN
WILL TAKE MUCH OF A- SURVIVE-
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS HEARING
AND. AND YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK
YOU KNOW. MY NEXT COME. THANKS
YOU ARE. LINE.
SIXTEEN AND- WE
GOT A LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I YOU SOUND FUZZY. YES
GOOD. OKAY. WELCOME BACK ACTIVE
WATER OR ACTIVE WHAT AT THE BACK
DROPS. IF YOU DON'T MENTION JEFF
IS ABOUT. OKAY ACTORS WATER BUT
WE ARE. IT'S NOT GOODNESS AT THE
SOMETHING. KEPT UNDER VERY
LITTLE TO NO ATTENTION TO
DEVELOP QUALITY AND A LOT. THAT. YEAH NOISE IS GETTING REALLY
TO HEAR I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ANY WAY TO RELIEVE THAT BUT YOU
MAY WANT TO SEND IN YOUR
COMMENTS TO MAKE SURE WE CAP IT. YEAH I. OKAY YEAH.
BOB.
MODERATOR NEXT COMMENT. WE'LL GO
TO LINE EXCUSE ME ONE SECOND
WHAT WE'RE GONNA LINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MEDICARE NUMBERS. AFTER THE
PHYSICIAN HOW CAN YOU SPEAK UP
JUST A LITTLE BIT YOUR LITTLE
HEART I. YEAH. IS THAT BETTER
THAT'S MUCH BETTER. OKAY GREAT-
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES JUST ONE AT- FIRST
THANK DAY COMMITTEE CHAIRS FOR
DECIDING TO HOLD ITS HEARING
AND- THEY COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR WORK DONE IN
ORGANIZING THE HEARING- AWFUL
NUMBER AGENCIES ARE
PARTICIPATING THE GFA EFFORTS
ACROSS THE STATE AND HARPER
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE LOCAL
AGENCY EFFORTS RELATED TO SIGMA.
ONE OF THE FOUNDATIONAL PILLARS
THE TAKE MY IS THAT
SUSTAINABILITY IS BEST TO CHEAP
LOCALLY WE APPRECIATE THAT D. W.
ARE IN THE STATE WATER BOARD
STAFF FOR CONTINUING TO SUPPORT
STATEMENT HAS-LOCALLY DRIVEN
PLANNING PROCESS AND FOR
REINFORCING THAT LOCAL
MANAGEMENT THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO KEEP GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY- WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE TO
WORK TO ENSURE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF TAKE MY
INCLUDING A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS APPROPRIATED
LAST YEAR. FOR SEGMENTAL
MEDITATION- LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO CREATED THE
MULTI BENEFIT LAND REPURPOSE
PROGRAM WHICH WILL HELP EASE THE
NECESSARY TRANSITION SOME MUST
UNDERGO TO CHEAT GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS ESTABLISHED
IN TECHNO WALTER PROMOTING OTHER
COMMUNITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS. CONTINUING TO
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES STRATEGIES
AND SOLUTIONS TO SUPPORT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN DEALING WITH
SOCIO ECONOMIC CHALLENGE
CONSEQUENCES THAT MAY RESULT
FROM CHANGES IN GROUNDWATER SUCH
AS PLANNED CALLING WILL BE
CRITICAL PARKLET COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE STATE ELECT-
AND AGRICULTURAL WATER USERS
GROWERS LANDOWNERS-
ENVIRONMENTAL DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY INTEREST MATTER
STAKEHOLDERS. ON IT SHE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY. IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NECK SUMMER. WELCOME A
LINE PLEASE AHEAD. HI MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBER MARK ON OF
WATERFOWL THE TWO BATES AND
WEBER LOS. I'M GLAD THAT THE-
IMPACTS THE MAN'S WETLANDS WERE
MENTIONED AGAINST SIGMA IT
DEFINITELY THREATENING TO REDUCE
MANAGED WETLAND HABITAT THAT
PARTIALLY OR WHOLLY DEPENDENT
UPON GROUNDWATER IT'S MOST
NOTABLY INCLUDES WETLANDS AND
THE TULARE BASIN AND GRASSLANDS
AREA SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AS WELL
AS THE WETLANDS OF- THE BUTTE.
VALLEY AND SISKIYOU COUNTY. BUT
FISH WILDLIFE OWNS WHAT BY AS WE
MENTIONED- EARLIER MAY ARE PRIME
ON AND UNDER SKATER FEDERAL
WATERFOWL HABITAT AGREEMENT.
THAT ESSENTIALLY REQUIRES
LANDOWNERS TO INTENSELY MANAGE
THEM ON ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. AS
ALL OF YOU- NO WE'VE LOST OVER
90% OF CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC
WETLANDS IN THE ONE EACH
REMAINING PROVIDES CRITICAL
HABITAT FOR WATERFOWL AND MANY
THREATENED AND ENDANGERED
SPECIES AS WELL AS RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PUBLIC.
THE STATE HAS ENTERED INTO
REGIONAL PLANS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND NONPROFIT
CONSERVATION GROUPS TO INCREASE
WETLAND ACREAGE- BUT ALSO HAS A
NO NET LOSS POLICY ON WHAT WENT
. BIG MAN WITH IMPLEMENTATION IS
. UNDERTAKING APPEARS TO BE
INCONSISTENT WITH THE STATE
POLICY- THE LOCAL GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT PLAN THUS FAR ARE NOT
FULLY CONSIDERING IMPACTS TO
MANAGE WETLANDS AND ARE
ESSENTIALLY TREATING THEM THE
SAME AS ANY OTHER LAND USE. WHAT
WHEN LANDOWNERS WHO CAN'T AFFORD
THE HIGHER MANAGEMENT COSTS WILL
BE FORCED TO PROVIDE MUCH FOR
QUALITY HABITAT FOR WILDLIFE OR
DRY AFTER WET WILLIE DO TIRE
LEAF CHANGES TO SIGMA
IMPLEMENTATION OR THE LAW ARE
NOT MADE AND- SO I WANT TO POINT
THAT OUT AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING AND- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO COMMENT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WEEK NOT A LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRWOMAN POWER QUE HAN
AND AGUILAR CURRY THIS IS LUCAS
FRERICHS ON BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY I'D LIKE TO OFFER A
FEW COMMENTS AND OBSERVATIONS
FROM NATURE CONSERVANCY WITH
REGARD TO IMPLEMENTATION OF
SIGMA AND A VARIETY OF GSA
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. IN
CONTRAST TO THE OVER DRAFTED
TWENTY TWENTY BASINS MANY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO GSA THEY'RE CLAIMING
THAT THEIR BASES ARE SUSTAINABLE
BECAUSE THEY ARE WITHIN THE
SUSTAINABLE YIELD THAT AS A
RESULT MANY BASINS ARE NOT
ACTIVELY PURSUING PROJECT
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS ON THEIR PLAN
UNTIL THE GROUND WATER
CONDITIONS IN THE BASIN
DETERIORATE FURTHER TRIGGERING
ACTIONS- ADDITIONALLY MOST YES
PEAS ARE USING HISTORIC
SUSTAINABLE YIELD INSTEAD OF
PROJECTED SUSTAINABLE YIELD WHEN
ESTABLISHING SUSTAINABLE
MANAGEMENT CRITERIA AND PRODUCT
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS- JUST ANIMAL
MANAGEMENT. REMAINS MORE
FAVORABLE DEMAND. MANAGEMENT AS
WELL. THERE'S ALSO BEEN VERY
LITTLE TO NO CONSIDER. BROWN AND
ON DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES-
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS AS
WELL AS TRIBAL INTERESTS WHEN
ESTABLISHING SUSTAINABLE
MANAGEMENT CRITERIA- SECOND
CLASS POINT HERE MANY DOMESTIC
WELLS ARE LIKELY TO GO DRY UNDER
THE MINIMUM THRESHOLD
ESTABLISHED IN MANY BASINS. AND
ONLY A HANDFUL OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BASINS HAVE WELL
MITIGATION PLAN IN PLACE. AND
FINALLY AT THE FINAL COMMENT IS
THAT THE MAJORITY OF GSA BOARDS
ARE DEVOID OF REPRESENTATIVES
FROM DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THE ENVIRONMENTAL INTERESTS AND
TRIBAL INTERESTS. THANK YOU TO
YOU BOTH AND YOUR STAFF FOR
HOSTING TODAY'S HEARING WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOCUSING ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANKS SO MUCH HAVE A GOOD
DAY. THANK YOU. IN MEXICO LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MEMBERS WOULD BE TO LEAVE I
WOULD ME WATER SOME WE
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
CONVENING DISAPPOINTING HEARING
AN ECHO THE POINTS RAISED BY
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE WORK WITH SOME OF
THE MOST IMPACTED COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE FROM GROUND WATER OVER
PUMPING. WE OFFER APPRECIATE THE
DILIGENT WORK FROM B. TO B. R.
IN REVIEWING THE JUST PEACE ON
THE ROBUSTUS TODAY THEY MUST
CLEARLY MUST RE SUSTAINABLE
HOLDEN A TWENTY YEAR TIMELINE
ADDRESS THE INTERESTS AND
RESULTS A LITTLE TIME. AS
MENTIONED- EARLIER TODAY CANNOT
RACE TO THE BOTTOM ANY LESSON
ALL BENEFICIAL USES AND USERS
INCLUDING DOMESTIC WELL USERS
ESPECIALLY WITH AND.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. MY WORK
ALONGSIDE THE HUMAN RIGHTS. CAN
A PLAN FOR HUNDREDS OF WELLS DRY
A JURISDICTION OR JUST BE AT TO
BE OUR RACE THE GET SAVE MY AT
MY THEY'RE JUST HOW. GOING DRY
IT NOTHING AND GIVEN THE STATE
LAWMAKERS RIGHT TO WATER OR
ALTER INSTITUTE THE NEED
MEDICATION OTHER. ONE BY FOR IN
OUR PRO CONTENT FOR LONG TERM SO
WE WHEREWE HAVE RESPONSIBLE. I
COVERED OF. WORK FROM BECAUSE
COMMITTEE LOSE ACCESS TO
SPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF INCREASING
COMING. THEY MIGHT NEED IT JOHN
CORONATION AND APPRECIATE ABOUT
OF THE ABOUT HALF AN INCH
STRUGGLE. WE SUBMITTED WRITTEN
COMMENTS OF THE HEARING BUT WE
ALSO FIND THAT APARTMENT AND
LEGISLATURE COLLAB WORK TOGETHER
FOR TIME AND I FROM THE TO LACK
IN ABILITY. INCLUDING STATE
INCREASE WATER CALL AND KIND
WATER LEVEL WHAT. DOMESTIC WELL
INTO MITIGATION PROJECT AND
FINALLY ENGAGE FROM ALL AND THE
BAY WITH A POLITICAL ON THE AT
THAT WE GET THE TECHNICAL
BECAUSE- THROUGH A LONG
COMMUNITY NUMBER SEVEN AND- THE
TRULY AND DEDICATION. BILLION
ARCONIC THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE
. EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CATHERINE THREE WITH THE
CALL STATE A OF COUNTIES-
REPRESENTING ALL EIGHT
CALIFORNIA. I LIKE TO THINK THAT
THE TWO AND IT'S THE STATE. FOR
THEIR AND BOTH THAT AND
EMPHASIZING THE AND STATE WHY
NATURE GROUNDWATER. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
ACCOUNT MEMBERS AND STAFF WILL
FRAME FROM OF THIS COMP LAW- WE
REALLY FOR TO CAN TO WORK WITH
YOUR SO AND THE BY COMMITTEE
THIS YEAR AND IN THE AS WE START
TO REALLY ON THEM. CHALLENGES
POSED BY THE LAW. JANITOR
WORKING HARD TO JUST WATER
DURING THE ONGOING FROM CONTENT
USE SO WE ARE OF WATER AND- BUT
WE HEAR THAT FUNDING IS
NECESSARY FOR THE OF SECOND AND
GRAY TO TAKE A REAL A- FOR WAYS
TO HELP LOCAL A WITH FUNDING I
THINK IS A- OF ONE. OF ITS FROM
AND WE TO WORKING PART WITH THE
STATE AND LOCAL. TO CEASE MY- TO
FULLEST BUT- THANK AGAIN FOR THE
REALLY AFRAID YOUR THANK YOU.
AND THAT WHAT A LINE. FIVE IS
GOING. GOOD MORNING CHAIR VICE
ON MY THANK YOU POSTING YEAR MY
NAME IS GO TO A- OF YOUR COMMON
ON THE OF CLEAN WATER. AND
ALIGNMENT COMING APPROVAL BY
LEADERS CONTEST PROJECT IN THE
CAR. AND COMMUNITY LOT OF SAN.
WHAT TO SHOW US UP TO DEPARTMENT
AWAY RESEARCH. QUALITY AND EXAM
AND- ON THE JERRY OF THE
CREATURE ILL HAS. BE AFTER
TAKING THIS TOWARDS. DRINKING
WATER USE THAT. BECAUSE A VERY
DEEP ME OF THE TRYING TO TRAIN
ON THE- CAN SUPPLY. I'M PROVIDED
COMMENTS. AND GAINES MAN AND
CONCENTRATION OF DRINKING WATER
YOU THE- AFTER THAT THE
DEPARTMENT TO. CLOSE ATTENTION
SUBJECT AND EFFICIENT AND
EFFICIENCIES I THINK MOST
IMPORTANTLY PROVIDE GUIDANCE
BELIEVES AGENCY. WE ALSO WANT TO
FLY THE IMPORTANCE OF IMPROVE
DETAIL REPORT JAMES DATA ACCESS
AND THE AVAILABILITY FROM JAZZ
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT MÀ I AM
HUNGRY HUMAN RIGHTS FOR. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION COULD
COMMENT DAY I THANK THE HOSTS
AND SHARING. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK
AND GO. ARMY MEXICO TO THIRTY
THREE IS GOING. THIRTY LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING BY GOOD
MORNING OKAY THE WHITE OF OUR
KING CHAIRWOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY
MEMBERS FROM BOTH COMMITTEE IN
NAME IS JIMMY THE LOCK AND I AM
DIVIDE PRESIDENT OF THE FAMILY
TREE INDIAN WATER AUTHORITY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS TODAY. A
DAY WATER AUTHORITY IS A
SOVEREIGN TRIBAL ENTITY BETTER
BY THE CONGRESS TO PRESERVE ANY
WRECKS THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF
OUR PEOPLE THE WATER AUTHORITY
WHICH CREATED BY THE LOCAL AREA
ALL. PALMER WE CALL IN FACT THE
QUEBEC. THAT SORT IT UP A
TYPICAL ABOUT AND MANAGE THE
LEAST PROVIDE UNDER THE FAMILIES
FOR. IN THE WATER SETTLEMENT.
MANY YEAR ARE FACED A LITTLE.
LEADING TO A BUDGET YOU TAKE.
WILDLIFE IN CLEARWATER I'M FOR
THE CHANGE WITH THAT DELIVERY.
HE STATE LAW. AND FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES THE GREAT THE DALLAS
REYES LIVE WORK INCIDENTALLY THE
COULD. IN THE LATE LATE NIGHT
PIZZA. AND THE CALL THE OTHER
TWO CENTURY. THE VERSION THE
BETH AND TRY UP. COUPLE MORE
DIFFICULT FIVE YOU SEPARATE HAVE
LIVE. CARE QUARTERS THE PIPE.
TECH EVERY WATER SUPPLY IS ONE
WITH BIG TO YOU TO. THE END OF
THE GOT CALL TO. IN COVERAGE OF
THE TWO THINGS. UNDERSTATEMENT
AT THE PORT TO BE THAT YOU'D PAY
FOR THE UP WITH CALIPHATE WATER.
VALUE. IT IS A PROFOUNDLY VALUE
BASED AND ONLY UP. 80% OF THE
COULD. TRAVEL RESERVATION AND
LAND COVER AND BY INDIA WATER.
IMMEDIATELY BAND CONCERT PROP.
FORTY QUICKLY OF THE BASE. THE
REMAINING. THIRTY OF THE BASE
AND COVERED. BY THE COULD W. BY
THE END OF THE THAT. UNDER THE
LOCAL AB PEOPLE. I'M OF. THE
PROVIDE THAT BECAUSE PATIENT IS
I THINK MY. I'M SORRY IF THEY
THANK YOU IN THE TRIBES IT OF
THE EGGMAN BOTH OF THAT THE
THIRTY WITH WATER A THE
CALIFORNIA. TO BE RESPECTED
PEOPLE UNFORTUNATELY HOW THE
LOCAL EACH. HAVE YOU FEEL BETTER
OF THAT FUND REQUIREMENT WOULD
BE KERRY OUT AND THE KIA P.
APPROACH THE WATER AUTHORITY
PACIFIC. LIFTED GOVERNOR OF THE
ENTITY THAT TO BE ACTING AS THE
- UNIT THEY- ENTITIES CONCORD
THE LOOK G. HOW OFFERED THE
AUTHORITY IN THE- MEANINGLESS
AFTER. TO PARTICIPATE IN. OF THE
- IN THAT IN THE REJECTED THOSE
OFFERS. WHICH IT WOULD HAVE TO
GET. IT IN THE PARTY WITH THEIR
WATER RIGHT AFTER CONTROL. OF
WHAT A THE WATER. WHO INCREASE.
FUNDING AT THE TO THE BY. SURE.
WE FIGURED THAT ARE POORLY WITH
THEIR WATER RIGHTS ARE ONCE
AGAIN BEING DISREGARDED AND
PLAYED THAT WITH INDIA WATER
THIRTY BANDS RESPECT ALL ON W.
FROM BIG LAKE BAKER PAPA WATER
SURFACE CALIFORNIA WATER COULD
BOARD TO WORK COLLABORATING WITH
THE IN THE WATER BAND. AND TO
CARRY OUT WHAT YOU. THAT THE
FOR. THANK REVEALED WATER RIGHT
BE RESPECTED PULL THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR TIME THANK YOU. NEXT
SPRING COURT ALIGNED ONE PLEASE
AHEAD. ONE THIRTY NINETY AND-
GROUNDWATER COMMITTEE YOU WE CAN
YOU- EXCELLENT READING FUHRMAN
APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
GLOBE ARTICLE. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HASN'T SIGNIFICANTLY
INVESTED IN WATER STORAGE SINCE
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHEN
JERRY BROWN WAS GOVERNOR THE
FIRST TIME AROUND. THIS IS AN
ERA OF LIMITS AND WE ALL HAD
BETTER GET USED TO IT BROWN SAID
UPON BEING ELECTED GOVERNOR IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE EMBRACING
THE SMALL IS BEAUTIFUL WAY OF
THINKING. SINCE THEN
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION HAS
DOUBLED AS HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEMANDS AND MORE THAN 50% OF THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES ARE
ALLOWED TO FLOW OUT TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY. OUT OUT THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY TO THE PACIFIC
OCEAN RATHER THAN BUILD A
DESPERATELY NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
COLLECT AND STORE WATER DURING
THE WET YEARS GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED INTO LAW. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN A NEW WATER
CONSERVATION ACT THAT WILL LIMIT
EACH CITIZEN TO JUST FIFTY TO
FIFTY FIVE GALLONS OF WATER PER
DAY BY TWENTY FIFTY. THE TRUTH
IS THAT 50% OF CALIFORNIA'S
WATER SUPPLY ALREADY GOES
TOWARDS ENVIRONMENTAL PURPOSES
OF THE REST OF THE WATER ONLY
ABOUT 10% GOES TO URBAN USES FOR
HOMES AND BUSINESSES. AND 40% IS
USED BY AGRICULTURE A FULL 50%
OF THE STATE'S WATER IS USED FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PURPOSES. SINCE
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
VOTERS HAVE APPROVED EIGHT WATER
BOND TOTALING MORE THAN THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS. ACCORDING TO
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND APPROVED THE CONSTRUCTION OF
TWO MORE DAM. YEAH ON MAY NINTH
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. JERRY
BROWN SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
AND WE CAN MAKE WATER STATION A
WAY OF LIFE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH-
WHAT GATES FOR FUNERAL. ON TO
THE NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU- MORE
CALMER BECAUSE AND THEN. NINE
AND CURRENTLY NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR THAT THEN WE WILL
CONCLUDE THE HEARING THANK YOU.
HELLO.